foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Robert Hess alongside me is my good
friend danielski Donya The World Is
Still buzzing after dingley wren's World
Championship Victory just yesterday how
are you feeling how are you doing man
it's been a while it has been a while
I'm so glad to be back together Robert
you did an amazing job on the commentary
so I can have the tournament and I'm not
just saying that to stay your friend I
was on the edge of my seat or like the
edge of my bed uh the last couple of
rounds the tie Breakers were
scintillating we're all hungover from
the world championship but the Chess
World ain't stopping it ain't letting up
time for the next tournament
yeah these players are going to sit in
this field today but will dingley Ren
fresh off his World Championships
Victory you think we'll see his name in
the plan
everything ding says seems to be so
wholesome he said that he wanted to
visit Turin Italy uh and see a match of
his favorite soccer team Juventus so
this is the one time I'll say I actually
wish for dingler end to take a rest take
a couple of weeks off tour Europe and uh
just chill after his victory but hey I
won't complain if we do
I won't complain either but he does
deserve a break but the Chess World will
not get a break from some top level
entertaining non-stop chess because as
you see the tour schedule for the
Champions chess tour Magnus Carlson took
the air things Masters the chesso
Masters were won by Hikaru Nakamura who
stormed through the losers bracket
taking down Magnus and then five down a
car won it twice and today Begins the
chess kid cup play in phase we know that
the main event the divisions will take
place May 22nd through 26th you will be
there in Norway uh Donna you're gonna
have fun with that one I know you
haven't been to Norway
I've never been to Norway it's always a
country that I've wanted to visit
obviously my brother went there a couple
of years ago said it was the most
beautiful place that he's ever visited
so obviously my main role will be the
commentator tournament not to look at
the beautiful fjords and sights of Oslo
but hey you can do more than one good
thing on a trip but we're not there yet
that's coming your way May 22nd to 26th
but first you have to get there at least
a lot of players have to qualify for uh
the chess kid Cup final but it's great
that the CCC train Robert has left the
station I can't believe we're already
two majors in uh and here comes the
third one
yeah two majors in and some people are
majorly pleased with their results
because in our tour standings there will
be some familiar names at the top Hikaru
Nakamura Magnus Carlson Fabiano caruana
no real surprise there but do any other
names stand out on this list for you
Dania
do any names that not really I mean we
don't have uh too many strong players in
the CCT unfortunately most top players
are deciding to skip it uh but obviously
I'm looking at the Battle of generations
there's the fabies the wesleys the
Mainstays and a lot of the younger
players have demonstrated incredible
speed and incredible consistency
throughout the majors thus far I'm
looking at Notre back of dusotorov Alexi
Serrano who always seems to come up on
top in title Tuesdays and in chess.com
rapid events Robert one of the most
scintillating things about the CCT thus
far is its unpredictability nobody has
an easy ride and you could lose to
absolutely anybody
it's true and based on the ding to Palm
Street match we've come to expect the
unexpected like Magnus Carlson not
taking part in the chess kid cup he will
have to re-qualify for division four and
no breaks for him but let's look at this
the next bit of the standings here
vladis over tammyv he did beat Magnus
Carlson in the chessful Masters that was
very impressive and the means happened
to buy he won division three Sam seven
won division three at the first event
the air things Masters so we have some
winners of the lower divisions and we
also have a teenager in Dennis lastimic
and another in elevator ferrugia I was
gonna say a couple teenagers there
alireza farusia cannot be slept on
obviously uh his chest trajectory has
been the path of a lot of rumors
spreading and a lot of speculation but
alireza has remained relatively active
in online chess let's not forget where
he is in the classical uh rating
standings he's still a beast he's still
very much capable of qualifying and I
definitely want to see alireza in the
finals of a major obviously he will have
to jump through a lot of Hoops to get
there and uh in the previous major he
failed to jump through a hoop named uh
Lexi Serrano
he did indeed and let's not forget about
prognando we missed not to mention that
teenage Superstar from India so big
names in the second bit of the standings
here but let's tell what's gonna happen
today because today is the chess kid cup
playing that is what is going to occur
we will have nine rounds of 10 minutes
plus two seconds per move the top 74
will advance the match play and when we
get to match play there will just be two
games of 10 minutes plus two seconds per
move with 53 players advancing to the
chess kid cup so Dania we'll have many
participants to start but it will narrow
down by the end it will indeed this is a
brutal event and like I said earlier you
can lose to write about anybody round
one pairings are already incredibly
strong you have to survive nine rounds
of the Swiss stage obviously the time
control is one that you should be used
to uh from previous play-ins as well as
from the RCC finals ten plus two strikes
a really good delicate balance between
you know still having the speed of a
Blitz game uh but giving players a
chance to think in critical moments and
it's really produced a very high quality
of play it's also produced tons of
prizes for so many different players
Robert not just you know the top five a
lot of people get a chance to score a
lot of cash
and fans have been very excited about
these Swiss events so many superstars
playing let's look at some of the names
that are in the field today because we
know Hikaru and Fabi they can't play
today they're already qualified through
but Lavon aronian Liam lay trying to
make it back to division one fedo save
the big fish Anish giri your Tata steel
2023 winner we've been talking about
farrusia but Donya look at all of these
names here in the field
Matthias blue Bob and of course
Alexander Bortnick who's one of the most
dangerous players uh to play in any
rapid or Blitz event and his pedigree
needs no elaboration but obviously we're
gonna follow a niche I commentated with
them the first half of the world
championship so now I'm rooting for him
uh I'm not going to keep it a secret man
aronian Lim fetusaev and all of them are
already gonna face Grandmasters in the
very first round
yeah and on Drake and we can't forget
that name he is a star online he is
super dangerous but let's talk about the
format for the Swiss stage because we're
starting to Swiss before eventually we
get to The Knockout later in the month
74 players will advance the match play
it's open to Grand Masters and the top
three from Monday qualifiers 10 minutes
plus two seconds per move it's a rapid
time control and in traditional chest
storing we will have one point for a win
half a point for a draw so that is
standard scoring in chess events Dunya I
am super stoked we talked about notable
players and that was just a partial a
very small part of the list for every
one we named there there are 10 more
Grandmasters in the field this is going
to be an awesome event it is indeed that
that is one of my favorite things about
commentating uh the Swiss stage of any
tournament particularly the CCT
qualifiers which is that we get to
introduce chess fans to lesser-known GMS
we get to see lesser known GM shining
and perhaps even qualifying to one of
the top divisions uh and that's amazing
because that's how you find new players
to root for that's how you find new
stories and new narratives uh you
stumble across a GM that you never heard
of and you realize hey this guy's not so
bad let me look at his other games let
me follow his other performances and
nowadays that's how we identify Rising
Stars they might not have an eye-popping
feeding rating Robert but they
definitely have eye-popping performances
in a lot of online events people like
Dennis lazovic for example
yeah same old nerdiskey but new
narratives today and we'll see if we
will have a shining star somebody who
will break through the elite of the
Chess World and make their way to
division one just like Ralph mametov did
for the air things Masters division one
he's been a rapid Beast for many years
but he finally broke through made it to
division one and he almost took down
Wesley so in the process so this event
is about to get underway we do have many
strong players in this field not just
your levana rhodians and all the reasons
but many Grandmasters who are waiting in
the wings looking to take down those top
players there's a Target on their back
it's not going to be easy but it sure is
going to be fun it is indeed and unlike
a title Tuesday where you need you know
seven and a half or eight out of nine uh
to make your way into sometimes even the
uh the top five sorry it's 11 rounds so
you need something like nine out of
eleven uh which sometimes doesn't even
get you into the top five because the
field is so strong you need a lot less
points Robert which means we see top
players taking a little bit less risk in
the earlier rounds because it's less
essential to you know go three out of
three or four out of four a draw here
and there even an early round loss is
not the end of your tournament it's far
from the end of the tournament but the
downside of that Robert is even if you
lose and you're off to a bad start you
see freaking Ray Robson playing against
Vladimir frederasev on 0.5 out of three
sometimes
no yeah that is crazy the pairings that
we get in these fields where as you said
some really big names will take part in
the first round and part of it is
because some of these players don't play
much rapid chess online so you'll see
and I mentioned this to you off screen
Donna that career chefchenko his rapid
rating on chess.com was something like
24.50 he's almost 2700 over the board
classical chess he is an absolute star
he now plays for Romania and you will
not want to face him if you're some
26.50 you don't want to face off against
crystalchenko there are other big names
as we're showing on screen we have
bluebound Bortnick those are some of
those less heralded names in terms of
classical chess but Bluebell made his
way to the Fisher random World
Championship top eight he was playing
live and he was playing the best in the
world so even players that may have two
six to start their rating they will be
able to take down those two seven pluses
the super GMS yeah consistency and
solidity two skills that are so crucial
in these qualifiers can't get too high
with the highs or too low with the lows
and Matthias Blue album has exactly the
kind of makeup of a GM who you would
expect to qualify great opening
repertoire uh doesn't get tilted able to
defeat really any of the top players
which he's done very regularly uh in
chess.com Blitz and title Tuesdays and
as you said I mean their rating is
important we expect players like LaVon
aronian and you know Anish Geary alireza
to qualify more often than the GMS in
the 2600s but that's the scintillating
thing about these qualifiers you just
never know who's going to emerge on top
and on that note Robert I think the
games have officially begun
okay so let's choose a game I'll let you
pick because I'm a good friend I'm a
good uh you know try to be collaborative
here so where should we start there's so
many big names how are you going to
choose
how are we going to choose this is one
of the most difficult things of
commentating I get that stress uh and
that fomo from not choosing the most
interesting game I'm looking at Arjun
Eric Isis board and you know visually
looks like he might be in a little bit
of rubble
okay so let's dive into any game of your
choosing you mentioned origin era geissi
so let's Dive Right into that because
our generic icy was in division one in
the air things Masters and we see he has
the black side of this position wait
what is going on how is there a bishop
I'm telling you
what what is happening this was a king's
Indian too this was a pretty normal
opening that went completely Haywire if
we could rewind a couple of moves as
Arjun contemplates uh his next move he
played this Knight C6 move uh in in the
king's Indian which is not common the
Knight made its way to E5 how did the
bishop go from E5 to D4 well here's how
Arjun put it there he played C5 F F4 the
bishop was chased and normally you take
the Knight of these types of positions
here the bishop sinks its teeth into D4
but Arjun might have underestimated uh
Muhammad Shah's last move which is
Knight to E2 hitting that Bishop which
you don't normally want to lose in these
types of structures
this just looks bad for black white
could not Castle the bishop on D4 made
sure the king could not get to G1 you
cannot Castle through or into check and
what's a good way of getting your king
castle by taking the piece that's
stopping you from doing it and that
Bishop is so essential to Black's
defensive stance because it's the G7
Square the H6 square and white will be
able to push E5 if that Bishop is
removed from the board so Bishop G4 I
think that's a great choice but Queen A4
check maybe that is what Argent
underestimated the queen gets out of the
pin with check and if the bishop drops
back to D7 the queen slides not to D1
but a square like B3 White's taking that
Bishop on D4 and Arjun aragaisy is in
huge trouble yeah it would not be an
exaggeration to say that Archer might be
borderline lost here uh if he doesn't
play perfectly and even if he does Queen
drops back to B3 I thought maybe Queen
C2 was a little bit more accurate uh to
be able to slide the queen over to F2
later on in the game and hit the pawn on
D4 so Arjun trying his best to engineer
some counter play on The Queen side
Bishop D2 I think he wants Bishop F2
check that might be another reason why
you wanted to put the queen on it on C2
that's such a good find by you the queen
B3 was much more natural and since
you're going after a pawn you're
attacking B7 but you're not taking care
of your own pieces Bishop D2 Bishop F2
check it distracts the king away so
you're trading dark Square Bishop for
dark Square bishop and that is way
better for black than giving up that
Bishop for a knight even if it costs him
a pawn this is worth it so done that is
great awareness from you and from our
generic icy and this may allow him to
stay afloat because if he gave up that
Bishop for the night and didn't get
anything returned I mean his position
was terrible
yeah it was and that's exactly what
happens now the bishop is still in
trouble it can be chased to The Rook F1
but at least you have a little bit more
Spice in the position Queen to A6
actually comes to mind that threatens
Bishop A4 something tells me Arjun is
going to wheel his way out of trouble
which is what a lot of these top players
do they're able to think on their feet
they're able to engineer Creative
Solutions in difficult situations I
think this is starting to move in the
right direction for Mr eridicey and just
to show a quick line after Queen A6 if
white tries to stop that pin with Bishop
C2 Knight takes E4 it comes to mind come
on take my knight I dare you I hung my
peace but then there's Bishop A4 at the
end winning the White Queen pinning and
winning that is devastating that is
totally devastating that would win the
queen you can't go Knights uh you can't
go Bishop C2
if you don't go Bishop C2 well what do
you do not so easy to make a decision
but Archen drops the screen back to C7
maybe he was worried about some E5
Advance now I'm curious what he's gonna
do on Rook F1 uh maybe just drop the
bishop back to D4 and maybe he's saying
listen you already moved your king so
I'm gonna get long-term counter play
against your king when it's in the
center the knight from F6 can jump into
G4 so very hard to predict how this game
is going to go Robert maybe a good
opportunity for us to look at some of
the other top boards okay I agree with
you that at least he got a little
something the white king cannot castle
that gives him some hope so where should
we go to next there's too many big names
for me to pick one
let's go to lavon's game he is facing
off against Spanish
uh who is known to many chess fans as a
noted Spanish language streamer uh very
strong very strong Grandmaster and this
is exactly what I'm talking about right
he's 25 50 feet a but I would absolutely
not be surprised if he scored a couple
of Victories over some of the top guys
but I think he's in trouble here this
looks like a roaster limo gone really
really wrong for black structurally
speaking oh that Queen side is ugly
um yeah I know this type of double
isolated ponds and then white has B3 and
D3 pawns meaning that if your C Pawn
ever moves I get to capture it for free
this is really bad for black here and
it's no surprise that Lavon aronian he
is taking strategic matters but also
tactical ones Rook G3 was attacking the
H6 Pawn the King goes up to H7 to get
out of a pin but look at Levon go it's a
principle of not just two weaknesses
many weaknesses and he's just going
forward with all of his pieces Donna
this looks not pleasant at all and
that's an understatement for black and
the Knight can come out to G4 you're
absolutely right a Hallmark of these top
players is their ability to use both
sides of the board to their advantage
right now Lavon has left last queen side
pawns alone but guess what the moment
black tries to drive the Knight into the
defense let's say Knight F6 white can
make this subtle move Queen F2 and black
is experiencing Mega problems with his
C5 Pawn so I don't I just don't see
Ibarra saving this he's under pressure
in so many different ways also the clock
is already down to five minutes he's
doing his is best to trade pieces but
Lavon man he is playing this like a
hyper bullet game did somebody tell him
the time control is ten plus two not
game in 15 seconds well this actually
was his what his was doing last time
around when he qualified for the chessel
Masters division one he was playing at a
lightning quick Pace sometimes making
errors he had a game against Liam lay
where he probably should have won but he
played a bit too quickly but he had a
great score there and if you look at
this position Black's pawns isolated a
pawn isolated E Pawn double isolated C
pawns it's an eyesore and I don't need
my glasses to understand that Black's
Pawn structure is terrible and that
white is having all the fun and gonna
poke and prod at them they will they
will indeed Lavon and sustain the
pressure eval bar dropped a little bit
but I think Lavon has this under perfect
control let me tell you another player
who has things under perfect control and
each giri who I mentioned at the start
super excited to a niche to see a niche
playing he faces off against Israeli Jam
Avital borohovski so let's go to that
game because I've been staring at that
position out of the corner of my eye
Robert for a while and I still cannot
make heads or tails of it it seems like
a niche is better what do you make of
this crazy end game that they are in
White having just captured a Pawn on e4
in order to solidify the Knight on D5
obviously the bishop could not have been
captured because the Rook on D1 is
undefended I had to count quickly and it
is even material it doesn't look like it
because white is missing an a pawn and
what has these doubled e pawns but you
see in each Geary now join us on camera
hi Anish I know you can't hear us I'm
good to see you again buddy uh I think
he's going to say hello to some past
pawns I mean look at this these A and B
pawns will storm up the board in the
future the E4 Pawn is targeted and very
weak this King on F2 even though Queens
are off the board it's not the safest
King in the world and if you the threat
was Bishop takes E3 check and the king
would have been dragged out to a bad
Square so uh now in this position the E4
Pawn is likely to be targeted and won by
black
it is indeed an English is so good as
are all top players at massaging these
types of advantages you might even see
black uh slow roll this and play a move
like G6 or H6 and kind of toss the ball
back into White's Court
uncharacteristically though he's a
little bit low on time he's low five
minutes and what what does Avital want
he probably wants to coordinate his
pieces as much as possible I don't even
know what White's next move is going to
be because Bishop takes Bishop merely
adds oil onto the fire it sends the
Knight where it wants to go anyway uh so
Avital just kind of Treading Water uh
trying to make or Nation to making as
many decisions as possible and to get
lower on time Anish he's not Rusty per
se Robert but maybe a little bit less
experienced uh in the grander scheme of
things in online events yeah he hasn't
been playing as much lately he does play
in title Tuesdays all the time and he
scores quite decently there and he's
just trying to figure out at what point
can I go after and win the E4 Pawn I
think a very quick instructive thing for
people is that taking on D1 and taking
on e4 you win upon at first but you
actually might just lose the the game in
those positions because after the swap
Rooks Bishop E4 Knight takes E4 just
this forcing sequence I will see The
Rook come out to d8 with check and the
big problem is you've sold one Pawn but
Rook d8 Rook D7 at the end and then
there's gonna be a swap of dark Square
Bishops F7 G7 H7 all are In Harm's Way
this is not the way you go for black
nope and I'm just gonna show the rest of
the line on the analysis board the
Bishops are swapped on an F7 is captured
and all of this stemmed from greed right
all of this stemmed from giving away an
open file in order to take a pawn that's
already condemned so it's not just about
blindly taking on e4 you have to do it
while maintaining control of crucial
files so instead Anish she did in fact
play G6 which is a move that I brought
up as a kind of example of a
semi-weighting move we might also see
him finish his architectural design on
the king side with H7 H5 uh but yeah he
brings his King up so he's gonna tread
water here keep the tension and try to
find the perfect moment to release that
tension on the D file on keep his
Advantage going in the end game yeah so
Anis he's just trying to work the oh
Knight D5 that made the Eva very unhappy
uh for white I wonder if you can just
take it and this is one of those
examples where you have a good night
against a not great Bishop because that
Bishop on G2 is staring into its own
pawn and that Knight will be anchored on
a dark square and oh King did D6 block
hating a pass pong with your king that
is great in the end game and by the way
A5 A4 B5 B4 A3 and so on that's going to
become a queen
oh it's totally coming there he goes
Avital desperately trying to engineer
counter play on the other side of the
board he's trying to open the H file I
think it's just coming too slowly and a
niche can probably continue pushing he
takes on E3 uh we'll probably see him go
B5 at some point I don't know if it was
totally necessary to trade Bishops at
that juncture I don't know if it's gonna
change anything in a very instructive
example Robert of a case in which a past
Pawn brings you absolutely no benefit
because it's totally blockaded by a king
that's it's in a dark square and the
absence of a dark scored Bishop for
white is really what eliminates any
chance of counter play I think Anish is
going to take this to Victory but a lot
of technique left to be shown here I
think the best move for white is taking
the D5 pawn and throwing it off the
board that gives your Bishop uh some a
really nice diagonal and oftentimes I
was saying this throughout the world
championship that these top players
Grandmasters they would give up material
for play White has no activity to speak
of but that is why amitaborkovski is
trying to open up the H file but good
luck to you you're not getting anywhere
and what is getting somewhere is Black's
queen size Pawn so I think that Anish
Gary has a pretty simple task ahead of
him I would be very surprised if he
doesn't win this game
I would I would as well we're going to
leave a niche to his own devices I'm
looking around uh the horn some other
Crazy Games Vladimir fetise have an axel
Bachmann are in a crazy tactical
struggle I think we need to go to that
game right now because Vladimir far to
save is in the midst of either playing a
brilliancy or crashing and burning I
think it's the LA I think it's the
former oh my goodness the smokes the
last move D7 giving up his Queen in two
different ways because his past Pawn is
going to become a queen and her Royal
Highness is going to deliver checkmate
we gotta unpack this and Rewind two
moves ago because I just say I've had
these dark squares on the king side but
black has the equivalent battery staring
at G2 looks like Axel has things under
relative control he plays Rook to EA
grabbing the open file that is safe
starts with the deflection sacrifice
Rook to E2 look at how many things The
Rook is doing it's protecting G2 and
it's deflecting The Rook on E8 obviously
you can't take so Axel thought that he
had better save outsmarted Rook F7 and
if you take on E8 no big deal Queen
takes it I'm holding on no D7 hitting
the Rook threatening promotion White is
coming from all sides Robert this is
classic Vladimir fettuccess right here
and all black can do is deliver a couple
of meaningless checks and resign yeah
you just get a few checks and that's it
and this could already be our game of
the day I know we're starting with the
first round here but that was some sick
tactical Wars when you give up your
queen it can be captured by two
different pieces but you're the one
delivering Checkmate that's amazing
stuff from federal save we're not
surprised what what happened
there's talk in the game of the day
there's another crazy position it's very
very similar we gotta go there too it's
a tourizaga against Darius sorry to cut
you off Robert but that one isn't
fetusaf's control look at what we have
here I thought the black was mating
white now I realize it's the other way
around oh my gosh there's also a pass
Pawn in the position as well but Queen
G3 level heads prevail and you see that
the queen trade is offered Queen takes
G7 is Checkmate so your queen cannot
really avoid the trade e takes F7 check
by the way like was that available just
a move ago just taking a pump with check
trying to get a queen
and that's exactly what caught my eye
now of course black cannot take on B2
that's what kills him because if he
takes F7 but two moves ago when Rook D2
was played my eye was caught by the line
ef7 King H7 and you can't take 28
because of Checkmate on G2 obviously uh
not King h8 uh because then white
promotes with check I saw that line I
was excited but Queen G3 is a total
showstopper Robert complete show stopper
and Darius is no choice but to part ways
with his Bishop this is over
yeah gonna be honest It's just sad when
players make simple moves and then
they're up a piece at the end you're
like I was going for my attack my
brilliancy I think no I'm not really
sure that was so brilliant brilliant for
me perhaps but not for the player trying
to make magic happen so this one is over
let's go to a different game is going to
take the full point and this is actually
what you were saying look at this
matchup Darius fierch is eternizago's
first round opponent these are 2650s
duking it out
yeah in fact they're rated exactly the
same they're both 26.37 so those 2600
matchups are incredibly fascinating but
I also like seeing the lopsided matchups
at the very very top let's go back to
Arjun aragaisy's game because he's been
struggling from the very opening as we
see Darius stop the clocks proverbially
and resign let's go back to uh shike
against a turizaga against aragaisi
because this has gone into a Time
scramble and I think Arjun is not out of
trouble in fact he's in a whole lot more
trouble than he just was a king on G7
and a queen that is what black probably
desperately needs but you can just swap
Queens take B7 thank you very much this
is just a one-sided Demolition and you
would think that Arjun eragisi had the
white pieces against his compatriot
Dunya he's just getting blown off the
board
completely blown off the board and he's
been trouble from the very very
beginning you lost that dark squared
Bishop even though he engineered some
cool tactics to get the bishop to F2 it
was sent back to D4 where it was
captured by White Knight
shike has developed a huge attack on the
king side but how many of these games
have we seen uh the tables turn in when
the lower rated player gets nervous in
time pressure so a lot of work yet to be
done I've lost so many winning positions
against sergeant in Blitz the guy is
unbelievably tricky so a lot of work
left to be done and that might not have
been the most accurate move work I've
seen it or take F6 F6 F6 oh he missed it
Arjun missed it you don't have to take
back the Intermezzo F takes E7 Bishop A4
as you're highlighting and that pawn is
going to Queen this was a nasty display
of Chess from a new buyer's shock here
that was some brilliances and I I was
gonna believe you down here I was
latching on to what you were saying that
I have seen Arjun come back because he's
not even down material here let's count
the pawns six pawns per side two Brooks
and a bishop but who has the best pawn
it's white
and Bishop A4 is a crucial resource
without that upon an E7 would be more or
less confined as it stands I think takes
in Bishop A4 ends the game Arjun might
have missed this move as well
and that's it Bishop takes E4 just move
the Rook anywhere rookie won obviously
do not promote because black will take
and then take on F1 show a little bit of
patience after rookie one I think Arjun
can very safely resign the game
what a big upset my goodness Rook F4
just as good that's it Rook anywhere
does the trick and now we are going to
see an upset in the first round our
generic Garcia he still will have his
chances to make it to those top 10 spots
the top 10 finishers here are the Swiss
they get to take on each other for the
right to getting to division one of the
chess kid cup but this is a really bad
start for our generic geissy he is dead
lost right now
he is indeed okay we can leave uh this
simple technique to uh he's incredibly
strong opponent I'm looking at some
other interesting games Alexander
castanic and jorg Meyer are locked in an
interesting battle man so many cool
games let's go to that one with your
permission Robert uh Meyer against
castenia you don't need my permission
buddy but I appreciate you asking that's
why you're such a good friend whoa is it
a black pony
with Jack or did he
what's his idea he wants cd6 queen C7
chess C7 but it's Bishop 87 or Bishop D7
even
either May either way I thought Queen E7
Queen takes B8 and Bishop takes C6 looks
interesting you're correct Perhaps
Perhaps white can drop the queen back
with check and just play down to Queen
down a rook in fact I think Meyer has to
give the check on C3 how many pawns does
white have I count six pawns black has
four but black is an extra rook and you
cannot take up B8 this is what Georg was
relying on to take this Rook but as you
were saying Bishop takes E6 the white
King on E2 is In Harm's Way and black
will deliver a Checkmate down the line
yeah it's crazy how quickly the attacker
shifts from being white to being black
look at the clock 30 seconds now Brook
York Meyer as he comes to the
realization that Queen takes V8 is not
the way Queen C3 check from a practical
perspective should be pretty automatic
black can absolutely lose this down a
rook because White's Rook will jump into
the game Robert with the Rook takes H2
but no he takes B8
oh my gosh no that clearly was wrong
Bishop takes D5 looks pretty sufficient
but the king runs away into the into the
queen side okay that is huge and there
also will be a moment where Bishop E4
you can block the check with your Bishop
so look at Alexandra showing page maybe
bishop G4 here that way there's no
Bishop E4 for white
oh because if Queen takes E4 so you set
up a pin against the F Pawn but Bishop
takes D5 I would not be able to resist
if White's King runs away then Black's
King could be the one caught in the
crossfire all sorts of forks by the way
along this long diagonal as well and
Alexander now down to 10 seconds she
struggled in time pressure in these
events can she hold her composure here
this is a big moment and she takes on D5
and the engine still likes her positions
of Bishop E4 there must be something
wrong with that if you're white you want
to trade the Queens off desperately
because your king is the ones being
hunted first both kings are open but not
Queen 64. oh that was wrong win H4 I
thought
oh gosh and she well she knows she can
draw this that's the good news for her
if she was nervous but she had more on
the table
black and try Rook G4 check but I'm
actually not convinced that the pawn end
game is winning but York doesn't even
have to go into it he can just play King
F3 and King back to G3 and now a
repetition of moves I think is
inevitable but I think it's really smart
him not to take his pawn and they show
you you probably will lose it just
because black as he split pawns but
white has passage on the queen side as
well so it's a it will be a race I just
think that Black's H5 Pawn is a little
bit too far ahead but yeah it's smart of
him just to keep the status oh Alexander
goes for the win though she thinks that
her H Pawn is going to be stronger than
anything white can create on the other
side of the board but I think she might
regret this because black can absolutely
lose this game if she overpresses if you
lose the a pawn and you aren't able to
promote the H1 White's gonna get
protected passers
but probably a draw still very likely I
think Rook D2 is a really smart move
just take that a pawn now she knows
she's in no trouble uh but good on her
she really wanted to win this game and
now we're just seeing liquidation the
black's King is active the d-pawn trying
to run up but f-pawn is there as well
indeed it is and now a draw is
absolutely inevitable A5 can be tried
but he's gonna push his spawn
oh F6 Rook F1
I think I've spoken too soon I think
jorg is playing for the win now King D5
open this Rook B5 check so you can't
really get away with that either
F6
Rook F1 and then check a ton of times
but the problem is now Rook B5 you can
try to go after the a pawn as well she
needs to check the king away from the
past one Ricky one check and then as the
King goes to F7 you're blocking your own
Pawn over F1 King E7 rookie one check
make sure the king steps in front of the
white Pawn that slows down the progress
that gives you a Tempo which you can
utilize to move your king outs out of
your past pawns way and then start
pushing it ASAP that's exactly what she
does but suddenly black is hanging by a
thread here take the pawn
yes take the pawn the sacrifice you Rook
for the other you know you're making a
draw
yes D1 happens just in time oh one tempo
that black white uses to step away from
the pawn obviously this is a draw
and we're gonna see a repetition of
moves here or Rook takes F7
or this what a game
that was a toss-up at some points but
Alexander kostenic she was up a rook and
with the attack after she gave the Rook
back that was a close call so done any
games remaining here in the first oh
yeah there's a cool uh at Rook versus
ponzen game in the game guadora against
like Wong Lim this is also going to be a
draw so we went there just to catch the
end of the game looks like a nice save
for the Vietnamese number one
and other than that Robert there is I
think one more game no I think that
probably is it for this round one
there's so many games now there is one
more okay what's happening there couple
more there is drozdovsky against
Harsha vardan Knight and pawn versus
Bishop but this looks like a dead draw
to me classic scenario where because you
have only one Pawn left you can never
push G5 black sets up the force fields
and you can never intercept the G5
always met with Bishop takes G5 this is
a draw
and here Knight F4 would be the best
attempt because if black takes the
Knight then black lose the game but the
king now gets to rush in front of the
pawn it can sit on G8 oh now it's time
to take because King gets here and we'll
see King and pawn versus King draw well
played by black
well played indeed this game ends in a
draw we had a rook vs Knight end game on
one of the other boards but it looks
like that game
uh is coming to its conclusion as well
I think that's it
that was a fun first round
it was indeed I'm just captivated by the
amount of top players we have
participating I don't know where to run
to uh it's like a position where you
have six candidate moves and all of them
are amazing but we don't have time to
speculate because round two has already
started and it's time to go around the
horn once again some of the top players
are not catching a break Anish giri he
was facing a strong gym in round one
he's facing p ineon in round two who's
only 25-15 Robert but man is he
dangerous
all right let's check out the start of
these games they're about to get
underway but I think we we saw it really
exciting first I'm catching my breath
we're only one of nine rounds into the
Swiss and we just saw Wild positions
where aren't you there geissy let's not
forget he lost his first game against an
international Master upsets happen and
we just saw a big one
we did indeed and on the top boards we
have rajdean against aronian uh we have
antipov against the tourizaga let's
start
uh on Anish giri's board and then go
from there he has the black pieces or
sorry he has the white pieces beat
borokovsky with black that makes sense
and Anish kind of completely dodging
Theory playing some sort of sort of
weird alien essentially playing the
Italian against the Sicilian and just
trying to get a regular position where
he can outplay his opponent I think this
is a very good strategy and you see a
lot of top players adhering to that
strategy in these online events it
doesn't mean they're not taking it
seriously
no not at all and sometimes you the best
way to play for a win against another
strong player someone is well paired is
to play something offbeat because if we
look at their ratings anishkiri is the
stronger of the two players but if you
go down some deep theoretical territory
that actually allows the player with the
black pieces to uh come up with that
prep and try to neutralize your
advantage so we see Bishop C2 now we do
not have a symmetrical Pawn structure
and Dania I'm looking at the bishop on
C2 I'm looking at Bishop on C1 I'm
thinking that a niche might be going for
an attack
when I was younger these Bishops were
introduced to me as the Horowitz Bishops
when one of them controls c1h6 the other
B1 H7 I don't think that term is in
common use anymore though what is in
common use is the fact that Anish has an
initiative on both sides of the board
Indiana also struggling with a weak Pawn
on B5 if black plays Queen to B6 there's
a typical idea of Knight F5 don't forget
about the X-ray that The Rook exerts on
the bishop on E7 suddenly Robert it's
amazing how people like Anish do this
looks like a totally normal position
relatively toothless two seconds later
black plays one imprudent pawn move bang
you're in big trouble
and it's hard to even see where black
went wrong what did Black do push that
C4 Pawn to get the E4 Pawn you've given
up a Bishop's Pawn for the King's Pawn
that sounds like a good trade for you so
it's hard to blame him but as White's
Pieces Just storm into aggressive
territory B5 is hanging as you indicated
if you protect that pawn there are
Knight F5 tactics and your Bishop on E7
is loose you can play with like Queen to
D7 that way you defend but where's that
Knight on B8 going right if you play
Queen D7 to defend B5 then you can't
play Knight C6 next without dropping a
pawn but I think that might be the best
option just keep that pawn defended for
now and well I guess that white can keep
attacking it and you could try to sack
the pawn with B4 to really increase your
central control but the secondary issue
is that Black's Pawns in the center are
stuck in mud if you play E5 you make
things even worse you let the knight
jump into F5 and if white eliminates the
p-pawn guess what these will be
connected passwords in the center on the
queen side that is that can immediately
start rolling up the board so anishikiri
he's a beast he's also a good start
Queen to B6 displayed so he does allow
Knight F5 but white doesn't have to rush
with this move I think it would be more
Indonesia's style to play something like
Knight to G3 or Bishop E3 and keep
improving his position keep increasing
the pressure
yeah Bishop E3 comes the tempo because
the black queen should probably move
there may be an opportunity at some
point to chase the bishop out of e3 but
first your queen it has to remove itself
from its sight so where do you even
bring that Queen
A6 Bishop D3 yeah automatic Queen A5
that's B4 as you're pointing out and the
queen then has to go back to A6 and only
then Bishop D3 is why just stealing that
pawn
this is getting more and more
problematic even though we don't see the
eval bar Rising black must move the
queen
unless Knight D5 Works tactically which
I'm way too lazy to calculate it's the
clock hasn't struck noon yet Robert that
means no calculation for nariditsky
I respect that and I think that uh for
Anish Geary he's already had this worked
out so he doesn't really calculate he
knows at this point that Knight F5 is a
good move at the very least he will
secure himself the pair of Bishops in an
open position that's good news for Anish
even as his head dips down I mean he he
did that typical chess player thing you
were in the right place on camera yeah
then your head lower and lower as you
concentrate on the board yeah we only
see her forehead then we only see the
top of your hair Knight to D5 has been
played so he is accepting the loss of
the bishop pair the problem is he might
have to accept the loss of the game
because apparently there's something a
lot better than Knight to F5 available
for white I think it might be Knight
takes C6 93 93 sort of oh
queen queen D3 first maybe because if
the knights on E3 can take the bishop on
C2 so what if we start with Queen D3
here
so if you start with Queen T3 you can
pull up an analysis board quickly then
we'll go to alirez's game because he's
in some interesting complications as
well I have to go G6 to defend against
checkmate
and now I mean you could just play
Knight F5 take E7 and play Bishop H6 I
did cheat a little bit and the actual
correct line is I think incredibly hard
to find Roberts do you want to know what
it is
tell me please so it's Knight takes E6
Knight takes E3
I mean I don't think I'd see this game
actually you just take back on E3 and
it's totally anti-climactic and you play
Queen to H5 and the problem is that
black just doesn't have the defensive
fire power to all the threats if you
play H6 then I think either Queen G6 is
good or even Knight to G4 setting up
mate threats uh along the lines of
Knight takes H6 and Queen H G6
Black's problem of his major defensive
forces are clustered on the other side
of the board and he doesn't have any
counter play against Dwight's King
something tells me though that Anish is
going to spend a long time calculating a
knight take C6 but it's much more human
in my eyes to consider a move like Queen
T3 or Bishop takes H7 neither of which
is quite correct
yeah no I think Knight takes E6 seems
automatic uh but it's misleading that's
what the eval bar sometimes tricks even
us but on each Geary finding that that
seems like a really big ask of him and
he's a super Grand Master with a super
high rating but that just is not very
human I think he might just play Knight
F5 and take control of the game that way
though the way that he's thinking
he could find it it's not completely
outside the realm of possibility
I think sometimes during the commentary
Anish underplayed uh his tactical
ability I mean the guy is a calculating
machine he grew up playing the night or
if he grew up playing a ton of Blitz so
Anish isn't just you know a dry
positional player none of these top
players have really only one way of
playing they all can calculate they're
all incredible tacticians so I'm excited
to see whether Anish uh will be able to
spot Knight takes C6 or whether he
settles for the long-term positional
Advantage either way he's in charge of
this game from the very beginning
he is and for everyone who's tuning in I
just want to let you all know this is
the chess kid Cup this is not a youth
event and each Curie hasn't become his
son's age all of a sudden no the chess
kid is the sponsor of the Third Leg of
the Champions chess store so just like
the air things Masters and the chest of
Masters before it chested cup is the
Third Leg of the Champions chest tour
and 96 was played Dania so wait a second
this is what you were talking about is
he gonna see it that's that would be
incredible just Knight takes E3 you
don't play Queen H5 you don't play
Bishop takes H7 check because black can
just take that bishop and then the end
block will have two minor pieces for The
Rook Niche he clearly sees something
here the reason he's pausing Robert is
just to double check and he's played
Rook takes E3 that's not the move it
shifts the eval bar completely the
opposite direction
is he going for some kind of queen H5
Rook H3 type of idea it's hard to blame
him for this he's bringing up his Rook
he lifted his Rook into the attack but
it was a mistake and chess is a
difficult game sometimes and yeah it
feels like that Knight takes E3 Queen H5
Knight G4 type of stuff that was
possible to find but very difficult
especially in Rapid play and of course
another idea is that G6 is now
discouraged because if Bishop takes G6 I
think the problem is that after H6 white
is sorely missing the attacking presence
of the Knight that Knight G4 Knight
takes H6 idea was the cherry on top you
needed that to crack through Black's
defenses as it stands you can play Queen
G6 but black can actually simply defend
with Rook F6 and pave open the
evacuation path for his King white could
easily lose control of the game the last
thing I'll say Robert is that White's
Rook is also immobilized because you
have to prevent black from taking on F2
that would result in immediate Checkmate
on the back rank or on G2
there are problems for the white king
all of a sudden the f file open the
queen on B6 staring through the Rook to
F2 so I think Anish is more likely to
win this game than he has to lose just
because he's the one attacking first
look at Black's Queen side the Knight on
B8 Rook gonna hit they're not taking
part in the action the queen on B6 it
actually is helping out because it
stares Through The Rook to the F2 Pawn
but without pieces in the game it feels
very hard to defend your king
yeah especially given this time control
you have to take the eval bar with a
grain of salt but anyon you don't want
to give him too many chances he will
defend with cold bloodedness and
resilience I think he's gonna go Rook F6
or Bishop F6 that's a difficult decision
he's gonna have to make and that will
take more time off his clock I think it
affords us a good opportunity to look at
some of the other top games because we
have yet again a lot of interesting
positions Robert we haven't given Ali
Reza for Russia the attention that he
deserves just yet shall we take a look
at his game against our very own
Benjamin Bach
I will never complain to look at
inalaisa fuja game let's do it I want to
see how the teenager in France is
playing this and material count is even
black has no space and that Bishop on A5
at some moment if white could play the
move B4 that Bishop will be trapped as
well
it will indeed it's hard to identify the
opening when you just look at this
position unless you're familiar with the
structure which I am because when I
played the nimso Indian that is indeed
what alireza farusha played I had this
structure quite frequently it's a
sideline white played an early Queen C2
followed by E4 but Benjamin he has a big
space Advantage box pieces are
discombobulated black is barely holding
on to the D6 spawn and yet Benjamin's
last move appeared to be a big mistake
and you see why is it because of some
sort of F5
maybe you have five and Knight G6
oh and then after four
F5 would be a big move because you're
opening up your king but as you're
showing the bishop on E2 is a bit loose
that Knight on G3 would be kicked out
the way and then a bishop on seat at
long last will get into the game F5 is a
huge opportunity I think he'll Spot It
I think he will as well alirez is such
an aggressive active player you have to
generate breathing room for your pieces
Bishop P2 is a bit of a lazy move right
it was a move to complete White's
development so we understand where he
came from but apparently there were more
tactical ways to treat this position
let's see if black can come up with F5
followed by Knight G6 F4 and the
avalanche on the king side moves so so
fast that Bishop on A5 also Robert that
could come in actually very handy
because white snipe has to drop back
onto either C3 or D2 where it can be
eliminated at the right time uh
softening up White's control over his
very own E2 Bishop
yeah I actually wonder you know how the
mistake just happened because I feel
like White's Choice was probably super
difficult there your Bishop was under
attack from a knight and you want to
keep your bishop and F5 is not an easy
move to spot like you are exposing your
own King as black there will be some
long-term weaknesses
yeah I'm sorry to cut you off this is a
great explanation and F5 is indeed
played I was just looking around the
horn I saw that Alexander castanoke lost
in 12 moves uh to Sasha Bortnick so uh
that just happened and it was all Theory
hmm
that's unfortunate you always hate to
lose quick games like that you can
forgive yourself oh I'll just learn the
theory and that's a problem at this
stage you lose a game you're kind of
running out of contention quickly you
are indeed and so Sasha has one and a
half out of two but we turn our
attention back to this game the Knight
drops back to C3 now the big question
for black how are you going to attack
this bishop the move G5 comes to mind
but it's very very committal you could
also attack with your piece you could
play Knight to G6 but something tells me
that alireza is taking over the
initiative in this game
yeah he's kicking the pieces back first
the bishop went from D3 to E2 then a
knight that was on e4 went back to C3
then you're kicking the dark Square
Bishop back and blacks pieces will come
to life if you get a pawn to F4 the
bishop on C8 will go to the F5 Square it
will vacate that score for the bishop
their problems for the King on B1 all of
a sudden alarisa can also start thinking
about A6 and B5 and playing on the queen
side and going for an attack of his own
indeed he can he's gonna invest a little
bit more time and figure out a way to
keep this initiative going I will keep a
close eye on this game we'll come back
to it I think when uh the clocks are
showing one minute rather than four but
in the meantime we've got so many other
fascinating games to look at I want to
swing by karil Alexander land he's
playing Dennis lassovic and they are in
a very interesting tactical battle we
talked about those lesser-known GMS
Robert gorilla like senko I don't know
if you can even talk about him as a
lesser-known GM because he participated
in the candidates tournament for
goodness sake
yeah he was as an over 2700 in the
candidates but right now he's in a whole
world of trouble I mean look at this
position let's do a quick material count
Donya Black's up a pawn White's Knight
on B1 hasn't moved black is just moving
his pieces towards the white king and if
that Rook on A7 we're on F7 if you can
just drag that Rook over there for a
second just pull it up and put it on F7
the game's over all right King is just
toast but it might be over anyway
because of Knight T3
no then Queenie oh
oh that actually could backfire
completely
maybe the other night to D3 and this is
where Dennis lazovic excels he's got
five and a half minutes his time
management has been incredible I think
there might be tactics with like Knight
D3 and Knight takes F2 something exists
here it smells but you actually have to
see it
that works now what you just said is
definitely the solution Knight CD3 and
you take on F2 because you're either
dragging the queen on F3 away and then
Knight H3 check will be devastating or
you're bringing the king onto the f file
and he plays it and if the kings of the
f file there's a rook a queen and a king
all in the same line The Rook wins that
Showdown and the block 94 will just jump
out the way as I like to say when I'm in
a tilted condition he sees everything
sometimes it feels like Dennis lassoving
the guy that kid is a machine and it's
so important to be stubborn tactically
it's easy to look at this and say well I
don't have any discoveries because
wherever you go with your F4 Knight
Black's a White's Queen follows the
Knight and gets out of the danger zone
but you can deflect the queen onto F2
first then Knight H3 would be 10 times
more devastating or like 100 times more
devastating this one's basically over
22 moves no this is just brutal Knight
takes F2 is available here you've
spotted that tactic and I think Dennis
lastman will as as well look at his time
by the way he has five minutes left in
this game so he's been blitzing and
playing great moves he's up a pawn he's
about to steal a second and the white
king just has not enough defense oh he
plays there it is oh my gosh King takes
F2 the other Knight jumps into D3 don't
even need to play Knight H3 trick which
by the way would keep white in the game
because you don't want to give away too
many pieces for the queen I think
alexenko's position is now officially
resignable he's going to try one
last-ditch attempt to complicate the
game
and how does black finish this off
Knight H3 King H2 and somehow White's
still hanging by a thread because the
black queen is hanging the white Queen's
gonna hang and Dennis and he find a way
to emerge up a queen here
Queen H4 Queen G6 oh and the Knight on
B1 is hanging two look at this
full board awareness from Dennis and the
lack of coordination from White's pieces
there's a rook on E5 a rook at A3 a
knight on B1 and F1 the king is in
trouble and queen takes B1 just steals
material here
and it hits the other night you still
can't take the Knight on F2
does Dennis see that he attacked the
Knight with his last move I think he did
he's just double checking making sure
that there are no tricks this would be a
huge win for the Belarusian Grandmaster
it would put him on two out of two we're
just so used to seeing him competing on
equal terms with the very top players
it's crazy to think that he's not even
2600 feet eight not for very long though
he's one of those players that you call
underrated when you look at a first
round or a second round pairing and like
oh I'm playing a 25.50 this game is
officially over Dennis Lesnik wins but
you're looking at you're playing a 25.50
okay I've got good chances then you see
the name attached to Dennis lesvik and
you're like no no that's not right that
guy's My Level so he is playing at an
absurdly high level at this point I mean
the pro chess League it seemed like he
was winning most of his games there he's
a beast you don't want to face him he's
an absolute Beast speaking of beasts uh
we have that Anish giri game that has
continued to heat up I think we should
go back to that game for just a second
because anisha's sacrificing all of his
minor pieces and he is trying to justify
that early sacrifice on E6 but he's
failing he's trying I don't think he's
succeeding I think ineon has brought all
of his pieces to the defensive effort he
can drop his Bishop back to f8 anisha's
last move was more like desperation
Robert rather than coming from a
position of strength
yeah as you're saying Bishop f8 what's
the big threat in the position Queen
takes G7 check would be game over so
Bishop f8 covers that pawn then you also
could take the knight in F5 the reason
you can't take it right now with your
Pawn is that Rook takes E7 check that
Bishop is hanging so you actually take
care of all of your problems at once the
attack may still be there I think it's
still a bit scary for the black king on
F7 but Black's up a piece for just one
Pawn so Bishop f8 is a great move
it is and the moment White's Rook swings
away from the e-file black and now
simply take on F5 in fact Bishop f8
creates the threat if he takes F5 to add
insult to injury and he's just 30
seconds on his clock this is going to be
a hard breaker for Anish a loss of the
white pieces unless he can turn this
around with his last seconds he's
certainly trying his best 1984 is an
excellent move this is what makes these
top jams so good he knows things have
gone wrong but he's not panicking and
he's still trying to exploit all of his
assets here including his pressure on E6
he's trying to provoke black into
playing the movie five so that white has
an entire new diagonal to work with
maybe E5 is still the best move but it
lets the Knight also jumping back into
F5 so anyon is far from celebrating a
victory that Victory still has to be
achieved
great move though Bishop D5 he's
covering the E6 square and that diagonal
that you were just talking about and
done if the times were reversed white
wins this game but Anish gear is also
down the clock I could see Indiana
taking some time here he might get in
time trouble of his own but he's playing
perfect defensive moves at the moment
and B4 that's does wreakive desperation
a lot of anisha's moves but this is how
you have to play when you're down
material and your attack is fizzing out
break more Firepower into the position
you attack the queen where does that
queen go you want to stay in touch with
the B5 Pawn you don't want to drop that
one but Queen B6 the queen is strength
farther and farther away from that King
out of seven and white kid play this
almost positionally with Bishop to B3
trying to soften up that E6 Pawn it's
weird because White's down a minor piece
and queen B6 is on the board in a niche
with 10 seconds left can he keep
attacking Rook take C6 what a move and
he's sacking everything throwing the
kitchen sink it black I think he wants
to recapture with the rook and then chop
off flex Rook with Bishop to B3 and
attack on the light squares what an idea
with his last seconds yeah there's also
Queen E4 check at the end of the
variation and The Rook on A8 is loose so
he was distracting the queen away from
C5 because in these positions I know
it's gonna be hard for a lot of you to
visualize but if everything gets swapped
off on E6 and queen E4 check happens The
Black Queen would have gone to E5 and
The Rook on 8 was Untouchable so let's
just see this happen here uh we are
seeing some trades Knight takes E6 as
possible Bishop B3 as well it has to be
considered just pinning and then going
after that Rook but that's a curse
rather than a blessing because Anisha
six seconds now to make that decision he
plays it simple with Knight takes E6 it
wasn't the move apparently and black is
not obliged to recapture on E6 black can
also play a Brazen looking move like
Rook takes A2 if he believes that he can
escape the checks and he plays it
no more checks is a back rank Checkmate
that black is threatening if you move
your Bishop Queen takes F2 so he goes
Knight F4 he wants Knight D5 before Oh
still not over still far from over the
other threat Robert is Queen E6 Queen
takes A2 can you defend against both
threats at once well if you play King d8
White's Knight jumps back into E6 and
somehow White's remaining pieces are
able to coordinate and cause serious
problems one and a half minutes for
black I've seen crazier things happen
maybe the move is just Knight to F6 and
close off White's access to the E6
Square
yeah or Rook A1 check just a force
Bishop B1 and then that means the White
Queen and the bishop are tethered
together and that could distract white
enough so that there is no checkmating
attack he throws it in and now Knight F6
looks great Dania I think that's a
really good idea king d8 would be a
mistake as you pointed out because
Knight E6 check with Queen E8 to follow
uh that would be dangerous for black it
wouldn't be a tragedy it would force you
to go back to E7 Queen C6 looks like the
best move because he's simply taking
this thing out of the check on E6 he's
also taking this thing out of a check on
D5 neither of these moves that lead
absolutely anywhere and Indiana is up a
full Rook he's essentially Consolidated
he needs a couple more accurate
defensive moves and he will have
dispatched a niche Geary with the black
pieces what a huge upset this is about
to be but 40 seconds maybe time to force
the queen trade with Queen E4 oh that's
another sick move and that forces
resignation that is a Game ending time
Donna just want to point out can you try
to play Bishop 64 show everybody why
that's not a queen blunder
well it's because of a bug on chess.com
I'm letting me take free Queens no you
cannot take on E1 because on e4 because
their King on G1 is pinned and you
called it Robert that is why he
delivered the check on A1 it took the
life out of the bishop and he just took
the life out of Anish giri with a
victory beautiful tactics by a niche but
it wasn't enough
no it was not but Denise carry will have
time to recover nine rounds of the Swiss
you need to make in the top ten for a
chance at division one we'll come back
in a few but this is the chess kid cup
playing Phase this is heating up he
actually continues here in like three of
the Champion's chest tour we'll be right
back
[Music]
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chess vessels and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
the most important thing to know about
me is that I love the game of chess I
taught my younger brother to play when
he was four now he and I have been
teaching chess for 16 years we run the
online Magnus chess Academy where kids
get weekly small group classes with
vetted and trained coaches kids can
learn compete and even get the chance to
meet and learn from the most successful
players in the world
visit chessacademy.com trial to try a
small online class
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we welcome you back to the chess kid cup
the Third Leg of the Champions chess
tour I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me my good friend Grandmaster
Daniel nerdinski Tanya two grounds are
in the books we've seen some big upsets
like Arjun Eric garcy and these Geary
being taken down by an international
master and a Grandmaster whose ring does
not start with 2700 so we've seen some
excitement what what more do you expect
to see going forward well it's like the
wild west here Robert you absolutely
cannot predict who's gonna make the top
fives this this is what makes these
qualifying events so scintillating it's
not just a technicality because we know
who's gonna make it in the end nothing
is guaranteed you can see top players
essentially go 50 but I'm looking at
people like LaVon aronian who managed to
win his first two games he defeated
Maxim rajtein very strong Israeli
Grandmaster with the black pieces from a
dead equal end game in round two so
Lavon is one to watch obviously I'm also
looking at Anish giri and to see how
he's going to come back from that
devastating shock defeat in round two at
the hands of Indian GMP and eon
you said shock defeated I thought it was
shock your mama jarov I'm hoping that
he's somewhere in this field as well
there's so many notable players I think
145 players are taking part in this nine
round Swiss so to remind everybody it's
nine rounds of 10 minute plus two
seconds added per move for the players
it's quick Pace it's fun but for some
it's very stressful as they want to make
their way to these divisions there are
three divisions in the Champions chess
Tour event and we see in the third round
we have levada Ronin playing oh against
basem I mean
one of my favorite jams Dr basem he is a
fully accredited doctor he is a super
strong GM over 2700 uh and Incredibly
nice guy uh not the Lavon isn't but I'm
a big
yeah but Sam is a great person and he is
a doctor as you said that's why it's his
username uh on chess.com but he also is
somebody the first player from Africa to
cross 2700 he's just about there right
now his rate dipped in recent years but
he's on his way up and now he's played
this H6 move so if there's something you
can expect from Boston Mommy and it's
offbeat openings not main lines look at
his Bishop on f8 it's paying the price
and I have played this line very
extensively I played it against Wesley
in the U.S championship and Knight C3 is
all of the rage you basically switch to
a Four Knights and try to make the move
H6 obsolete the other idea is that if
black plays G7 G5 which at one point was
all of the rage in the Italian white
generally counter-strikes in the center
with T3 T4 now normally Robert if
blackened eliminate the light squared
Bishop uh without giving away his own
Bishop that's successful but I think
Lavon is throwing all of his eggs in the
D4 basket he's gonna try to transpose
this into some sort of a philadelph
I like it I mean that's just a strike in
the center was black done so far pushed
some pawns that Knight has hopped twice
already so I think that Lavon is playing
this with great emphasis on the center
and you can automatically capture so
that's going to show that Levant should
probably pre-move there a takes B3 but
he will play D4 next you will indeed and
of course black could technically
prevent it with C5 and I would not rule
that move out I wouldn't totally rule it
out but I mean creating that massive
hole on T5 white also has the plan of
dropping the Knight back and pushing F4
so it's not like D4 is the only idea in
the position
I wouldn't take measures this drastic I
would just play Bishop E7 and meet D4
with either he takes D4 or Knight D7 I
think black is a little bit worse here
but the position remains very very solid
but Sam is such an experienced E4 E5
player he should still feel relatively
at home here maybe G4 can also be
considered
I know why you didn't suggest that at
first and also why I didn't you don't
really want to give up your one
advantage in the position you have the
bishop pair and how did he goes for it
but how did Black take White's Bishop
Knight went out to C6 and then out to A5
you moved a couple times here white is
giving up hit his Knight by just playing
H3 a very useful move to give the king
Luft in the long term and your queen
gets out to F3 so it does look like a
position where white is several Tempe
ahead if in fact black takes an F3 but
don't be surprised if the bishop drops
back to H5 this is a rapid game so if
you play G4 we'll see a night sacrifice
we will indeed and H3 has been played
and the Big Moment of Truth does he take
on F3 and prevent D4 at all costs ugh I
don't like that position he's gonna go
Bishop H5 and now it's up to Lavon and
Levon does not hesitate at all we see
him doing this all tournament long
Robert he just plays on his intuition
and he leaves himself with so much time
for the later middle game stage this is
an incredibly effective way to play
rapid but only a couple people can get
away with it maxiva Shilla grab and
levonaronian I think the only two at the
top maybe Jana pondichi also plays this
fast and Rapid it's an incredible
because others you make Christmas think
too quickly and by the way Dennis Lesnik
and Dimitri kolars moved to two and a
half into three they must have drawn
their game quite quickly here but if
that night sacrifice happened black just
didn't have enough Firepower for the
attack so it wasn't worth it and Bassam
quickly realized that and that Bishop is
this winter Kappa Blanca that Bishop is
terrible on G6 but LeBron's last move
Knight E2 he's gonna bring his Knight to
G3 to help Safeguard his King but it
does allow black to strike in the center
at some point with D5
it does indeed in response to D5 white
has to be ready to capture the pawn and
E5 and that is why I do think that white
should get his Knight to G3 quickly I
also think it's why basem should
consider the immediate D5 but with his
own King side not developed I don't
think that he can get away with just
intuitively Knight takes C5 Knight takes
G6 forces more weaknesses on the king
side the other night could then come out
to F4 no that doesn't look good enough I
think but Sam is probably deciding
between a move like H5 you know meeting
fire with fire on the king side and a
more pedestrian uh developing move like
Bishop to E7
oh let's go H5 or you know Queen D7 with
H5 to follow because the H3 Pawn will be
Lucid many of these positions uh so I'm
liking the idea of H5 rather than D5 as
you said the E5 Pawn can be captured
that may be giving white too much ease
in the position so yeah Queen D7 or H5
those are my two places and girl he
wants a castle approach he does he wants
to play Queen D7 cast Queen's side H5
and I want to check me the guy
and that is not what vasimo means sounds
like but you know your other impressions
are better than that one what he's not
from he's not from Columbia South
Carolina
uh no I don't think so but maybe one day
he'll settle there but I think that this
position is not going to settle down
anytime soon so should we hop elsewhere
and then come back to this game as the
action continues well we have a bunch of
other fascinating action going on in the
top boards I want to go to alirez's game
first I want to stop by Vladimir fetta
saves game because he's in another
Italian and he just made a very
interesting a bold move against French
team
has to now figure out which minor piece
to give back up
oh my gosh so Knight takes Pawn Knight
takes Knight and D4 with a fork a bishop
and Knight and E4 is under attack both
minor pieces there Dania would you play
Bishop D6 to keep the bishop or would
you maybe move your knight back to D7
your E Knight back to D7 and once dc5 to
your knight gets active on C5 these
questions are not easy to answer yeah
now the standard way of dealing with a
center fork trick as this is called is
to drop the bishop back to D6 that's how
you keep your Bishop there but if you
keep calculating after Bishop takes E5
White's Knight can come out to F3 I
think this is what fedesaf is banking on
and then the bishop can't drop back
because white is the one who delivers
another fork and how often do you see
that a fork with d3d4 and then a fork
with the E4 E5 I think Bishop D6 is
wrong I think Laurent has to play this
more creatively I'm also thinking about
Bishop takes D4 CD and Knight to C6
trying to accentuate the weakness of the
D4 Pawn but then white can still drive
the pawn up to E5 reposition the Knight
to F3 and that looks really comfortable
as well another case Robert of the eval
bar showing a slight Advantage for black
I think that's meaningless I think
Vladimir has chosen a very interesting
practical idea
the third option I see is Knight takes
E4 ignoring the fact that both your
bishop and Knight are under attack
because many of the variations that
Daniel I think we should quickly show if
we can bring up an analysis board what
you were saying in the event of Bishop
D6 is super instructive we're taught to
keep our Bishops if we can but Bishop D6
would backfire because of the de Bishop
E5 Knight F3 as you pointed out the
bishop wants to move again you want to
save the piece but you're going to lose
a piece thanks to a second fork and that
would win white the game and even if you
don't win a piece many of these
positions are favorable for white with
the bishop on C2 and Bishop on C1
slicing across the board towards the
black king side so I like what you were
saying Bishop takes D4 is one idea um
you can knight takes E4 as another but
the engine I mean it just has no problem
here whatsoever there are definitely
problems that black has to solve and I
do like Knight takes E4 it took a while
to come to that idea but expressing a
finds it and fresen a I mean he was 27
20. so he still has that class and he
has that incredible experience level in
the Italian the only time I played him
over the board I actually decided to
play uh not in Italian it was a real
Lopez but we had this exact structure
and he can play this in his sleep so
Knight takes E4 a big decision we're
gonna have mass Liquidation in the
center the other night can actually pay
a visit to D3 Robert once the d-pawn
repositions to E4 Vladimir has to decide
what minor piece he's going to take he's
got three options D takes E5 is out of
the question F2 drops so you largely are
deciding between Knight takes D4 and
pawn takes C5 knowing Vladimir he likes
to keep as much tension on the board as
possible he's gonna play for the win
until the chickens come home to roost
and I think he's probably gonna play
ec5 although
I don't know doesn't feel all that
inspiring for white he could also play
Knight takes E4 and other projects where
Bishop takes E4 those pieces are still
forked so he doesn't have to take one of
Black's minor pieces just yet and he may
decide on that so it's funny when a fork
with a pawn is there like it can
sometimes just sit and you don't have to
rush I'm taking a piece back no you do
not and like you're mentioning Vladimir
he keeps the tension I think Bishop
takes E4 Bishop D5 is one way the game
could continue I'm gonna predict a draw
here I think we're gonna get a couple
more minor piece trades and the pawn
structure is largely symmetrical so if
the Smoke Clears and neither side
blunters you should get a relatively
balanced late middle game but I'm also
looking at Ollie rez's game we have to
pay a visit because his position is
heating up and heating up and there's
another Fork on two minor pieces on the
other side of the board in Ali resist
game against Marts and crafts a very
strong Ukrainian Grandmaster Martin I
think is in quite a world of hurt here
and I want to point out that Martin
crafts has almost took down Fabiano
caruana in the chess.com Global
championship in 2022. that was the first
round pairing Fabiano playing against
craftsive and Craftsman was better in
most of the games he beat Fabiano in one
of them but he just couldn't make it
work in the end if 500 got through but
Bishop F5 also doesn't seem to work
after politics E4 if we say politics E4
back the issue is that black pawn that
sits on e4 will be a long-term weakness
that white will go after and the King on
G8 is open even more open than the King
on G1 because there is a white Bishop
sitting in front of that King so I think
that there are problems in two different
directions you could trade queens and
white should be better with the Knight
coming to C2 into E3 going after the
bishop on F5 and if that F4 Pawn that
rumbles forward oh no Black's in huge
trouble and the time situation is not
Black's friend either he's down over
four minutes on the clock craftif
constantly has to make these difficult
decisions right now deciding which piece
to recapture with on e4 I would play
Bishop takes C4 he takes Pawn he takes
with a pawn and Queenie one here very
tempting preparing to drag the queen
over to the king side but like you're
saying white is positionally better as
well Ali Reza says hey you want to trade
Queens yeah I'm probably not going to
Checkmate you but I'm going to dominate
the center perhaps of trying to trade on
his own terms and this is only making
things worse according to the engine
King H1 I think could be considered here
talk about keeping the tension
you can also just take it but you can
get two oh yeah you mean like E3 as well
I want to get my knight to E3 so that's
why I'm leaving the Square open uh but
yeah this is not a solution to Black's
problems there are too many of them to
deal with uh the pawn E4 it's gone too
far it's overextended I think white will
win that later in the game and if we do
a quick material count a black and white
both have six pawns to their name so
that if E4 Falls that opens up the
bishop on G2 and gives white extra
material this is no good for crafts if
unfortunately he's found himself dealing
with a very good shape alireza farugia
so uh Donna what do you say can we go to
the game between Sam shankland and
Jordan Von Forest to Big names in the
Chess World one a former winner of the
Tata steel event that was Jordan run for
us one a former US champion and an
Olympiad gold medalist in Sam Shanklin
so these two players and look at the
tension in the center oh look at this
position Sam Shanklin is so solid he did
win a title Tuesday pretty recently so
much like Fabiano caruana he's not known
quite as a rapid specialist split
specialist but he's gotten better he's
got more experience and I like what he's
showing in this tournament thus far his
Knight has entrenched itself on the uh
Prime real estate it's on Brickell
Avenue in Miami but the only tactical
problem is after Knight takes F6 check
which Jordan has just played Sam might
have wanted to consider Ponte except sex
because D5 followed by D takes C6 is
possible The Rook underneath one is
defended enough times
but Sam probably will just trade twice
on the one and queen takes E6 or what do
you see no exactly that but it looks
like background Checkmate but the queen
on C6 also covers the E8 Square whoa
that was like very close either your
puncher was shattered or you're getting
background checkmated but now it looks
like pure liquidation and in some end
games right it's not end games without
the Queens white would be better because
the bishop is a long range piece but the
king's on H1 it would have to be out on
like F3 in order for white to have an
edge here but as you're saying Queen C7
keep the Queens on a queen and Bishop in
combination one another they could pose
some problems for the black king
Queen C7 Jordan squeezing the life out
of this position there's a good test for
figuring out if there are realistic
winning chances the test involves one
question would I be terrified facing
Magnus Carlson on the defending side in
this position the answer is always going
to be yes so it's a completely useless
test I would probably be terrified of
the white pieces too but in all
seriousness Queen B8 check white could
maybe position the bishop on C5 but with
five over five minutes on the clock
Robert I don't think Sam is gonna have
too many practical difficulties here
yeah the problem is maybe there's a
Target where you you would like to play
A4 B5 B6 like something like that where
if you could just push that oh I was
gonna say I didn't think you could do it
because Queen takes A4 is still possible
the queen protects the Knight on E8 but
if that white Pawn could get up to B6
that's where it starts getting dangerous
for black and you can't even play B5
here because you could take twice the
queen will defend the Knight 98 from B5
and this position so clearly illustrates
how difficult it is to win without
control of a whole complex of squares if
you had a light squared Bishop to guide
the pawn forward that would be one thing
now white has to find alternate ways to
get B5 in and by the way the queen of
the night we know it's a very strong
combination so Jordan can't dilly dally
rounded he missed something there's a
blender 146 Queen before us exactly the
B4 poem is loose so he's playing a
little bit maybe too much for a win if
he finds a draw he should take it
because this Knight is going to a light
square like D5 and that Bishop on E3 can
do nothing about it it's an inherent
limitation of Bishops they have to stick
to their color complex so this Knight on
E6 now instead of D5 yeah black is
nothing to worry about I think uh Sam's
done this really well
he had a chance there with a B4 Pawn
he's gone G6 I don't like that move it
softens up F6 in these positions yeah it
weakens the king side I would play B6 if
I'm your and then he doesn't have to
worry about the safety of his Pawn I
still think we're talking about a
relatively High chance of a draw Queen
C7 check would force the queen trade and
I would have done that
wait that would have been a great ending
for Black yeah then the pawn would have
become a serious weakness and Black's
king would have been only a couple steps
away from winning it man this is
incredibly sloppy from both players
right now
yeah B6 I think is necessary if he
allows Queen C7 if white plays H again
seven
E7 is a no-brainer now maybe Sam he's
forgetting that the Knight is unpinned
and he's found it Eddie Jordan oh is
letting this one slip I think
for a draw
he does indeed King E6 King D6 King C6
it's not that far away but the pawn on
F6 is a weakness and if you ever push F5
then the King goes back to H4 into G5
and the white king will go after the G6
Pawn so maybe there is no way for black
to win this position but it was scary
you're right that they were playing a
bit of complacent chess like oh I'll
just make moves to my hand it's just a
draw but you can lose positions like
this and maybe Sam he still has
ambitions
he certainly does he trades on G4 he's
gonna go King D6 but what saves Jordan
here is the presence of that Target on
F6 it's forcing Sam to liquidate the
king side even further now it's a dead
draw now it's official unless white Miss
is a fork uh which Jordan is not going
to do uh this game is going to end
peacefully as we expected David Navarro
in the meantime he lost David Anton
gihara who delivered a Checkmate two
Rooks down it was an incredible attack
by the Spanish GM uh a lot of the other
games are heating up as well Ali Reza
though has failed to generate winning
chances that position gets crafts if
he's messed it up and I think the
Ukrainian Grandmaster is going to save
it
okay let's check that out this game we
know should Peter out into a draw and
wow we're a rook end game oh wait wait
but White's up a pawn
oh it is up a pawn and I think it was
probably still a draw sorry I miscounted
the material but before crafts of last
move was a huge mistake because now he's
gonna lose the C4 pawn and he's created
a massive hole on D4 White's King
immediately accesses it's a win for
alireza I Stand correct so maybe no it's
okay I mean the evil bar sometimes does
that we see like oh it's just a draw but
no the position down upon even if there
was a path towards a draw somehow two
extra Pawns in the center for white if
we're breaking the board in that way and
now c4 is falling there's no chance this
is game over and farrugia will take it
and go two three out of three perfect
score
I would actually consider Rook takes C4
ba and Rook A4 here as one way to play
but you're right connected pastors on
the in the center this is completely
winning all he has to do is deal
successfully with the counter play on
The Queen side he's going to do that
alireza is going to win his game we've
got a couple of the other top games
still going we've got a torizaga against
Mohammed muradli uh who's up there
Alexander Vortech is though is getting
sizzled by Alexander shimanov can we go
to that game really quickly and just
check out a crazy position on the board
oh why you gotta do this to everybody
there's a king on d8 and there's no way
this eval is yeah okay there it goes it
was waiting to get into the position
there was no way this position was equal
can you just your queen of C2 is under
attack I was about to ask you when you
hit you can't take on h8 oh my gosh
Knight takes each might have been
possible
when though I mean you could take the
queen and take on h8 can't you no when
the King was on E8 your Bishop F7 check
it probably wasn't a good idea because
the Knight on B5 was also hanging but
tactically speaking you you wouldn't
have dropped the full Queen
I would consider Bishop D3 here now I've
seen Alexander board tank pull out
almost any lost position I saw a
beautiful mating construction uh with 95
Rook takes C8 and Knight takes D7 the
problem is that anytime you take on C8
black and recapture with the Knight and
vacate an escape score for the bishop a
bishop to D3 such a cold-blooded move
Robert because Queen takes G2 is met
with Bishop to E4 sending the queen back
it is nowhere good to go
well he's gonna go Queen H3 or queen G4
but this is not going to solve any of
the problems so he does in fact choose
the queen of G4 but can you take this
Rook on h8 like all of White's pieces
are defended so after Knight h8 Bishop
C7 Queen takes C7 you're threatening
Checkmate on d8 in one move and your
Bishop 24 is defended even if it wasn't
a Checkmate threat
it's a point I make to newer players in
particular when you're attacking it's
important to get out of Checkmate mode
and to realize that sometimes the best
approach is just to take as much
material as you can Rook takes C8 and
Knight takes C8 white is going to be up
two minor pieces and even if he loses
one of them even if one of the knights
fails to get out the other one will
Shimano takes a different approach this
one's over it's a big win for the
Russian Grandmaster
it is and it was a big win for Lavon
eroding we see he goes up to three out
of three he takes out Dr basem he was up
a piece the last time I looked off to my
other monitor but it's a nice win for
Levant he wants to make his way back to
Queen h8 is not mate there is Knight G8
there so good as you said go out of
Checkmate mode I went back into
Checkmate mode by taking a free Bishop
that was the better choice hey if
there's Checkmate then I'm by all means
go back into Checkmate mode uh I'm also
in uh Renato Terry mode because we've
got one top game two top games still
remaining got FedEx and fresenet uh in a
relatively level uh Italian middle game
and we check out Renato Terry's end game
against Dimitri on Drake and I think we
can trust that Alexander shimanov is
going to finish this off he's got made
in two indeed and queen h8
if he doesn't find that that would be
surprising uh but he's winning in like
80 different ways because the
black Bishop the black Rook have not
done anything and this is the problem
with bortnick's play sometimes is he's
amazing he has great tactical awareness
he's very sharp but sometimes his
openings are his Achilles heel and then
he gets in positions like this where he
hasn't moved his Queen side pieces but
dude I mean one and a half minutes for
Shimano he's taking 30 seconds now on a
maiden two queen Diego and queen h8 is
you can find this while skydiving and
okay 95 he's missed it but it doesn't
matter or does it now you don't want to
give Alexandra portnick any additional
opportunities and this is shocking
he'll be up a full piece I'm not too
worried about his chances here but he
did Miss Checkmate too so that should
make everybody watching at home you
should feel better than even super
strong Grandmasters miss checkmated two
moves
and I think particularly a lot of people
in the chat they like to they get very
surprised it happens right GMS don't
have automatic pattern recognition
especially if it's a less conventional
mating pattern it this certainly was a
less conventional pattern with a queen
mating from h8 supported by Knight on F7
support Nick is going to keep trying
he's gonna lose this game let's go
really quickly to Ronaldo Terry's end
game against Dimitri I was going to say
Dimitri fatasev uh Dimitri on draken and
it looks like on draken is pushing
through for another Victory Dimitri is
back in good form
I think we see the problem for white and
it's not just a bishop against a knight
this even material but it feels like
blacks up a pawn because white has
doubled bee pawns if you could take the
B5 pawn and put it on F3 I don't think
we'd be talking about a problem at all
for white we're talking in a stable
Advantage because the Knight can hop
around but now the Knight does hop back
but King can come up to F5 King G5 now
if Rook goes back D2 the King goes to F4
and you know the king is gonna hop into
G3
yeah this one's essentially over we're
so used to Excellence from Dimitri and
Drake and but defeating Renato Terry
with the black pieces is no easy matter
he is unbelievably solid he's still an I
am and name only but he's over 2500 feet
he's gonna be a grand master as soon as
he gets his third Norm
this is not his game though I think
black can even go E3 and deflect The
Rook from the G2 Pawn a little bit of
work still required for black but on
Dragon's got just enough time to make it
happen there we go
I wouldn't be surprised if Rook takes E4
even one I was just gonna make the point
that black has so many past pawns that
sometimes you can even give away
material but Rook C4 is excellent you
win The Rook Rook exchange but first
involving a sacrifice uh Rook takes A4
might also work so he can go for that
but instead he plays Bishop B4
Tanya he's still winning but I tend to
worry when people make moves that don't
immediately end the game like others
would have and I worry when you're
dealing with a rampaging Knight and
you've got only 26 seconds he's just
repeated moves once Dimitri not as
confident as we're used to seeing him in
time scrambles Rook F2
and Renato's gonna keep trying Rook
takes a fiber F5 that's a great find but
I'll drag it there Rook at five game
over where's Bishop D2 also good
but he does he really want to take that
Knight I don't think so no and if he
plays Bishop F4 trying to knock the Rook
off of the fifth rank it's still sd5 so
Dimitri can't he needs to press that
final bit of the gas pad
okay oh he's just taking his pawns yeah
before and Rook G4
and there's importantly that white Rook
can't get to A7 in time Rook G7 might be
a useful move you could probably move
the king and win this way because it's
Rook H4 at the end so yeah it was
important that white was not able to
steal that pawn at in time and not King
H3 should end the game or this and Terry
resigns because the king will stop the
Pawns rasulov of ugar takes down matia's
blue bum as well so a pretty big upset
like Juan Glenn beats Sergey azarov
we've got a couple of games still
remaining uh gotta save and fresna they
draw their game kind of as we expected
yeah that one looked pretty even so
right now we have five people what
perfect three to three what is this that
was a checkmate by uh delivered by Paco
Vallejo pons against a very strong Anton
demcinco we also have Min Lee who is
still playing so I'm jumping around here
a little bit but I want to catch the
tail end of the last few games oh four
does that win
he misses it he plays C6
behind forward
Rook F4 would have won that is super
instructive so when we get a moment we
can try to show but this is still not an
easy draw black is down a pawn but man
has the activity to make the draw you
had to avoid King C3 there because that
would have gotten obscured I think he's
gonna hold though King B2 and King A2
can be tried but black is checking on C2
white simply can't defend the a pawn
without exposing himself to some checks
or can he
you win the game
that's so easy to miss and kick to D4
such precise defense by men but King B2
and white as winning chances yes because
if your Rook sits on B3 the King goes A2
Rook H5 to A5 is the threat
Rook C5 or K5 but black will check from
the side Rook C2 the king's cut off so
there could be Woody chairs with the B
Pawn
but if you push too early black will
play Rook B3 and any pawn end game is
going to be a draw if black can win the
b-pawn Obviously good point so Rook B2
now
okay oh he's waiting for Rook B3 I think
he wants like rugby then Rook B2 and
then push the beep on
I don't think he's gonna make it happen
though mid is up to 15 seconds now and
he's basically waiting he's waiting and
waiting and the moment white shark
leaves the second rank black starts
delivering the lateral checks the moment
white plays B5 black plays Rook B3 I
just don't think white can circumvent
those problems and it's super important
that the king with the D4 not to B5
because then The Rook wanted to see if I
would check the king would have been
forced backwards Black's King being
active is what's helping him save this
game
and Kozak is going to discover that he
could have forced the winning Pawn end
game he's going to be kicking himself
this would have been a big win but let's
Juan man I mean we're so used to seeing
defensive Excellence from him not sure
exactly how many points these players
have I would guess estimate one out of
two so uh they'll be on 50 most likely
and uh Min just a couple of moves away
from holding a very impressive draw
against the Hungarian Grand Master yeah
they're gonna go to one and a half out
of three which is an even score and
that's not bad considering how difficult
this field is it's pretty much all
Grandmasters but it's going to be some
disappointment for uh Kozak because he
had that win and he probably felt like
he had good winning chances in here he's
gonna try to push B5 if King B5 is Rook
C2 and that's why this Rook keeps
sliding back and forth oh and Rook B3 B6
is so easy to miss it's easy to assume
that white has to trade but wait a
second let's Juan I think he's gotta go
Rook G7 and Rook B7 exactly he's gonna
chase the pawn down but banging his Rook
to G8 now don't go over G7 because B7
Rook B8 and rook and a pawn Rook is a
draw so he's gonna take A4 but that's an
easy draw
fantastic defense at this point you
don't care about opposition when there's
an a pawn opposition doesn't matter as
long as your King has access to the
corner Square it's a dry would take with
a king and I think ozak uh is going to
force the trade of Rooks here and
acquiesce to the inevitable a draw is
agreed and a missed opportunity 40 moves
back at this point uh when Rook D3
uh was played Rook at fourcheck was
indeed a winning Pawn in game in this
position
yeah oh just the King goes back to E5 so
the password doesn't promote but black
is tied up to defense of the pawn white
will stick his King in front of the F
Pawn and at some point the black king
will have to go to D5 and C6 the white
king goes F4 F5 and it doesn't look
immediately winning but the the concept
is there the principle of Chess that you
have a connected pass Pawn protected and
black has a lone passer
and one of the biggest problems that
black has to keep in contact with the c
Pawn if you play King F6 in a position
like this white can start going King D5
and kc6 and White's Pawn is always going
to be faster so black has to stick to
the uh left side of the board and when
you do that white keeps approaching the
F Bond so it's a very instructive end
game to analyze it teaches you a lot
about the way that King Activity Works
in Pawn end games and the importance of
a protected aspawn but all of that is in
the past now uh no pun intended no pun
intended
um nice because round four is upon us
Robert
upon us look at you keep going you won't
stop and I don't want to stop I won't
stop no I'm Gonna Roll let's go to uh
maybe farugia against Levon aronian whoa
yup sorry I misclicked but what game was
that
I misclicked into it it's an even more
fascinating game Sorry that was a mouse
slip but yeah let's go back to the
massage on Tony Haro game what do we
have here what is this it's a Carroll
Khan
it's a pawn sacrifice and is white just
gonna play Bishop D3 and go for the
light squares after the pawn E6 is
captured
had white is really putting some ketchup
and moussard on the king side
that was that was pretty good you're
you're on a roll I won't call you butter
but you are making everybody happy with
your jokes but I think that black should
not take on E6 isn't this one of those
positions where you play around the pawn
somehow you don't mind EF King F7
because if you do yeah it's weird yeah
Queen D6 is what I thought
and it's weird because I mean most
people without any experience would take
on E6 automatically the problem is that
white establishes control of the square
in front of the pawn and Black's Bishop
is buried beneath a pile of rubble the
difference in a paradoxical way yes wax
King is weaker but it's easier to
engineer E7 E5 and that is a crucial
Pawn breakthrough uh Robert actual pod
break they're not a pun because then the
bishop opens up and listen whites pushed
all these pawns and felt really cool
about it he's gonna pay the price for it
what comes around goes around on the
king side yeah it may have felt cool at
first but now you're gonna feel the
breeze in front of your king and not in
a good way you're going to be shivering
when the white king goes to the king
side it may fall victim to an attack so
let's not just think because Black's
King has moved that only Black's King is
in trouble as you're pointing out the
Dark Sword control for black will be
beneficial and E5 is definitely the move
on my radar let's open up the center of
the board Bishop C5 comes out Rook to E8
things of that nature it makes it seem
scary for white
yeah David is going to develop an a ton
of counter play on the center and on the
king side I think the Lesser evil might
be for for white to Castle because the
G3 Square it is protected by White's
night otherwise Queen G3 check would
have been a devastating check now a big
decision for black when does he play e75
he wants to prepare it by completing his
Queen side development I like Black's
position I'm gonna say I I like the
counter play associated with E5 I don't
like White's lack of development and
White's permanent weaknesses on the king
side I don't like the possibility of
Queen before Chuck Jules is gonna have
to be very very precise if he wants to
justify his Brazen it's all variation
play in the opening yeah I'm worried for
white because look at Black's pieces you
have two knights out and developed the
queen is also developed for white you
have a knight on E2 and otherwise all
you've done is move pawns so you're
pointing out Queen before check ideas
that's important but rookie 8 and E5
that happens really quickly and White's
King on E1 not safe if you go over to G1
excuse me you're not very safe over
there there oh gosh these are not easy
decisions for white
my favorite expression in these cases is
from the frying pan Into the Fire
wherever you are with your king you're
not going to be safe white is trying to
ensure relative safety like reclaiming
the B8 H2 diagonal now E5 comes with
even greater effect though because it
hits the bishop 25.95 maybe waking
Castle in that position and hope to get
away with it this is going to be a
fascinating middle game Robert
yeah this definitely will be fussing and
we'll let the players try to figure out
what to do here it's super complicated
let's go back to that levada Ronin
against Eliza faruga game maybe yeah
spicy as well yeah yes and this matchup
is one that I think everyone is excited
for and it's very important for the
tournament standings their position so
far not the most exciting because we
haven't seen a single Pawn trade uh but
these are difficult positions and the
strike for each side will black play D5
is that available to him or is that weak
in the E5 Pawn uh for white you're not
really wanting to play D4 too soon
because E4 gets loose so it's not easy
to determine the pawn breaks
I think chat will find this pretty
relatable I hate playing these positions
for both sides and it's one of those
cases where you play from the black side
you think man this sucks I don't have
counter play I don't know when to play
D5 then you start playing this from the
white side you're like wait a second my
opponent could just go D5 and I'm worse
so no matter how you slice it
structurally positionally this is really
complex because there's so many
decisions one wise man said that the
pawn the side that controls the pawn
breaks controls the position or well
here both sides have a bunch of Pawn
breaks white is B5 and A5 and breaks on
the queen side black has D5 and
sometimes even G5 the engineer some Pawn
play on the king side white also has D4
so wherever you look there's gonna be
Pawn breaks there's going to be
complexity and D4 is on the board my
friend but look at Levon the guy is
unbothered by this you push your Pawn
forward good for you my knight comes to
G6 and unlike from the C6 square that
Knight can't be kicked out very easily
and it could also hop forward into F4 so
if we talk piece by piece here and I'm
not talking about a Kelly Clarkson song
I'm looking at the Knight on G6 is being
better than one of its counterparts of
the white Knights the bishop on B6 I
actually like more than the bishop on B2
because the bishop on B2 is a defensive
piece unless you can make C4 happen and
and he does it right then as soon as I
trash talk it he says you're trash I'm
getting my Bishop out in the open and
this could be scary for black because
Knight F4 might be taken out of the
equation with d takes E5 ideas but then
the bishop on A7 is happy it's a game of
give and take Dania I'm giving you the
mic because I'm really unsure whose
position I prefer oh that was smooth I'd
put it this way I'd hedge my bets a
little bit in a bullet game no question
I'm taking black I think's handling a
space Advantage is incredibly hard when
you're in time pressure for two reasons
first of all you you know it's like the
Roman Empire you need to keep an eye on
the far-flung regions of your Empire
where you're on the defensive side
everything's compact everything's well
protected uh the second reason is that
uh White has more decisions to make
white has to decide when to play D5
whether to play C5 and B5 now white
controls most of the pawn breaks and
that's not a good thing if you're in
time pressure but has over six minutes
on the clock objectively I think white
almost always has an edge in these types
of positions and Lavon he has some
decisions of his own in particular is he
gonna play Knight F4 is he going to play
he takes D4 although that is not a move
Robert that I would really consider
making unless you're fully on the
defensive because it gives white really
nice bind over the D5 Square it gives
white snipe the prospect of reaching F5
so I like alireza here objectively but
lavoni's played so quickly he's left
himself with a lot of time to handle the
defensive task here and now he is
bringing all of uh the toys to the
nursery party
and one thing that maybe laying blow
beneath the surface the queen on D7 may
end up on G4 and white skin could be in
trouble because you may just push that
pawn on D5 thing I'm kicking your Rook
back that has to be a good move but I'm
kicking a rook back that has to be a
good move
whoa but he but he put C5 instead we
might see instead a ton of captures in
the center but the point I was trying to
make is once the Knight lands an F4 if
the queen can also land on G4 that's
very dangerous for the white King on G1
listen if I could commentate with Robert
Hess I'd be a happy man but you can't
have it all and The Rook on E6 has a
couple of things to say in regards to
the queen making its way to G4 but I
would consider even the move rookie 8 to
your point that would create a very
serious threat of Knight of four Queen
G4 and what exactly is White's next move
going to be in the center right what is
white going to capture probably Pawn
takes C5 and Knight C4 if like an
engineer a queen trade then black is
going to pay a very steep price for this
bishop which is now fully out of
commission
yeah that's what you want because some
people may think let me take on D6 first
and then take on E5 but in the bishop on
A7 is a happy piece it slices across the
board an ideal situation is if D4 and D6
pawns are gone from the board that
Bishop on A7 is not going to see the
position and well Levant brings his
Queen into B5 if you've allowed me to
take the square I will occupy it he's
attacking the B4 Pawn then I know the
engine wasn't thrilled about it but I
actually really like that move I like it
as well because I mentioned a queen
shade favors white well not exactly if
you play Queen A4 here and after the
queen trade your Center could very
easily collapse because you haven't had
the time to play D take C5
agreed and queen A4 is one of those
moves that do you really want to play it
I mean it's yes you offer Queen trade
black is that obligated to take you uh
if you take on B5 a takes B5 black is
capturing towards the center as well so
these are really difficult decisions for
these two players at the moment I think
that alireza he probably likes his
chances with all of his pawns storming
up the queen side uh but that night
coming to F4 it's D3 that's a long-term
issue that he'll have to deal with
it is indeed and I think we'll leave
alireza farusha to make these difficult
decisions as you call them you might be
better on the board on the eval bar but
practically speaking Lavon has very
serious chances in a big time advantage
to boot my eye is caught by a
fascinating position in Vladimir feta
saves game how many times have we said
that probably all nine rounds he's got a
wild tactical Affair against a very
promising young Indian Grandmaster and
he has just sacrificed the Knight so we
can jump into this position at the right
moment
wow he gives up a night on E3 but I
don't think he's going for an attack
he's trying to collect pawns he just
took one Pawn on E3 he'll take a second
on D3 and win all of Black's pieces
start capturing on D3 E3 is loose
there's a problem down the diagonal by
the way the E4 Knight and the F3 Knight
behind it so white is better and I'm not
entirely sure why because I'm looking at
this position and I feel like Black's
counter play is not just sufficient but
maybe ample
yeah Knight takes C3 Knight takes E3 not
only are we gonna lose the E3 Pawn but
you could lose a knight in the process
you might have to drop the Knight back
to D2 at the end of the line now
apparently in this position black had a
crazy move F7 F5 which would have opened
the f file it also would have opened the
G file
name a player who's gonna make that move
in a rapid game I don't think Vladimir
can be blamed at all we're playing
Knight takes C3 and liquidating into a
position that's going to be a lot easier
to play
yeah a lot easier for him to play I
think White's test is more difficult
because the three pawns if they're
stopped then the minor pieces they're
happy but in this position look at
Black's Bishops you have Knight F6 check
as you're pointing out but here after
Knight F6 the bishop takes on F6 you do
not want to take with the pawn to open
the G file uh so we'll see 1963 check
you have to take back Queen takes D3 and
now you don't have time for Knight F6 it
doesn't really thread anything
you don't but you can play Knight E to
D2 and I think the reason the eval bar
is a little bit pessimistic is because
after Rook takes E3 white moves the king
off up to F2 coordinating the Rooks and
the move Bishop C5 there this could be
hard to visualize for some people I'm
not gonna make the moves on the board
because I think we're gonna see this on
the actual board white can intercepts
the bishop with Bishop to D4 and a
little bit later I'm jumping the gun
here Robert but the pawn on C7 is a
long-term weakness and white has just
the perfect way to attack it by bringing
the Rook to C1 there's also some
positional weaknesses on the queen side
may seem unimportant right now but if
white repels the uh initiative and all
of these factors are going to make their
presence felt
the good news though for federal save is
his Bishop on B7
unopposed on a very long diagonal and he
will have three pawns for a night so I
think that even if he doesn't
immediately win the game which is unlike
it happened he does have the confidence
that what remains in his position is
sufficient to at least hold the game but
I agree with you if white can play
Knight E to D2 here and then Parry off
the threats it would be a position that
both players have chances a three result
game
result game indeed and white is burning
a ton of clock trying to figure out that
move he's finally played it but he's
down on four minutes on the clock uh
more like three minutes that is but uh
Vladimir has I agree great practical
chances in the end game but things have
finally settled down here so I think a
good opportunity for us to keep going
around the horn and reviewing some of
the other top games of course Lavon uh
Dimitri on draken a couple of players
with three out of three Dimitri has a
relatively tame position against Eduardo
so I'll give you the final say we can go
to on Dragon's game uh we can go to
musard against Anton gihara which is
continuing to heat up yep that's
definitely go there because that
position is really awesome you see the
king did get the G1 for white that's the
good news the black King's still in F7
and white hasn't attacked the king so
you dragged the black king out and
what's about to happen castling by hand
the King goes back to Jade the Rooks are
connected for black and you're not going
to play G5 here I mean you you can do
that I just think that you're helping
black out what's in the path of the Rook
on f8 the Knight on F6 so I think that
G5 you're hoping for an attack you're
just not gonna get one
yeah it's a crazy situation where the
fact that you have moved your pawns away
from their initial positions is both a
blessing and a curse it might give you
the attacking Firepower that you need
but it is also consigning the king to a
lifetime of danger especially given uh
black Strokes which are really x-raying
these crucial files black as Knight
takes G4 ideas after the king drops back
the other thing though is that the
Knight on E3 is actually trapped now
it's imprisoned but it's got a nice
hotel room it's got a it's got a flat
screen TV it's kind of chilling and
white is no easy way to reinforce the
pressure on the night because you can
never move the Knight out of E2 which
would be necessary if you had wanted The
Rook from you on to attack the Knight
because the G3 Knight will also be
hanging
and now that you mentioned it it's not
complete out of the question for black
in order to give the Knight some real
estate to play the move D5 to D4 I don't
typically want to sacrifice a pawn but
you can't take it the Knight on E2
because the G3 dinosaurs and he goes G5
this is a problem done and you know
what's happening from the very opening
what was all in with ambitious play and
an attack but here we need five oh Queen
E5 yeah
you just spawned with that move lpdo
loose pieces do drop off
goodbye
I wasn't expecting minus three or
whatever the bar says I can't really see
it it's too small uh my screen here but
it looks it's completely winning for
black because if you're dropping G5 then
you have no attack at all blacks up a
pawn and White's Kings in even worse
shapes it goes G6 but now the king can
go back to G8 and unless you can get a
rook on the H file and a queen there
going to h8 there's nothing
I think a lot of players when they look
at this position they get very scared
because you recognize the mating pattern
you see that pawn on G6 but you have to
look kind of creely as you're saying
even putting one piece on the H file
that's easy to achieve what are you
threatening the H7 square is permanently
defended white is busted here but black
needs a couple more accurate moves I
would consider starting with Queen G5 in
order to pin this Knight and generate
potential tactical threats like Knight
to H5 but listen three minutes on the
clock we start is such a tricky Defender
he's not going down uh gentle into that
good night no he certainly isn't I like
your ideas with both Queen G5 and maybe
starting with Knight H5 uh maybe there's
no big difference between the two but
it's funny we're talking about the
Knight F6 being a Defender but as we
kind of were indicating as well there is
no attack so even if Knight moves from
F6 you need your queen on H7 not a rook
there so Knight H5 looks very powerful
for black let's trade pieces remove some
of the Defenders from the white king and
because the Knight on E3 is an aggressor
and then E2 is just sitting passively
defending black is much better here with
both of the Rooks coordinated as well
that's a great breakdown a knight H5 was
the best move that would have kept a
minus four advantage he's gone Queen G5
and this is the drawback white gets The
Rook to H2 and you're not in time to
play Knight H5 so I put that idea in
David's mind I feel like knowing his
playing style he might go C5 and D4 and
just try to accentuate the pressure but
if you give white too long Robert guess
what in H1 Rook G1 we were dismissive
about White's attacking chances but give
the Rooks enough Tempe and there will be
hell to pay if you allow some sort of a
discovery with Knight F5 so I actually
feel like Queen G5 might have been a
serious practical mistake even if it
keeps an objectively winning position
and Planck's C5 and D4 is super
difficult because the black kings in a
mating net if that pawn on D5 were not
there look at that diagonal it's opened
up and the blacking could be in danger
it wouldn't lead to Checkmate just yet
black has a number of pieces to protect
the king with but Rook E6 is a great
move let's keep our position solid and
the G6 Pawn is a target we can play
Knight F6 to D7 for example and go after
the G6 Pawn directly so I like Rook E6
you can also double your Rooks on the
e-file if the 93 ever becomes attacked
so really good decision making by black
in this position and with two minutes
and 30 seconds approximately per side I
think that black chances are great yeah
he's still very much in control I don't
want to over hype light's chances but
Rook to H3 is a sneaky move because it
reinforces the Knight on uh G3 and you
also can't fall asleep on the prospect
of F3 F4 right now though it just gives
black the G4 square and makes things
even worse so I wonder what is Black's
White's next move after an itd7 is he
trying to set up some sort of check on
h8 I don't think he can make that happen
anything come to mind maybe oh 94 94
yeah oh that's the idea he protected his
Knight over there on G3 allowing for
Knight D4 uh King H1 Rook G10 still we
have to consider those uh but yeah
Knight can hop to D4 because the 9g3 is
defended this game is so sharp and now
David Anton who is down to one minute 45
seconds to calculate this
no this is getting hard
oh my lions and what are some even yeah
as I say what moves come to mind for you
besides Knight D7 or Rook FTE C5 I think
you might have to play C5 and play
prophylactically as anti-climactic as it
is you have to cover the D4 square and
mustard continues to generate serious
threats now Queen takes G6 runs into
Knight F4 but the eval bar drops even
further there's probably some immediate
win here and it's just D4 just driving
the pawn in reinforcing the Knight
you yeah why it's just running out of
ideas here
so Queen D2 stepping backwards didn't
seem correct King H1 was one of the
ideas we talked about but great play
from black taking away the DeForest uh
Square because that Knight wanted to hop
forward and now the 93 is safe which was
the queen can move away I still don't
walk into a fork before trying to
undermine the defensive D4 Pawn I like
that but why not just B6 he's gonna try
C3 and queen A2 I know Jules
I played him enough Blitz Games to know
exactly I always dirty mind thanks here
but that's not gonna help that's like
trying to pinch a dinosaur I mean queen
A2 doesn't even do anything anymore
yeah the dinosaur looks more like Barney
here you know it's not it can be scary
for some I had nightmares with Barney
when I was a kid but for others it's
like yeah there's nothing going on Rook
takes F3 take that pawn go after all of
White's forces the King on G1 is In
Harm's Way
yeah White's position is repulsive
suffering from halitosis remember that
cgc commentary I remember that where you
were surprised that I knew what it meant
and I don't think either player has
stinky breath they probably brush their
teeth but a dinosaur undoubtedly did
man that was that was so smooth I really
have no words I don't think Joel mustard
has any moves here and he might not have
any time after the next move he is
getting massacred on the king side David
on tone is cooking with some fish oil
he's gonna have four to four and uh he
is trailed by a pack of dinosaurs
including Sam shankland lots of people
on three and a four Robert but uh all
the top games are still going and
Dimitri on draken is trying to convert
an extra exchange against etorizaga and
I think he's not doing such a bad job of
it let's look at it because this one
looks like a win for black let's go to
that other game and what is happening
here it is Five Pawns for black four for
white the B for it Bishop C3 that
configuration is actually really
annoying to take down because they
protect each other and if you leave the
B file don't be surprised that pawn
starts pushing up the board so Dania
closer to a win or white or a draw and
black is happy knowing Dimitri and
knowing his hours of realizing
advantages I would I would give the edge
to White largely because black is also
down a minute so I'm draken he's going
to go E4 at some point maybe even now
and what you want to try to do is get a
pair of Rooks off the board if you get a
pair of Rooks off the board it might
still be a draw because of the presence
of this additional beep on there's that
e form of I think Dimitri's gonna push
this for a long time he can try Rook B8
and Rook E8 so plenty of opportunities
left for white obviously objectively
this should be a Toronto question about
it speaking of draws looks like olly
Reza's game is approximately balanced so
we should go to that one as well at some
point all right
okay I like what you're saying about
this one by the way though just about
aha there could be like a checkmating
net with G4 and G5 from White so you
have to be careful but let's go
elsewhere this game it does look not it
up for the moment
it does indeed uh so I'm changing my
mind I think turizaga might be able to
save it let's quickly check into Ali
Reza's enemies Lavon I was about to say
this game is going to end in a draw for
sure now I'm not so sure because the
pawn structure has gotten the imbalance
on the king side but they are about to
have a repetition of moves if alireza
accedes to it and he does not with 16
seconds left he pulls a dingly red and
declines the repetition
but that could backfire because the E4
Pawn was covering D5 and F5 so Knight G7
comes to mind I want to reroute that
Knight into F5 with check and go after
your pawns and that was a big Choice all
of White's forces look at that Knight
and C4 Knight D3 Bishop C3 Pawn F4 Pawn
E5 they're staring in that Center there
but you have given an important light
Square to Black retreating night mode
how many times do we say it it's the
hardest type of move to find and this is
where lavon's excellent time management
You could argue he plays too fast this
is where he leaves himself with that
additional 30 45 seconds which allows
him to find these difficult moves and
time scrambles I think Knight G7 could
potentially be met with ef and 95 no
that blunder is a fork to 94. alireza
has to be super accurate here and I
think he is being accurate and look at
that you could have taken on F5 but good
awareness from alireza that he would
have doubled the black pawns but they
would have been undouble shortly and the
black king would go E6 D5 and so on so
B7 is under attack oh King E6 out of
four
oh that's a that was a mistake to
capture then very bad move by Lavon I
think he forgot that white vacates the
F4 Square for his other Knight which is
now a huge positional threat the G6 Pawn
could be lost and White's epon could
Rumble forward under the right
circumstances the g-pawns are trouble
the B7 is under attack I don't think the
B7 Pawn is that important so I think
that white knight F E3 giving up B7 if
you take on B7 the Knight goes to D5 and
hits the bishop hits the white B Pawn as
well he does take it but uh E5 is loose
King E6 is now possible because the F4
square is also under control
Knight back to D6 is available to
alireza farouza how does black Stave off
the pressure because white is have a
pawn well something like 93 comes to
mind keep an eye on Forks keep an eye on
the F4 Square which if it's relinquished
by the D3 Knight would lead to some
trouble a trade on E3 followed by Knight
D6 things are stabilizing here now King
E6 Robert is still possible
although he has allowed a check on F4
but E5 is now hanging because the bishop
is off the board so you go to King takes
E5 Knight G6 King D4 King C3 and go
after those Queen side pawns this is a
three result game I know that sounds
crazy probably white is the one in the
driver's seat alireza has to quickly go
around and take that H5 pawn and Levon
is going to try to take on D6 in return
so he was it why did he do this so he
gave up the pawn like this he just wants
Knight D5 takes B4 oh and maybe they're
not enough pawns remaining for white
that's the issue night before Bishop A5
do not go King F6 what do you do though
Bishop takes D6 CD and Lavon trying to
stop the pawn with his Knight no no
yeah he walked in the fork he walked
into the floor
Knight C5 Knight B7 takes a five
unbelievable that extra Tempo allowed
black to win the H Pawn and win the rest
of bites pawns alireza missed it the
first time
yes and oh who might be seven and look
at this you know why that's brilliant
because on the server it's game drawn by
insufficient material the reason why is
with best play from the side that's down
two minor pieces it is a draw now you
can walk into a Checkmate that does
happen sometimes but it's I mean you
should Google this two nights Checkmate
it is a theoretical draw and the engine
excuse me the server concludes as much
whoa how did this happen sorry to cut
you off those are great points I just
wanted to flip in the dragon game which
I think is actually going to end in a
draw despite the fact that he's now got
a full extra exchange and that's because
the torizaga is he playing for a win now
is black voting for a win
oh I guess you can't go King C1 it's
very important because then the bishop
could be captured oh I can and you
promote you lose your Queen Bishop G7
Bishop G7
oh my gosh
for black it was
oh so play King play King B3 here play
King B3 it's driving you draw they
repeated oh my gosh I thought he was
trying to avoid repetition but they have
repeated moves just to show that Daniel
that instead of King C2 there uh just a
moment ago that Bishop back to G7 was
winning because the Rook can't leave the
first Rank and then next one will be
king C2 and this is the chief difference
right Rook D1 King A2 you go around from
the other side and the bishop is safely
restraining the pawn and white amazingly
is unable to get to the uh the F5 Pawn
King D3 King C1 King C4 King look at
this King D2 King and King E3 black is
in time and the bishop cuts off the king
from the E5 score King E6 King F4 and
black will obviously give up the bishop
for the pawn what a chance missed by
three zaga to win that with black
so far down the line and it looked like
it couldn't get losing for black but the
bishop cut off the king from E5 so great
save from iterizaga I'm drinking I'm
sure will be a bit disappointed but
we're four rounds of the books I only
see one player with a perfect score
one player and that player is David
Antonio gihara the Spanish Phenom he
will be facing most likely Levon aronian
the highest rated player with three and
a half out of four we've got one game uh
in its closing stages it is sun called
Gupta Indian Grandmaster against uh the
guy who defeated Arch and Eric icy in
round one we haven't heard uh Arjun Eric
icy's name again he has been scuffling
this tournament and that's not because
arjun's a bad players because this
tournament is brutal
it certainly is and well this position
looks brutal for white you are down in
exchange and unlike in that a turizago
game there are no past pawns for white
in fact White's also down a pawn and
black has pawns that are running up the
queen side so this looks like a very
one-sided Affair and that means two big
scalps taken down by uh by new bear
shock here and he missed King F7 which
should have ended the game immediately
it seems like he hasn't made any
progress in like five years in fact he
is making progress he's eliminating
what's kingside pawns uh Queen side
pawns that is and now the king side
pawns are gone
and now it's resign time
that's unfortunate
yeah this is game over and two big wins
I mean that's a great start so far
absolutely and you might say well why
are these IMS playing the tournament
they don't have a chance guess what
that's why there are over 50 spots
across the three divisions with
excellent prizes across the board so
even if you're not necessarily playing
for first place you're playing to gain
invaluable experience Robert these are
10 minute games these are serious
serious games for these younger and less
lower rated players which gives them a
big push in classical career as well
it does indeed and well four games are
in the books we have one player David
Anton in the lead with a perfect four to
four down at this is the moment where
the players they get a little bit of
break the fair play Team make sure that
everything is settled all players are on
cameras from multiple angles so uh it's
okay we're not worried about that but
the good news for the players especially
those who are trying to make those top
10 spots to buy for division one they
get a little bit of rest Donnie and I
will do the same but when we return it
is more from this chess kid cup playing
when you return
[Music]
thank you
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
we're here in Toronto for the global
Championship I got Fabiano caruana with
me you don't need to talk yet I got
James kids we're gonna see who
recognizes these guys out of the out of
the random passerbys and we're gonna ask
them some fun questions about Chess for
five bucks do you know who this is
no okay active an actor well you see
this guy
any idea who he is somebody very famous
he is
this is actually 50 Cent's brother his
name is Daryl that's right it goes by
75. you want to play chess okay so what
is he a player or something obsessed
he is a chess player I'm not but he is I
play on the side yeah I've been taking
some coaching lessons from Grandmaster
Canty over here recently over your
calculation over everything what's your
name again sir my name is Jamie what's
your name
I already knew it it's
Daniel yeah Daniel nerdinsky
there it is
on the attack baby on the attack if he
wins I know the guys at chess.com we'll
get him a diamond membership okay do you
know what that is yes okay is that
something you want yes yeah okay look at
you look is this a London yo we got a
pro here with the London London how'd it
go
I should have said youtube.com
csq pod what is the URL of this YouTube
actually don't remember okay
look at the pot
welcome to check with mace the only
podcast by chess pieces for chess pieces
I'm a rook and I'm a pawn let me ask you
this you ever feel like you're
undervalued absolutely everyone's like
oh pawns they can only move one square
they can't go backwards maybe we don't
want to go backwards maybe we're focused
on the future yeah I feel that sometimes
I wonder why we're even protecting it
King he wasn't elected through a
democratic process maybe I want to be
king dude I think about that every day
yeah okay real quick shout out to our
sponsor hellofresh I don't use them
because I'm a chess piece but I'm sure
they're great
thank you
foreign
We Are One Step Closer to seeing the
chess finals of the Olympic Esports
series 2023 thousands of contenders
battle it out to reach the preliminaries
which will commence Thursday May 4th we
are streaming all the action right here
on twitch.tv slash chess Donya and I
will have the call for that as well but
right now this is the chess kid cop the
Third Leg of the Champions Chester we're
in the playing Phase and we are the nine
round Swiss Donya only one player has a
four to four score that is David Anton
I'm excited for the next five rounds I
am as well David and Zone has a big X on
his back and how many times Robert have
we seen players get off to a hot start
and they're facing a lebonaroni and a
Dimitri on Drake and our generic icy and
before you know it you've got four out
of seven so David cannot rest on his
Laurels he needs at least a draw here if
he wants to stay atop the tournament
standings because there is a big big
group with three and a half out of four
indeed there are they all are hungry
they want to chase down the leader and
David on top will have a difficult
pairing so who is he playing in this
fifth round of action
he is playing Lavon aronian and we will
start from that game uh because David is
in first place he is playing the highest
rated player who's got half a point less
than him that is standard pairing uh
pairing technique and standard technique
in the opening as well we've got some
sort of slightly weird Italian where
both wires have staked their claim
Robert on the queen side
the type of game that I've often seen
from Mickey Adams and those players who
they trade on E3 F takes E3 they play
for uh an edge on the king side where
the Rook on F1 would have an open file
but black just says yeah well you could
take me on C5 as well my double pawns
aren't so bad so who is going to end up
with the double Pawns
yeah I never know what you're supposed
to do in these types of positions I'll
tell you one thing which is that Bishop
to B6 is out of the question here that's
a common way to try to trade on your own
terms but only when the pawn is on A7
here I think Lavon does the most
straightforward thing he trades he plays
Bishop E6 and will we see a quick draw
after the trade in Knight C3 we
literally have a completely symmetrical
position of blackplay's H6 but for
deviate on tone I think it's largely a
question of approach and methodology if
he wants to keep some life on the board
I would play Knight B to D2 and keep the
tension
I do think it's smart from Lavon aronian
that you know at this stage you don't
have to go all in so if he can just
equalize and make a draw against the
very strong David Anton who's Taken part
in the Champions chess tours of recent
years so I feel like for him he's just
I'm gonna make a draw I'm gonna try to
keep my momentum four and a half out of
five that's a great start for David but
C3 indicates Queen B3 is next yeah I
think Naveed is still trying to squeeze
a little bit of life out of this game
but of course that could potentially
backfire I mean if black plays D5 then
white has to figure out a way to
maintain his control over the center
because the last thing I would want to
do is Rectify Black's Pawn structure and
hand over control of the center so I'm
Lavon I'm seriously contemplating
uh fighting for the advantage of D5 he
plays it
and I just want to note Donya that
something funny is happening it's not
funny for one player particular but
Dimitri kolars not at his computer
screen because his clock is running
against Vladimir photos you need to know
when the brakes are all other players
did so for kolars I hope that he goes
back soon but if you're ferrosev you're
looking at this like wait if my opponent
doesn't show up I get a free win with
the black pieces he'll certainly take
that
he will and I've gone off on that a
couple of times Robert is a player in
these tournaments you have to be at your
computer 99 of the time during the break
you go up go to the bathroom get some
water sit your you know what back down
and wait for the gains to start that is
just a no-brainer and we see this happen
way too often with players who I don't
know what they do they go onto the dance
floor they go to a restaurant between
the games you got to be at your computer
just like you would be at a real board
in an over the board tournament
yes and well this game is slow moving
done any more exciting games that we can
head on over to
yes there are there are plenty because
there are plenty of players with three
and a half out of four alireza ferrugia
this game is setting up Sergey volkov
and Eduardo Victoria have already drawn
their game so they uh are both on four
out of five now let's go to all the rest
of ferocious game against Gregorio Parn
because we have a wide open Center a
Catalan that has turned
uncharacteristically tactical and a more
pleasant position without question I
think for uh Gregorio par and thus far
yeah but one of the big decisions is
when or if does white play the move E5
because if you play the move E5 you are
hitting the Knight on F6 you're letting
the Bishops stare at each other but you
also give black that D5 squared you put
it in blue and I would be feeling pretty
blue if I allowed my opponent to hop to
D5 but as you're also indicating Knight
A4 is a very annoying threat trying to
take down that dark Square Bishop so
done it what would you do with the white
pieces here first I'd say and then I
would decide between Knight A4 and
moving the queen right now the ball is
definitely in White's Court I would
consider the move B3 if I'm Grisha
because you the last thing you want is
to give away the bishop the bishop is a
key cog in the machine it keeps the
Knight protected it's staring down the
barrel of the king side so if I'm
Gregory I'm investing one tempo for
prophylactic move you can then drop the
bishop back onto its fianchetto Square
particularly if black x-rays it with
Rook C8 and then you continue in very
typical cattle and fashion
Rook C1 Knight C4 which by the way he's
decided to play immediately so he's
defending tactically against Knight A4
now he's created a counter threat of
Knight takes E6 trying to force Flex
Queen onto a more Awkward spot and this
is a common problem Robert in the
Catalan where Black's Queen actually has
a lot of trouble finding uh 24-hour
parking because if it moves to the C
file you run into Rook C1 or even Knight
B5 if you move to the E file which you
might have to do and you lock the Rook
on f8 that's not something that you do
because you want to do it it's because
you have to do it it's true the E4 Pawn
is in trouble as well so these types of
positions it's all about who is going to
control the more important squares whose
pieces are going to be more active but
something that just happened I have to
note if we go to the Dennis lazovic game
against vasif durability both players
are there but unfortunately as happens
sometimes in online chess there was a
mouse slip on Black's sixth moves see
that King on f8 you see that cake
sitting there it wasn't intentional go
back to move six Donya black was trying
to Castle and instead of castling look
where that King ended up
it's one of the worst and most
infuriating Mouse slips because of the
damage that it does right you might not
seem like such a big yellow castle by
hand well in a position like this where
you've given up control of the center uh
and then let's save and D5 immediately
lazovic no mercy I'd see five Knight T4
oh
oh God
just brutal and I mean you could hardly
blame black for it you see the glyph
there giving it a question mark which
means that it did make Black's position
worse but you know what else made
Black's position worse that Mouse slip
on move six uh yeah just one of those
sad days when you're playing chess and
you're hoping to have a good score and
then your king ends up an f8 and the f
file is open for a white rook and a
queen lands an H5 I think we know what's
gonna happen in this game
I'm Dennis lazovic as a monster he's on
three out of four right now super solid
hard to beat he'll be on four out of
five and he'll join that big Peloton uh
who will be sitting on four out of five
because presumably we'll have quite a
few draws with players on three and a
half out of four Queen td6 vasif is
still going to try as long as he keeps
the F6 Pawn alive this King still can
lift to fight another day Queen H6 Jack
will be met with King E7 then Asif
probably will try to quickly get a rook
to G6 that is still has to show some
technique that's exactly what he's doing
this is amazing this is this is
carpovian right here Knight back to D1
heading for E3 saying I don't care about
the C4 pawn and King E7 is met with
Knight E3 look at that
that is an amazing Vision yeah I know
that that is sweet stuff from Dennis
live now he's gonna take on F6 and you
know if black could have defended that
pawn maybe he had some chances but as
you're indicating Queen G5 you go for
the E5 on Knight E3 push that Bishop
back maybe the Knight comes into F5 uh
the bishop on G2 may end up on H3 at the
right moment keeping that King in a box
on E8 oh no this is really bad news and
also Rook C6 at some moment Rook E6
check is available because the F7
Horsepen too many good ideas but yeah
Rook C6 is a game Ender
this is just not the kind of mistake
that you can commit against someone of
Dennis lazovic's caliber Mike mark my
words he's going to be 2700. I I see it
I think down here that a lot of the top
players already consider him at that
rating it's just how good he is yeah so
let's uh we don't want to look at this
too much longer it is very unfortunate
for vasive durability who Mouse slipped
and played King of Fate he is losing
this game Dennis last week doesn't care
how it's done as long as he gets it done
he'll go to four to five so let's head
on over somewhere else this is too
difficult to look at maybe on draken
against bernatsuki because those are two
more players who are on three and a half
out of four Dimitri and drinking has
already dispatched a couple of strong
players he failed to convert that end
game against Edwardo to rizaga actually
could have lost it at the end but now
he's got the white pieces against Vitaly
bernatsuki and that King's Indian
disaster a massive Kings Queen side
attacker with a knight coming to C4
black hasn't even fight off his ground
yes and put his pants on and he's
already losing his Bishop oh my gosh the
bishop just lost it's trapped in there
and look at this structure white as all
of his pawns on light squares and the
bishop 184 is trapped in enemy territory
so if you just go back a couple moves
Dania when that night went to A4 we
understand what bernowsky was thinking
by bringing the Knight to A4 he doesn't
want to backtrack to B7 because that
Knight is dominated by White's Pawn so
he goes forward but he gets his peace
trapped and this was just a really bad
King's Indian for black
the reality is uh even if B5 didn't
exist after Knight C4 white is
positionally winning because black
hasn't gotten off the ground on the king
side I don't understand how they even
reached a position in which it seems
like white has made six or seven moves
uh to get the queen Side open black has
made one he's played 98 he hasn't even
managed to push the F Pawn in the king's
Indian listen I love the king's Indian
it's a lifelong opening for me but it
can also be very very hard to play in
this rapid time control because you need
to be ultra precise in your move order
you need to know exactly when to attack
on the king side and when to defend on
the queen side if it's Oliver natsuki
this is going to be a forgettable one
for him and another win for demon draken
who is on a rampage
not a player that anyone wants to face
and as we start thinking who might end
the nine after nine rounds in the top
ten reminder to everybody that the top
10 are playing for division one they're
five spots up for grabs against Magnus
Carlson he is not playing in the chess
kit cup he's an over-the-board
tournament that he will be taking part
in so that leaves five spots available
and well that Bishop on A4 has okay no
score is available Rook a one Bishop
takes B5 just take the queen your queen
on C4 is defended by two miners an extra
piece and that is game over Dimitri
rodrigan goes to forward after five
incredible performance by Dimitri I
think we have to jump right to alireza
for rouge's game because it continues to
heat up that Catalan the Center opened
up now the king side has opened up let's
see if Gregorio paren is successfully
handling the tension I think he's not I
think he might have blundered into some
sort of F3 Knight F4 trick look at
alirez's Knights
yeah that is going to be good night to a
minor piece for white I mean F3 the
bishop can take but Knight F4 as you're
indicating the Knight on C4 is loose
there's also kingside pressure the open
file can only favor Black so F3 is a big
opportunity and even if he doesn't play
F3 we just saw how Knight A4 backfired
from bernowsky black can play Knight A4
here and I really don't think you're
gonna complain all right A4 with
threaten Knight C3 F3 is still on the
horizon and I think alireza the fact
that he's thinking
essentially tells you that he sees the
move F3 I love the way alirez is playing
thus far in the tournament he's getting
his types of positions he's just
Unstoppable in situations where he's got
a long lasting attack against his
opponent's king his time management is
excellent as well so you know the rumors
of alireza farusha's demise and chess
are greatly overblown he's still got the
magic
he certainly does and this position is
just one where his Knights are going to
hop into key squares I think F3 it may
not be clear he does play it but at
first glance it's not like black is
winning all this material it's probably
Knight C5 into D3 hits The Rook on E1
hits the Knight on C4 the bishop on F3
is loose and loose pieces drop off so
this is just devastating right now and
farouza pounced he pounced and he's
doing it quickly and confidently Opana
has to figure out some way to stay
afloat here I don't see it though
because if he moves his Knight then
Knight takes E5 and Knight takes F3
would generate even more serious threats
against Dwight's King because without
the protection of your light squared
Bishop black could potentially stick a
queen on e4 I would love to be Ellie
Reza here right now this has been
amazing amazing play how do you beat a
Catalan like this in 26 moves
that just be all there is a farooja that
seems to be the solution and there is no
solution for White's many problems in
the position so we trust alireza fuja to
go to four and a half out of five and
Grigio paren super strong player just
transferred to the U.S Chess Federation
uh he plays in the American flag he's a
student or he has been at the University
of Missouri so you know he is somebody
you know is dangerous but unfortunately
he met a very informed always a fruit
let's go away from here Donya I don't
think that Gregory would like us looking
at this position anymore I know you've
known him for quite a long time as well
but yeah let's do him a favor and go
elsewhere his Catalan didn't work out
this game so maybe in the next game
he'll play a dog of land uh let's go to
uh Dimitri kolares's game against
Vladimir fedesaf
oh my sorry I got possessed there for a
second I feel like we're suddenly the
Nickelodeon NFL games where we'd have
slime and all this kid-friendly puns so
good on you I remember as a kid cat dog
was a show did you ever watch that show
no I watched Scooby-Doo and Teletubbies
and that was basically it
you kind of remind me of a Teletubby but
you know David Howell has that one under
lock and key in the costume but this
game here what's going on so there's a
queen trade offered white has a bishop
pair and a healthier Pawn structure
looks like clear Advantage for white no
question about it colara says a dream
position against fedes against him you
want nothing tactically fun things to be
as positional as possible but a big
decision to make you can keep the Rooks
on the board he decides to trade to
eliminate any risk and he plays before
just grabbing control of these dark
squares and essentially guaranteeing
that black will forever suffer with the
weakness of the C7 Pawn you can move it
up to C6 but uh that Bishop on B7 might
start complaining at a Sev this has to
curl up into a ball and hope for the
best
yeah because one of White's major ideas
is A4 I love how you draw we know each
other that well it's like that one at
this point yeah A4 A5 B5 spring free a
pass outside pawn and black will not
have the resource defended look at this
move F3 if black does play C6 I think we
know where that King is going it is
zooming right to the B6 square and that
also should result in a winning I I feel
like this end game is won by white 95
out of 100 times especially when both
sides have let's say under four minutes
because to defend this successfully
you need to be perfect you need to know
exactly when to play Knight D6 when to
play C6 I just don't see feta save
successfully dealing with the challenges
of this position Dimitri kolars another
one of those players we talked about at
Robert at the start of the tournament I
think most people in the chat have heard
his name they've seen him play regular
games on chess.com and the guy is over
2600 super bright future and these types
of players tend to be overshadowed by
all the Argent era guy sees you know
nihal sarens and uh you know alireza for
arugias but they are nothing to sneeze
at
definitely not we usually sneeze them
the truth but in this in this case
you're gonna like this one
coal Army purple I think that Dimitri
kolars is in the driver's seat his King
is really heading towards the queen side
and for ferrosev who is a great player
we've seen him in division one at the
chessful Masters he doesn't like
positions like this right this is not
really his style where he has to defend
passively but what he wants is to trade
that Knight for the light Square Bishop
even if it costs him one Pawn maybe even
two if the Knight and the light Square
Bishop comes off we get opposite colored
Bishops that is Black's best chance to
survive this my goodness Vladimir really
got grabbed by the caller here
oh
now Knight B5 Bishop dude and this is
the this is what he's trying to do he's
trying to force white into a decision
he's trying to milk some time
optometry's clock enforcing him to
consider Bishop takes be fine I'm not
sure what to make of that resulting end
game my intuition tells me it's winning
even though there's Obstacle of Bishops
but Dimitri doesn't want any of it he
wants to keep the same pieces on the
board and leave open the option of A4
which is now a big threat this is a
better move in a blitz time scramble
because you keep the same pieces you
know you have the advantage you could
play A4 you can throw in a bishop F5
check I'm not sure it's useful but you
can force that King back a little bit
more and I feel like for white you could
even consider move C4 here because you
have Bishops they're long range pieces
you want to open the board for both
sides that way you can aim at the king
side and the queen side the downside of
trading pawns though is that fewer
remain and maybe black will be able to
sacrifice a piece for a couple pawns and
there will not be enough material
remaining to win the game and speaking
of downsides the downside of A4 is that
it does allow Knight C3 but after A5
Knight A4 is almost mate but white has
the D4 Square that's exactly what
happens now B5 as we had pointed out
earlier is a serious idea you have to
watch out for C5 in response to B5 so
black can use a little bit of trickery
here to stay afloat Vladimir doing
everything he can to keep chances alive
but I think his chances continue to
dwindle nonetheless
but white could be one move too slow
because Bishop E2 and then B5 would be
automatic but it's Bishop between Knight
C4 giving up a knight in a pawn for a
bishop that's a bad trade materially
speaking but you get rid of the light
Square Bishop so Bishop F5 check that's
a good move Let's Go Active here and
where's the black king going because if
you play King to d8 Daniel let's not
forget about the king side H4 and G4 and
H5 and G5 and you're going to create a
pass Pawn over there
a past spawn or you're going to induce a
major weakness such as the move F6 which
allows White's Bishop to infiltrate from
the other side and once the D5 Pawn is
lost you can basically resign this is
what you're pointing out you need to
keep track of so many moving Parts when
you're on the defending side and at this
point even if you play perfectly I don't
think it's enough the one thing though
after King d8 don't play Bishop B5
because you're allowing the move G6 G6
is actually a very serious positional
threat because White's Bishop suddenly
feels a little bit confined I would
consider a prophylactic move C3 on top
of your suggestion of H4
yeah G6 does have the downside that it
leaves the H6 Pawn under attack so you'd
have to spend another turbo the Knight
gets back to C4 so black is hoping that
with the King on C6 and the Knight on C4
there's just enough and I'm not still
not seeing it but that C5 idea you
mentioned earlier done it if King B5 and
C5 check the A5 pod could be a bit loose
so there are some chances here for Black
Ops even though white is the one
controlling both sides of the board just
don't play F6 here because Bishop B6
ends the game on the spot it's very
tempting to prevent G4 G5 but fat Assaf
has to figure out a way to basically
keep the status quo there's King B5 as
he tries to cause as many problems as
possible and White's time pressure I
would ignore the glyphs here because
he's just trying to be as practical as
possible by the way levonaronian and
David Antonio Drew their game
oh my gosh C5
yo but that clearly was that was a huge
inaccuracy it took it from a winning
advantage and C5 check now is available
to Black it's played Federal saves
working his way out of this and he's
gonna take on A5 with the Knight and
then if you play Bishop two D6 there's
Knight to B3 check there's Knight to C6
check
unbelievable a huge oversight by Dimitri
who just forgot about that move
and well excuse me Vladimir has not
taken the pawn yet but Knight takes A5
is automatic Bishop D3 check is what I
would play just to kick that King out of
there but then there's just King C6 the
king is walking back in front of the
pawn and you have to stop Knight B3 so
wait he allowed it allowed Knight B3 but
I guess it's going around the backside
of Bishop f8
that's brilliant actually I understand
that the eval bar is saying that most of
White's Advantage is gone but in a
scramble like this we're going into
bullet territory Bishop FH threatens to
win the game yeah
she's gonna take everything you're gonna
take G7 H6 and this is what you pointed
out earlier that is why you bring pawns
up a lot of young newer players they
find this to be mysterious you know
where is the spawn going well you're
preparing for the eventuality when you
get to that H6 spawn but he's gone the
wrong direction King to E3 apparently
another mistake is it because he's
allowed A5 the pawn rumbling forward and
black creating counter play or is black
take on C5
I I think you could take on C5 but
precisely what you were saying Donna
with the a pawn rumbling King E5 was too
scary the a-pump would just keep going
but they see three points and the d-pawn
might Rumble black could win this black
could absolutely win this and that's why
whites King had to go back to D3 and
actually allow black to take on C5 a
check I just have investing one tempo to
liquidate as many pawns as possible make
it as long as possible for white to
promote with one of these King side
pawns this is amazing amazing play by
Vladimir G6 was completely off my radar
but I could have taken C3 or C5 but as
you said he is trying to get rid of
White's most active Pawn the furthest of
the board and that means that trying to
Queen upon will take longer brilliant
play from federal safe who's trying to
get D for it he's playing for a win here
I know that sounds crazy but at this
point white has lost control of this
game the F Pawn is nowhere near
promotion and both of Black's pawns the
red carpet is rolled out they can start
rumbling forward A5 or D4 gotta decide
which one it's a complete three result
game right now
I'm playing A5 I'm trying to get that
outside password off the board he plays
it and if you take on a H6 C5 follows
him D4 how is he stopping both pawns I
think he's gonna play Bishop takes H6
and prepare to give a bishop up for the
pawn but black could absolutely win that
if he can keep White's protected passers
uh controlled of course that's a big if
we're allowing Bishop G7
wow that's actually really smart because
if you trade on D4 the king takes back
to C6 the bishop just moves out the way
and black has both passed pawns A5 and
D5 and they're moving very quickly
they're moving quickly so black could
even give away the bishop for the C pawn
and still win the game even if White's
King didn't stop one Pawn the other Pawn
might be unstoppable this is dangerous
for Dimitri he could lose this bishop C8
probably a draw though
do you play King C3 and play for a win
no but Bishop A6 was Ultra precise
because if the bishop started on C8 then
Bishop D7 would have been White's move
because the Palm was still in C6 so
Bishop A6 back to C8 on the yoyo string
excellent play from federal save But
Here Comes Dimitri with his past pawns
Dimitri is trying to promote his F Bond
but look at Black's Bishop it is the
hero of this position it is holding
everything together and Vladimir is just
gonna go around take the C pawn and this
one I think is now officially going to
no this should be seven Wednesday G Pawn
but yeah
ship H3 so King B6 and then King C5
I guess it doesn't really matter no
matter what this should be a draw but he
is oh he's going after it is Dimitri
trying to lose this is going to G6 with
King E5 F6 and white is in the nick of
time here
or is he
the king of Fate what's another move
there but yeah unfortunately there are
no pieces remaining so you you would
like to get your a pawn going but the
bishop will sacrifice itself for it you
could even go King E5 and leave that
Bishop on pretty oh this is close but
Dimitri is just in time the game ends in
a draw the very fact that we were
talking about blacklink for a win is
crazy what a save by Mr finisaya and
then great resilience from federal save
and from Kohler's the end they're not
getting rattled when things started
looking like the article let's go to the
last week against Dura Bailey some other
game is still going and it looked
completely winning for white earlier but
now are we oh
it's still winning because white has too
many pawns but look into her Bailey
trying to hold it together H7 and King
G6 though and black is breathing his
last breaths here
yeah I think the engine was just
catching up to the new position then we
see that King f8 is met by E7 check and
King G7 and this game is over it's a win
on time but it was also on the board
because of that Mouse slip
indeed and that means we've got only a
couple a handful of games
still remaining I'm gonna flip on the
one that's likely is to go on for the
longest which is a rook and this is a
rook at night position it seems like we
have one of these in every round of a
title Tuesday Robert it's like
somebody's always going to reach this
end game and of course it's much easier
to defend rook and Knight versus Rook as
opposed to rook and Bishop versus Rock
yeah these positions because the Knight
when it blocks a check say in the middle
of the board it doesn't control the same
score as a bishop does right a bishop on
E5 covers many important Escape squares
for a king on the rim but this looks
like a draw kovalenko he fished third in
a recent title Tuesday uh you know he
put a photo on Twitter I saw that where
he's on the front lines in Ukraine and
still fishing third in title twos is
beating hikar Nakamura unbelievable
stuff
huge kudos to Igor kovalenko the guy's a
trooper and literally and uh it's
interesting this Rook at Knight versus
Rook end game I was doing a little
historical investigation recently now in
the case of rook and Bishop versus Rook
uh Francois philidor thought that the
side of the rook and Bishop wins in any
position then Howard Stanton came along
and in 1849 this chess player's handbook
I think he was the first to decisively
claim that both rook and Knight versus
rook and Bishop versus Rook are a draw
with best defense so we think they
didn't know anything in the 1800s they
absolutely did stonson spends over 20
Pages analyzing these two end games
I love the chess historian that you are
everyone knows Edward winter but I'm
talking about donaldski you do so much
reading for everybody you know out there
Daniel sent me texts with like with with
actual texts from 1612 or whatever and
he's like look at Damiano I'm like I
barely woke up why are you telling me
about Damiano Andrew Lopez but this end
game as you said yeah nerds indeed but
this game end game should be a draw with
proper play although strong players have
in fact lost this end game oh yeah when
they're in time trouble I have only had
to defend this exactly once against Mark
Narcissa Dublin uh Spanish GM he played
all 50 moves out I accidentally uh got
my king to the last rank but I managed
to hold it together by the skin of my
teeth I also had to defend working
Bishop versus Rook against Alex or
malinski also successfully but that is
so much harder because here the
technique is very simple your king is
fine on the last rank as long as you're
able to give the back rank checks with
you with your rook and you don't miss a
fork obviously
yeah the bishop can slowly help the king
press forward the Knight is not as good
as this long range pin it's a problem
for black to do it because you move your
king to D4 then you get checked again so
your king will often have to step back
as we just saw here and if it goes to C4
you give a check but if you go here
still rooking Rook pinning the Knight
and this is a known draw but the players
why not play it out although they did
just make a draw
indeed and we've got a couple other
eye-popping results uh B harshavardan
Indian I am defeated Sam shankland with
the black thesis so Sam despite a good
start in the tournament he's been
scuffle in the last couple of rounds and
he will need to be perfect the rest of
the way because we're already five
rounds in we've got three players Robert
tied for first on four and a half
yeah so we see who's risen to the top
includes on draken farouja and David
Anton and Lavon aronian he's playing
Dimitri on draken which should leave
farrugia and David attan to Duke it out
duke it out they are I'm gonna flip on
that game which is a Karo Khan in a very
fashionable Line This Knight f3d3 plague
has taken the World by storm everybody
and their brother seems to play I think
alirez's brother also actually plays
this line and to me and Anton responds
with the move G6
yeah just trying to feed care of the
bishop uh people may think why not D
takes E4 D takes E4 trade the Queens
white plays that for a win despite the
king being unable to Castle so we
actually are going to see more of a
fight with this line G6 is met by E5
shutting down the diagonal before the
bishop even reaches G7 and done it we
kind of have like a very weird situation
there's a Carroll Khan where G6 is
included and white spawns like D3 should
be Advantage black at least from an
opening perspective and a lot of weird
Pawn play in the center now they're
getting more of a French Advanced type
of structure if white plays D4 the chief
difference is that Black's Bishop has a
pathway to move to G4 and typically when
you get that French structure with the
bishop already developed it's a very
favorable version but you could pay the
price for playing G6 because the
fiancaro is standard fare but that
Bishop on G7 is obviously biting on
granite so the big question can white
keep his Center intact I do like the way
David and zone is handling the opening
though he's played with a lot of
confidence he's played with a lot of
verb thus far in this tournament
yeah he's entertaining us and what more
could we ask for from the players are
you not entertained these players are
over the board Gladiators and I think
that you're pointing out a very
important tactic because Knight takes D4
it's like didn't white just walk into
open analysis material yeah let's let's
definitely show that because Knight
takes D4 would be a game-ending blunder
but not from White from black take that
Knight on D4 after Bishop takes D1
Bishop B5 is check the only way to
interpose that Checkers with the queen I
take your queen you take back and I get
your Bishop at the end white is a piece
of hit light is a piece of head because
he's got two knights and black only has
one and white will be saying good night
I should also point out that even if you
didn't have this you'd have the move
Queen A4 check a move you always have to
check for when you're opposing king is
not developed because here black has to
drop the Knight back and you drop the
bishop so Knight takes D4 is bad no
matter how you slice it there's no way
the David is seriously considering it as
we go back to the live board he is
obviously thinking about the order in
which he wants to develop his King side
pieces you often see the idea of Knight
H6 Knight F5 in the French and in this
structure by extension and of course
Queen B6 is uh oftentimes automatic so a
lot of choices here positionally to be
made by Davidson
yes that's why he is taking his time and
he is down about a minute on the clock
alareza farouza Speedster he has been
playing in a bunch of title Tuesdays and
E6 played so it's a refusal to develop
that dark Square bishop and maybe
there's a future where it stays on its
f8 A3 diagonal goes out to B4 with a
check as you're highlighting here
because after Bishop takes F3 the Knight
Will recapture to keep D4 defended but
that opens up the diagonal and then
Bishop B4 check and by the way the light
score Bishop for white is going to be
terrible in these positions absolutely
it is no targets it has nowhere to be
right if it's on F3 it's biting on
granite if it's on E2 it's okay it's
preventing uh the pin obviously but it
leaves a lot to be desired
I kind of like Black's position I don't
play these structures but I don't like
that pawn on D4 it's going to be a
long-term Target and if you can trade uh
the bishop for the Knight and then the
dark score Bishops D4 is going to be
under Fire
it is and again you always have to
contextualize these positions against
the framework of the time control right
less than 10 minutes for both sides to
start the game so a position where black
has a very very clear plan and here
there is a clear plan of attacking that
D4 Pawn is going to give you a more
practical game even if the engine likes
the space advantage and you know likes
the fact that the pawn on E5 is
controlling some key Central squares
agreed completely so I like David
Anton's position I don't love his clock
management thus far he still has over
seven minutes remaining that's the good
news but time scrambles that's when
advantages are lost or positions that
are holdable are not held because you
just don't have enough time to calculate
so I'm starting to get concerned about
his time already despite the early stage
and I'm also starting to concern about
the position on board two between Levon
aronian and Dimitri and draken so we'll
go to that very shortly as we have a
look at alireza farusha he's cupping his
head in his hands and he's just kind of
watching Black's clock tick down
he wants to get back into division one
so badly the air things Masters it was
not a great showing from the wonderkin
who now plays under the French flag but
for alireza he was 2800 as you mentioned
he made it to the candidate that was not
a good showing from him I mean it didn't
seem like he was the farrugia that we've
come to expect and we did just see
Bishop before and I was going to say
this earlier but I wanted the players to
show it to us King F1 farrugia
understands much like Bobby Fischer
talked about back in the 60s and 70s
what peace trades you want dark Square
Bishop is necessary for white to defend
D4 and also attack an F6 never play that
move Donya it's a mistake here
it's a mistake I don't like anything
that David and tone has done the last
couple of moves and what he hasn't done
he hasn't done it fast enough but Queen
A4 by Ellie Reza I thought he was going
to take on F6 and get that control over
the dark squares in the center instead
he's trying to trade on his own terms
he's spinning the Knight and obviously F
takes E5 would be met with Knight takes
C5 that looks pretty Unthinkable to me
but maybe David and tone can exploit the
vulnerability of White's Queen and move
his own Queen to the equivalent Square
on his side of the board
yeah we will dive into that in a moment
I just have to take us to the Von
eronian game against dimitrien we know
how solid on draken is how difficult he
is to defeat it takes a player of Levon
iranian's caliber to take him down and
look at this oh no it's all completely
lost all
white is up a clean exchange and maybe
even more after Bishop takes rook and
pawn to F4 or something like that but
the game is completely one-sided on
drinking this is devastating for him I'm
gonna put it bluntly I as an elephant
player have had this exact line against
him so many times and white is just
better in this end game according to
Theory I'll rewind a couple of moves if
I may very quickly so they followed a
main line of the allop and Sicilian
right and Dimitri has shown a
predilection for this Knight to B6
variation but this resulting end game is
just bad for black black is suffering
from a lack of space black is suffering
from a dark sway weaknesses on the king
side but perhaps more importantly just
no active prospects for that French
Bishop on C8 more like a sicilian bishop
and Levon look how quickly and how
confidently he plays rook fd1 and oh my
gosh he makes things worse with an
elementary blunder just Knight C7 Bishop
p7 not Dimitri's finest day
he took upon the center but gave upon on
the flank and lost a rook for Bishop
look at this F4 the point is Bishop C5
check it looks like it's scary for white
because if you go to H1 there's like
Knight G4 but you're not actually
threading anything The Rook can just
take on D7 there are no useful Discovery
checks it would be a clean extra Rook
for white and after Rook C1 as you're
indicating I think this is bye bye and
Rook C1 I think Dimitri will try Bishop
C6 but then the Knight can Desperado
sack itself on e16 you can't even take
it because Bishop takes C6 is a fork
against the King of The Rook this is
just a couple of moves away from
resignation maybe even one move away
from resignation look at Levon aronian's
clock that's the most debilitating
demoralizing thing about this he spent
right around two minutes to Crush
Dimitri and Drake and in 20 moves like a
bug
you don't want to expect this when you
see two super Grand masters of this
caliber Dimitri and Drake and he's going
to be frustrated uh but this is a game
that I would consider resigning and
taking this time to restore my
confidence uh to maybe get something to
eat to refresh myself because it doesn't
feel like there's much hope here for
black at all Knight takes E6 probably
works out I would spend a little bit of
time calculating because Alex Bishops
you don't want to let them run amok on
these diagonals or you could get uh
forked on D3 for example so Lavon he's
left himself with plenty of time to
calculate the ramifications obviously F
takes E5 Bishop takes C7 is
winning for white do not take on D7 in
that position because if Bishop B6 check
recovering The Rook on C1 with the d8
square is under Black's control
yeah that's a very deep line hard to
visualize let's put that in the board
we'll bring up an analysis report so we
can show you because this is an
important tactic it looks like white is
stealing another piece in the position
but after F takes E5 Bishop c757 is done
just said
sorry go ahead is there a crazy tactic
with Rook C7 and Bishop A4
oh you're you're just a Madman there's a
background Checkmate Bobby struggled
with this yesterday during the World
Championship so I think I have you back
and Rook DH Checkmate will be on shuffle
of the bishop moves and that means black
loses a piece but just show that other
variation as well because this will be
lights out but Rook D7 would backfire
with Bishop B6 check eval bar drops
completely and it's a moot point that
the d8 score is protected because black
takes on C1 with check and is able to
hold the C the B7 Pawn with Bishop C7
Levon I think he sees it I think he's
making sure uh that this is a win and
he's going for it what a game by Lavon
watch him take C7 and watch him win the
game
uh in the live position Rook takes C7 it
would be a sick move that's just that's
heartbreaking or not even heartbreaking
Soul crushing is what I want to say when
you know you're lost and then someone
comes up with this tactic so move after
move your overlooking ideas it feels
like and oh gosh
over six minutes on his clock and then
draken will resign in this position
there's nothing left to play for he goes
down a full minor piece there it is the
double x clam that glyph the one that
everybody looks forward to getting
I think that Lavon deserves it for this
game giving up a rook for a bishop that
was his material advantage but he says
you can have that back I'm then going to
win your other Bishop this is game over
a great fight by you Dania and
impressive play from Levon aronia all
right Dima time to resign get a little
coffee
relax because one loss is not gonna send
you out of the tournament of course
there's over 50 spots across the three
divisions but listen six and a half out
of nine seven out of nine that gives you
a serious fighting chance to make the
top five he still has plenty of chances
left no shame in losing to Levon with
the black pieces
yeah and the top five is so important
because the top 10 players they will
compete and the winner of their matches
get to division one the losers go
division two but having top five means
you get to select your opponent so you
keep that scoreboard up you want to keep
on winning and then get your selection
of opponent that could be the difference
between making to the top division or
not so let's go away from this I don't
think we are doubting Levon of orange
ability to win up a full Bishop so what
other games are there that are catching
your eye
what other games well there's collars
against like Wong Lim on the third board
I think we should go there because it is
heating up like nothing else white is
attacking something fierce
and I think that the last move
apparently was a huge blunder from the
Vietnamese Grandmaster Rook takes B7
game is not over
because after Bishop takes C4 there is a
fork on G4 that is what he's banking on
looks like it has some immediate way to
win do you see it
I do not and it's one of these positions
that may require some patience Rook
takes B7 looked winning oh he takes this
way and white is still better so that's
let's be clear about that Black's King
is open white has a pair of Bishops
black doesn't even have an extra Pawn I
thought at first that he did but that's
five pounds on five Pawn so uh let's
bring up the analysis board and let's go
back to that moment because Donya did
have an instructive point that what
looked winning for white if the Rook B7
Rook B7 Bishop takes E4 thank you so
much for two pieces for your Rook there
was that Queen G4 check idea and you see
that black is the one who's winning
because you lose your Rook or if you
leave your Bishop on uh E4 I will take
that bishop and beat up some material
and apparently this is what makes the
EVAP bar so misleading Rook to F1 is the
winning move who is capable of finding a
move like that in a rapid game after
Queen G4 white is swoops in and takes on
E5 and the knight in E4 is going to be
lost so this patient move I think that's
the key word that you mentioned patience
Rook F1 would have been the winning move
you can't even move your knight because
of the pin on D5 lot of moving parts to
account for we go back to the live board
because I still think the Dimitri colors
is completely in charge of this game and
look at his last move there's some
patience H3 covering the G4 square and
now the threat of Bishop takes E4 is
absolutely devastating Knight D6 Rook
takes D6 and Dimitri might get two
pieces for a rook after all
wow I mean Rook F1 in that position
you're not finding that especially in a
rapid game but H3 a calm move from uh
kolars here and yeah what do you do as
black because Bishop takes E4 it
threatens the win a piece he goes Rook
of eight so he's trying to give up the
piece on the best terms possible Liam
Lane wants to take on H3 go after the
white king I do feel like black has some
chances because oh yeah it has to be
very accurate and white doesn't have a
lot of time left he's got two and a half
minutes on his clock you could lose this
right if you take on e4 at the wrong
moment Queen takes H3 sets up tremendous
threats against White's game that is the
downside of driving your pawns off the
board and leaving your king as exposed
as it is I think white needs another
patient defensive move but I don't know
what it looks like because Queen E2 runs
into Knight C3 maybe you repositioned
your queen to D3 but those are not easy
moves to make as your clock continues to
dwindle you want Clarity and that's why
I'm a little bit worried that Dimitri
might actually take on e4 no he goes
King H2 first that's another amazing
move but I think that black still some
chances Queen F5 does protect the Knight
and that Rook F1 idea I'm sacking my
queen and that white King on H2 it's
kind of in a mating net so you have to
be super capable if we can show A
variation very quickly right which one
yeah yeah you know where I'm going with
this so after you know Queen F5 Rook F1
take on F1 twice and if Queen D3
thinking that you're attacking this Rook
there's Rook H1 check and if you take
the Rook on H1 Knight F2 double check
and I win your queen
and what's even crazier is if you go
King G2 here you don't go Knight F2 I
think black has Rook to D1 no apparently
that's not the move but okay you see
what I'm saying right Queen D1 Knight C3
you're gonna have to find a move of that
type if King G2 is played
but that's not an unlikely line also 92
check might lead to some sort of
Perpetual check in any case
a beautiful illustration of the power of
minor pieces when they're fully
coordinated uh the common wisdom has it
that the rook and Bishop is the
strongest pair and it's the queen and
Knight but the rook and Bishop worked so
well together especially if you've got a
knight they're delivering the Discover
check as a middleman Queen F5 definitely
white Black's best chance look at the
clocks by the way white is under two
minutes so if there's a rook slamming
down on F1 a bishop on B7 that long
range piece staring through the Knight
to H1 that's a position that even black
can win because White's King is
uncomfortable so queen of five is played
and we've seen patient moves from kolars
it oh he goes working foreign
what's his move here for white
it's plus four but that's as meaningless
as as anything he's got a minute 45
maybe you just play H4 the point is you
want to keep the queen diagonally one
square apart from the Knight because
that way mathematically black cannot
move the Knight and attack the queen so
you want to keep this arrangea what do
you do
I don't know because even if you play H4
you're a brave man before on C5
but I can just take it and plant my
knight on C3 I feel like whoa oh
and now he's allowed what he's allowed
Rook D1
I mean Rook E1 comes to mind as well
going right after the bishop Queen F3 I
yes you're playing now it's a three
result game
oh my goodness Queen F3 is a really
scary move to play I would be surprised
if black has some wind there like with
Knight D6 and Rook H1 and Knight F5 yeah
that looks witty for black
it does and in the meantime all the rest
of Arusha has crushed David and Tony
Haro it started off well for the Spanish
GM but he took way too long in the
opening phase he tripped on his own feed
and he loses his game and loses his
share of first place all the rest of
arugia is on fire but this game this
game is amazing how is Lake Wong doing
this
yeah for roses on fire there's fire on
board in this game as you're pointing
out there's a checkmating net yes weaved
Queen G4 giving up the bishop he wants
queen E6 check and that's a brilliant
move maybe the only way for white to
survive but Rook H1 check instead would
have forced to draw like one took that
way too quickly maybe he's playing for a
win but Rook H1 and Knight F6 would have
forced an opposite colored Bishop end
game although I see he would have been
losing some of these pawns so he didn't
like that
Queen E6 king of Faith there's not a
single check next oh Queen D7 very
accurate
I'm guessing that's another brilliant
move because Queen E6 didn't work rookie
two check there's King G1 and that looks
like a draw with rookie one check rookie
two but black clearly is the one who
wants to win this game at this point
although crazily enough if black starts
repeating moves white could zigzag his
way up to F3 and the point is you attack
the tail of the discovery which means
that if black snake drops back you can
take on B7 unless of course Black Knight
drops back to D6 but Knight D6 jack
isn't typically an effective way to set
up any sort of mating net or any Fork
threats let's see who's playing for a
win here
will la Quang try to repeat moves with
rookie too or will he figure out a way
to keep the attack going well he doesn't
have another move besides rookie too
because The Bishop's under attack and if
you move it anywhere you lose it because
Bishop A8 Queen ehek Bishop A6 Queen E6
check give me your Bishop so I think he
has to play rookie two check and then
figure out what's next by the way white
has 24 seconds Tanya
yeah
it's taking him a while to find all
these accurate defensive moves crazy
that we're even saying defensive moves
so white paying the price ultimately for
weakening his King there's the check
there's King G1 will Dimitri KO Lars go
up to G2 and play for a win
if he does that is so brave because if
the King goes to G2 and F3 the Black
Brook will go to F2 with check and back
to F7 so Bob has a rook and two minor
pieces for the queen I wouldn't be
surprised if white is completely hanging
in there but it's difficult to do with
25 seconds in your clock and obviously
when you've been playing for a win your
whole game when you're used to thinking
that you're winning sometimes players
get overzealous they get over ambitious
they underestimate the effectiveness of
the opponent's counter play and I think
Dimitri is doing a wise thing I think
the fact that he's repeating moves shows
wisdom he's in a good spot in this
tournament there is no need to do
anything Brazen with 26 seconds
great idea from him just make this draw
it gets you to four and a half out of
the six you're right there in contention
but as we see on the scoreboard the
standings farrugia five and a half Levon
five out of the six Zoom usard at five
and six as well and King back to G1
rookie one that should let us to that
draw and whoa oh he's going for it this
is insane he wants E4 and he wants a
mating net I don't oh
do you like this decision not at all I
think that he's trying so hard to win
that he's probably just going to lose
because White's past pawns are going to
be way quicker than Black's attack Queen
C8 65. just get a pass pawn and the
problem is it's not like oh you give
black a move he's gonna set up a mating
net there's no way to arrange the knight
in The Rook such that the king is stuck
in a mating it because the King has both
F1 and H1 this is absurdity by like
unless white misses a fork which is
always possible for example Queen E5
would run into Knight F3 check but black
is now fighting for a draw I would
consider the move H4 to get yourself a
little bit more real estate no H4 Knight
H3 King F1 Rook A1 would be another way
to blunder a fork oh that's big but look
at this queen D5 check no matter where
the king moved a queen would have taken
a pawn with check C5 is gone no he he's
trying to lose this game we say this
often right Donna that sometimes playing
to win is playing to lose and he's just
losing at the moment and I think he's
forgotten that Dimitri kolares is a 3
000 rated Blitzwinger on chess.com the
guy knows how to handle this time
scrambles now it's not totally over yet
black could try to stop the pawn from C2
but C6 Queen D7 and C7 might just end
the game
yeah I think the Black Knight has to go
back to G5 at some moment hope to get
enough checks in to make a draw but it's
too far away the queen on D5 a
centralized Queen controls too many
squares black has nothing
but I would try Knight G5 H4 Knight H3
and try to set up that trap with Rook C1
and Knight F4 I've seen even very strong
players
kind of assume that The Rook has to be
stuck on the second rank one last try
here for like Huang and it is coolly
rebuffed by Dimitri who picks up the
Rook look at that geometry that is
amazing
wow and this game is over as long as you
walk into Fork I think Liam's gonna
resign right now he does that is oh he
doesn't resign he plays on him surprised
by that I guess now he resigned
it's about time aronian has defeated on
draken he did manage to convert up a
full piece in the end game believe it or
not Robert I know that's hard to imagine
and we have Shimano against giri which
is the highest rated game still
remaining let's go there it's a rook end
game I have no idea who's playing for a
win here I think it might be Alexander
shimanov
well with the white piece in the past
Pawn why not and King G3 apparently that
last move uh he takes G3 there was a
pawn there was a mistake I don't think
we'll blame him for doing that but now
Rook D3 check takes B3 but there's
rookie three to block
that was his idea rookie through Rook d8
now take that pawn and E7 but the pawn
is just not enough I think black is
gonna plant his Rook behind the pawn and
run the king through G6 to F6 a very
narrow path but it's gonna be just
enough here I think to hold the draw
wow and I just want to remind everybody
that Liam lay won the last uh Swiss for
the chesswell Masters he won the play in
Phase so he is a beast he did just lose
to Dimitri kolars and in this game
another Beast Denise Curie hopes not to
lose to Alexander shimanovan by the way
the player is down into bullet scramble
territory under 15 seconds after Geary
indeed and he's deciding between King G6
and Rook B8 and he's gone King G6 and
apparently that's a big mistake but it's
not because of F3 this is hard hard to
play accurately though yeah because King
up to G4 without Rook D4 check so king
of fives number six Rook C7 takes C5
Rook C7 check
oh you go here you take the pawn you go
back to C7 and then over to G7 at the
right moment and start picking up the
rest of Black's Pawns
that looks actually pretty
straightforward at this point Rook G7
King g16 G4
I think it's over wait black one is
black one like King B6 King A7 and then
free The Rook but that's too slow but by
the time you free The Rook this F Pawn
is right up Black's Grill on F7
F4 and close my eyes
yeah F4 F5 F6 F7 seems pretty automatic
but King B4 takes B3 and the a pawn is
quite Advanced I think white wins by a
Tempo he instead goes back to E3 great
defensive idea and now he's Paving the
way or the unobstructed progress of the
F1 Anisha is going to suffer another
defeat
it's so unobstructed that you drew an
arrow to the e-file they can do whatever
it wants at this point but
[Laughter]
that famous Magnus Carlsen and Denise
Geary he's used that himself but right
now I think he's the only one silenced
because uh shimanov is about to win this
game and go to five out of six one of
those players Donya not listed on the
notable player's graphic the start but
he's a monster of these rapid type
patrols indeed he is and Alexander
shimanov anishki resigns without
awaiting the the elementary Queen F6
Queen A1 and black is one tempo short if
that King was on C2 this would be a
theoretical draw Anish Gary is feeling
the pain of these qualifying tournaments
you can list absolutely anybody and uh
no shame in this this is just how strong
this tournament is I'm gonna go to what
I think is one of our last remaining
games between yakuboyev
otterbeck I'm three pawns up yakuboyev
and Alan show that's a pretty great
nickname I'm kind of jealous of it but
wait a second
both players and he's actually only up
two pawns so I like his nickname even
more now
Biz up two pawns I see I have a hard
time counting the three on two and then
adding that to the three pawns on the
queen side a lot of mathematical
calculations here let me tell you white
could easily get skewered
Queen G3 but Queen takes before check it
was Queen D6 it's a nice move I would
have taken B4 what is he doing you
should have taken B4 King C4 King B5 and
resigns yep
wow a lumpy show uncharacteristic flop
there in time pressure
that pawn doesn't matter
yakubaya played very well in the chesso
Masters division two uh you know he's
been a name that's been in uh or was the
air things back I'm sort of merging them
in my head but either way he's been very
strong in division two in the Champions
chess tour and he would love to make
division one if he wins this which it
looks like it's gonna happen he's going
to four out of six
four out of six indeed and you know we
don't talk we can't talk about everybody
there's too many games to keep track of
all of them at the same time but players
like Notre Baka they often squeak into
division one or division two or the
prize fund is still very generous
yeah no a nice win there for him he's at
four to six but there is not a break
right now the players go right back at
it so Daniel which game should we focus
on to start well we've got all the
reservation clear first I think we need
to pay homage to him and start in Ali
Reza land
I'm happy to do that let's go just a
moment here
and and while you do that Dania I just
saw that Mama jarv is playing we haven't
talked about him but he's not back
playing he's taking on David and
tangiharo so he's back at four and after
six
okay in the meantime I've pulled up all
the rest of ferocious game
against Jewel moussard who's got the
white pieces and playing a very calm
Carl con here exchange variation so
alireza tournament strategy wise he
doesn't mind a drop right if Musa would
offer a draw or force a draw I think
alireza would be more than happy to hold
of the black bases but after E5 the
position is relatively unbalanced so I
would not call this a drawing line
no and there are this this 146 players
in the field so if you get to around if
you hit the seven points you know you're
good alireza fuja five and a half out of
six three draws would land him at seven
yeah that works for him but look at this
we are going to see an isolated Pawn for
black I think Jule musard is playing
this very intelligently it's the type of
position where white can comfortably
play around that pawn and you have
blockaded the square in front of it you
have a C3 Knight and F3 Queen md3 making
sure that pawn get kick it forward and
you're drawing the correct arrows dhanya
but I think that white is happy to be in
this position
well as a sometimes karaoke player I
have had this exact position with black
and I've analyzed the move H6 which is
upon sacrifice Bishop F6 you will take
with a queen obviously and after Queen
takes D5 Rook d8 I think that's the kind
of position that black ones hear the
move as far as I remember is G5 Bishop
G3 and then Knight E4 as modern chest
wisdom holds it Robert the best way to
compensate for the long-term weakness of
an isolated Pawn is to make sure that
your pieces are playing to their maximum
potential that is exactly what you want
to do here even if that comes at the
cost of slightly weakening your king
but we were just talking about farrugia
would be happy to sail through with
three draws now he'll try to win if the
opportunity presents itself but G5 is a
risky move it opens up the black king
you're armed with preparation and I'm
sure alireza he's seen this position
plenty of times before but in a rapid
game you're worried is this the correct
position to play G5 is my king the one
that's going to be In Harm's Way I think
the answer is yes your king will be in
trouble but he does have enough
compensation around the fact that he
gets activity
and we have a quick draw in the game
between David and Zone and Vladimir Fett
is save you can see them over on the
left lower left of your screen number
six and number seven they're on five out
of seven and they will be overtaken by
players who are currently on four and a
half and will have one so
not the best place to be if you're Anton
and Vladimir they're gonna have to
finish very strong in the last two
rounds actually done it just to uh
correct your saving there it was mama
jar of Mama Jarvis probably are worse no
but he drew in federal save also got
that there's another draw and alireza
accepts a draw in this position so
that's why he was thinking you should
almost started accompanied Bishop page
four with a draw for
and I think for musar that's also a good
result because now he's at five and up
to seven one out of two should be good
enough given his tie breaks you don't
want to rely on tie breaks because you
may be overtaken LeapFrog by somebody at
the end but I draw in this position all
right I don't like the draw for band The
draw for come on chess.com please do it
already but I think that I understand
the player's perspectives
I understand it too and uh thank you for
correcting me it was Min Lee I think uh
who drew uh who drew the villains on
giharo and then fed a say of Jerome and
Yara so a huge Log Jam on five out of
seven all of those players especially
the ones who have climbed from the lower
half of the tournament standings and who
lost an early game that really kills
your tie breaks because when you lose
game one or game two you have to climb
up on players who have zero out of one
or zero out of two and that really hurts
the cumulative score of your opponents
if you're someone like alireza ferocia
you can basically rely on your tie
breaks but he's essentially the only one
who can rely on his tie breaks and even
then we've seen crazier things in like
the RCC
yes you never know how your opponents
earlier in the event if they go on a
winning streak or if they drop out of
the tournament these impact the tie
breaks but right now in this position
levonne Ronin with the white pieces he
does not want to rely on tyberg Heap
when Knight E1 to go Knight D3 next and
he wants to strike with Pawn to F4 look
at this bishop on B2 it's waiting for
its time to shine and if you get F4 in
oh that could be trouble for black
and that situation escalates very very
quickly because once F4 happens you
don't have the Machinery to keep the E5
Pawn protected one of the reasons for
that is that Bishop D6 can be met with
Knight D2 to C4 forcing that Bishop
house the shimanov trying to defend
tactically by pinning the Knight Lavon
on pins it with C4 now the D4 square is
a little bit weak but if you play Bishop
D4 Robert then white will happily take
and run those ons up the board with that
4 and E5 that is not what you want for
shimanth and the problem with this
position is Lebron is playing instantly
and look at him go Rook a to d8 he says
please take my Bishop on C5 I will take
back with my knight and that D3 square
or the D4 Square will be hopped into by
that Knight on D7 so I was going to say
that both options of retreating your
bishop or putting on D4 to trade they
look bad because of f4 and that's
exactly why he kept his Bishop on C5
that's exactly right and King H1 as we
predicted setting up the threat of f2f4
not a subtle move but a very scary one
nonetheless and now shimanov has to
figure out the defensive approach that
he's going to take is he going to drop
the bishop back to D6 which makes a lot
more sense now that the C4 square is
occupied by a pawn or is he going to
find some more tactical way to take the
sting out of the move F4 which of course
allows black to open up an x-ray against
White's queen and I think that's exactly
what shimanov is preparing to exploit
Robert if he takes F4 and then Bishop
takes you to a knight takes E4 picking
up a crucial Center Pawn
yeah though now I would take on before
for Lavon and then play A3 I know that
black has these double pawns here but
I'm going to take with my Rook on A3 if
you take me and then play Rook F1 to A1
he goes for the king side he's saying
I'm not going to hold anything back it's
hard to blame him for it and C5 by
shimanov oh gosh that Knight gets to D4
and the bishop back to B7 to aim at E4
he'll have chances to take control of
this game he most certainly will and
that will be made possible if white
plays F5 which is a very typical way to
continue that's often what you want to
do and then G4 G5 Lavon could do that if
he decides that the Knight coming to D4
is not as scary of a prospect as it
seems but suddenly the position's quite
a bit more double-edged and it was just
a couple of moves ago it feels like
black is having some fun too
yes you have some a play of your own
whereas that's why A3 came to my mind
instead of rushing with F4 I thought you
just played up the AFL probably that was
too equal for lavon's liking it would
have allowed black to just take a fight
for the a file probably trade Rooks and
maybe there was nothing to speak of
there but this looks like it could
backfire with that Bishop heading right
back towards B7 and the E4 Pawn will be
permanently vulnerable
it will indeed and the middle game is
going to be very complicated we'll keep
an eye on this game another game that
I've been keeping an eye on is again
Anish giri who has been scuffling he's
suffered two defeats which is not
something we say often not something he
ever does in a tournament he has to win
the rest of his games he's got to win
out if he is to have an opportunity to
qualify at the very least for division
two he has the white pieces against
Indian Grandmaster Surrey vibhav uh who
was a prodigy he was Grandmaster I think
at 14 years old uh hasn't had as smooth
of a second half of his career but he is
still knocking on the door of 2600 right
these are the players who often go under
the radar and can beat absolutely
anybody in an individual game I don't
know if he's gonna be beating in his
giri in this game though
I think black's best move is taking the
pawn that's on the side of the board and
putting it on B2 because that Rook
staring down the open B file is very
scary because black can't really Castle
Queen side you're walking into an attack
but as you're showing putting a Pawn on
B2 would be best for black and oh 77 oh
that's a huge tactical blunder and he's
just gonna see that in his sleep
yeah and well I mean Rook takes B7 if
you take back Bishop C6 check and he
plays it Bishop takes D5 you take him
Rook on B8 first and then just take back
it's a brilliant move but it really was
caused by a huge mistake a blunder from
black but a niche is not going to miss
this idea giving up a rook temporarily
to win more material
no he is not and obviously the blunder
was let on by the massive pressure that
Anish was putting on all three sides of
the board Center there's an open e-file
G4 Pawn is under attack and obviously
the queen side was a no-go zone for
Black's King as well because of that
semi-open B file which is now a fully
opened B file and white is going to
combine threats on all these sides of
the board rookie one is the immediate
threat F6 G4 just wins the pawn that
would be very a niche Style just take on
G4 secure your extra pawn and win the
game technically
why not Black Knight on B8 undeveloped a
White's Rook on F1 better than the Rook
on h8 though The Rook is staring at the
H4 Pawn white will be able to defend the
Knight G6 uh can be met by a knight to
F3 or even Pawn to H5 it does look like
Anish has this one under control
it does indeed white is going to win
this game he's five minutes up on the
clock this has been a massacre
anishigiri big rebound win against
Surrey vibhav and he is still very much
in intention speaking of contention we
have the top board mostared for Russia
having ended in a draw we just checked
on aronian shimanov so let's keep going
down the list perhaps and look at some
of the games on boards five six Etc we
have Dennis lazovic uh against Jordan
van Forest they've got a pretty boring
position we can check in really quickly
um anything around that area catching
your eyes should we look at a lazovic's
game real fast
let's go to Las Vegas why not this is a
teenage star who's won multiple title
Tuesdays and here we've seen with the
white pieces now there's a black king on
F7 many different games today are
featured in uncastle King and why has
slight pressure Rook C2 Rook C1 double
in the only open file that Rook on h8 is
not participating Dinah that's why
slight Edge to lasovic yeah for sure and
white has the pawn break E3 four that
can be prepared the eval bar continues
to creep up and I think that's exactly
what lasovic is preparing to prepare it
you have to reinforce the D4 Pawn he
does that with the only minor piece he
can do it with a knight Eva bar didn't
like that move could it be because of
Knight T6 I thought Bishop D6 played by
Jordan and what is he for
I guess 97
but that starts to look scary right
because as soon as the position opens up
that black king on F7 is In Harm's Way
if you take on e4 you might just be
losing on the spot that's why he brings
his Knight back to E7 a very good lesson
for everybody watching the more open
files that those are the results of
captures of Pawns trading each other
that is good for the white Rook on F1
and bad news for the black king on F7 so
97 a great Retreat for Jordan Forest
indeed the King on F7 safe for the time
being as long as the f file remains
closed so you are not going to see
Jordan taking on e4 unless there's some
crazy extenuating circumstance I still
wouldn't give this all zeros if I had to
evaluate I think white is in the
driver's seat but not on the clock he's
down two minutes he's got to figure out
where his Rooks belong he moves The Rook
away from the f-file obviously D takes
E4 is still out of the question I think
lazovic is trying to go Knight C3 and
the battle is going to revolve around
Black's control over this D5 Square can
Dennis Force black into taking on e4
eventually
yeah black does not want to do that but
Queen B6 the queen trade I think that's
really smart because look at the C file
I was talking about how white wants to
control that but black has all of the
squares under his control from starting
at C4 all the way down the line there
are no squares available to the white
Rooks and if you take on B6 after a
takes B6 the a file opens up and then
the blackwork can slide over to A8
and attack the A2 pawn and if the pawn
lifts up to A3 and black can send a beep
on down the board so the queen side
might seem like White's territory
because he controls the C file but it's
not just about file control this is what
you're saying it's about Square control
and if aside controls all key
penetration squares then the effect of
possessing that open file is greatly
diminished and so lazovic he says no way
Jose no way Jordan in this case he plays
Queen A40 it's The Rook on D7 and black
could shift the Knight over to C6 but
that would relinquish his control over
the D5 Pawn so a lot of moving Parts
here they account for or you would
invent for us he also has to be careful
Robert about the prospect of E4 E5 which
would really accentuate the awkwardness
of Black's Queen I think Dennis might
very well play E5 in this position I
wouldn't be able to resist E5 is super
tempting but it could be Bishop B4 as a
response hitting the Rook on E1 so you
get that Tempo yeah it could backfire a
bit because you do hand black some key
squares and you submit some of your
Pawns in place like the pawn structure
right now is favorable for black in the
center the reason why is D4 is a
long-term issue and both sides have dark
Square Bishops so I think for Dennis
lazovic down three minutes on the clock
I could see this turning in your invent
Forest favor
yeah I could see Dennis trying to kind
of hedge his bets and hold a draw here
because the more tension you create the
harder it's going to be to handle as
you're saying down two and a half
minutes so your invent four is doing a
good solid job thus far of holding his
own in this difficult position he gets
the C file once again
tries to engineer a trade of heavy
pieces and Bishop B4 can be met with
Knight C3 so white has not blunder The
Exchange
and the Queen
right to access things from the other
side Queen H6 is a serious idea you
could even meet Bishop before with Queen
H6 I mean that does look a bit worrisome
for black you do not want to allow the
queen in there but for now Jordan he has
a lead in The Clock I think he'll be
hold everything together but Dania
somebody who's not holding everything
together is Lavon aronian I mean he is
on the worst side of this game against
Alexander shimanov we looked there
earlier it's very important for the top
of the standings look at this position
the E4 Pawn is stuck in place and that
black knight it got to D4 this is bad
news for Lavon Alexander shimanov on the
strength of his victory over Anish giri
is now angling for a win against Lavon
aronian he has indeed ensconced to that
night on D4 and LeBron hasn't gone off
the ground on the king side yeah he's
managed to play out five he's preparing
G4 but Robert with no Rooks on the board
the luster of this attack is greatly
diminished I don't even think he's
playing H3 for attacking purposes I
think Levon is in full defense mode
trying to control key squares on the
king side so that Black's Knight and F6
doesn't jump into G4 at the right moment
yeah he goes Queen B7 right after the E4
Pawn Knight D5 played out of necessity
you cannot allow black to pick up the E4
Pawn but you see the evaluation start
going down and I would take that Knight
with the bishop I know we don't like to
give two unopposed Bishops it would be
two Bishops against two knights but the
position is locked up if you take with
the E Pawn you drop the F5 Pawn if you
take with the c Pawn is that really a
bishop on G2 it's staring into its own
pawns and a black knight will go to E8
to D6 I love this position for shimanov
absolutely that blockading square on D6
is just Prime real estate then you can
use your Pawn majority B65 against B3
instead Alexander shimanov he asks for
the queen trade and the evil bar is
having none of it what do you make of
this trying to eliminate the risk
I was gonna trade and take on B6 but I
understand his point that E4 is hanging
if the Knight moves out the way and B3
is also under attack so he's trying to
soften up White's defenses here but
maybe Levon has enough to hold because
after B6 Falls the C5 Pawn will be loose
as well and you have a dark sword bishop
and you can attack it from A3 you can
also trade on A8 take on F6 and then
take on H6 but that I think shimanov
likes because after Knight takes B3 the
pawn on C4 is going to be a permanent
weakness and black can attack it with
his light scored Bishop from A6 so win
A8 to me signals that Alexander Shimano
if he wants to manage his risk and get
the Queens off the board but I think he
was a little bit overly defensive I
think Bishop takes D5 would have
afforded him excellent winning chances
and Levon declines the queen trade
wow
I think Lavon was scared of those end
games so now Bishop takes default he's
giving up the F5 Pawn but E5 is hanging
you've invited the queen to B2 and this
is bad news for shiman I see the
evaluation bar I Think We're Not Gonna
argue that black isn't better because
black is better but at least the bishop
on G2 feels better and D6 can be thrown
in even if it costs went upon to get
some activity that could be important so
98 is still very much a possibility
trying to discourage D6 you're right D6
still has to be considered and said Alex
it goes H5 just to keep this F Pawn
separated from uh its colleague on G3
the downside is that you are not
blockading the D6 Square so you're
allowing white to play D6 I would not go
D6 just yet I would try to keep this
Pawn as long as possible maybe prepare
B4 and chip away at the edges
and I like Bishop E3 get your Bishop of
the first rank that frees up your queen
to move around B4 as you are indicating
that could be scary for black to deal
with and F5 is now threatened so he's
going right after the F5 Pawn the Knight
couldn't capture because E5 was loose
but the queen will be happy to take it
Shimano is on a roll right now he's not
playing perfectly Queen A8 might have
been an inaccuracy might have given
white great drawing chances in the end
game but he's also harnessing the fact
that LeBron feels like he's got to play
for a win and maybe with Queen to B2
LeBron was still hoping that he was
going to cash in his chips that pawn on
T5 and the bishop pair right now I think
it's looking as miserable as ever for
Lavon
and look at this you would think that
the the white Pawn should be on D4 and
the black pawn should be on D5 but we
have past Pawns in enemy territory and I
think what Lavon has done here is he's
saying your d-pawn can't move very
easily I know mine can't either but I
will get play because I have my queen in
the open file my Bishop on G2 it can
reroute F1 to D3 and if white could ever
play Bishop F3 and G4 is your other
arrows were indicating that could be
good for white to gain some space of
course you also have to keep tabs on all
of the key infiltration squares if you
play G4 prematurely you allow Black's
Queen to jump into F4 and the moment
Black's pawn reaches D2 the game is over
because you do not have a dark Squad
Bishop so that pawn on D2 would be
completely immune from Attack by White's
Bishop instead Levon he desperately
tries to engineer some counter play did
he just allow B5 was that the winning
move instead Alexander shimanov gets
control of the e-file but Lavon still
fighting still kicking still generating
chances
but now D3 Black's pass Pawn is faster
and the reason why B4 was so bad it has
allowed Queen E7 which offered a trade
of Queens but shiman just runs away
oh he's gonna do it later he wants to
make sure his King is safe and sound on
H7 there will not be too many checks
against it and D3 is happening whether
you like it or not black queen goes into
E3 D3 D2 this looks like it's just
winning for black and it's like the
final nepo Denver iPod game right you
can hold off the past spawn for a
certain amount of time but you're not
gonna stop its progress eventually the
only you can Bank on I think is D6 at
the right moment but white spawn isn't
going anywhere Black's Knight is a hero
for holding the D7 Square you can also
jump into E4 at the right time so here
comes Queen E3 Here Comes D3 Lavon
barring a miracle is going to lose this
game of the white pieces what a shocking
result this would be and what a series
for Alexander shimanov will have beaten
Anish giri and Lavon aronian
consecutively
well hopefully you didn't but if he does
do that then Shimano should do the Steph
Curry shimmy because he will be well on
his way to playing in the matches that
determine placement in division one
Queen comes to E3 apparently the bar
didn't love that still good for black
but why would that not be the best one
is it because Queen F3 what's the result
of the queen trade yeah I was trying to
puzzle that out as well of course the
Knight could head to D6 but the C4 Pawn
cannot be attacked again if white plays
Bishop B2 so the queen trade I would not
go with with open arms if I'm black I
would try to keep the Queens on the
board unless you can ensure that the
pawn promotes or that you can force
white to give away the bishop that is
the case Robert I think after Queen F3
trade and D2 I think wins by a tempo for
black
yeah and the C4 Pawn would be Loosely
plays Bishop F3 instead oh no Queen F2
check if you go King H1 G3 Falls and if
you played Bishop G2 just 94 after D2
and black is there first
and white will have to try D6 here I
think if black plays D2
but this is lost no matter how you slice
it LeBron tries King H1 but I think
Queen takes G3 would have ended it D2
ends it as well
it's over
Queen takes Jesus
Queen G3 because the queen can't take on
D2 the bishop on F3 is loose but I was
wondering if you could trade Queens even
and win that game but why trade Queens
when you could steal pawns and you could
steal another one with H3 come back to
G3 and then he won Lavon desperately
holding on to the promotion square a
couple more moves still required you
know what I would do I would go back to
E1 and then play H4 at the end of the
line and just promote that one
wow you're spoiled for Choice it's kind
of like ding the rent as you said
against Jana pump she hit a past A and C
Pawn here it's DNH Knight G4 ends the
game on the spot Knight G4 Blackboard
resign uh White will resign
yes Queen F2 mate is threatened Knight
H2 check and there is a resignation
shimanov wins and he goes up into second
place but tied for first with olive
frusia what a result and consternation
of the face of Lavon Rooney who was not
expecting to lose that game he drops now
he's on five out of seven still very
much in contention he's tied for seven
the place huge huge group of people with
five out of seven that include Shakura
Mahmoud let's go back to the last of it
game because that game is going to
determine a lot at the top E5 has just
been played by lazovic Robert we were
discussing this move earlier it didn't
work tactically now he's trying to make
it work because the Knight on E7 is
hanging but the eval bar hated it and I
think it was because of Knight F5
but what a move that is he gives him a
pawn with check and he says my king is
safe but wrong way the wrong way hard to
blame and black is still apparently
better because he's crashing through the
C file that Bishop on F6 if we see the
Queens come off the board it can't
attack anything it's stuck in enemy
territory and not able to defend and yet
another position where I would not pay
any heed to the eval bar look at White's
clock he's on five seconds now and
lazovic is losing control of the game
now Boris can play this positionally he
can take on D3 and go Queen C2 and try
to assert the superiority of his Knight
over the bishop
yeah this is strategically winning for
black in fact I think White's uh on the
verge of losing in just the three moves
Knight G3 check is possible tonight E3
doesn't look so bad but look at Black's
extra Pawn on the queen side
yeah extra fun on the queen side is
going to make its presence felt as is
the superiority of the Knight over that
Bishop which is now banished on F6 it
was strong with the Queens on the board
with the Queen's off the board it's
literally just doing nothing a little
bit of accuracy still required from Ben
Forrest lazovic is a demon in these time
scramble environments but Knight hits
the a32 yeah
the game
yeah I think that's game and Rook C4
simply just go after the Pawns take
everything he's doing Knight H2 oh he
pre-moved that that was not a smart
pre-move because you don't need to Rook
up to his mate resignation has happened
Jordan Von force was a five and a half
and a seven we haven't really said his
name too many times today Dania but you
see him now in a tie for third place
yeah then forest with an incredible
climb I think he had an early loss so
that's why he was banished to some of
the more uh lower half of the tournament
standings but all it takes in this
tournament is a couple of consecutive
wins and boom you're right back to the
top six out of seven uh is occupied by
farouza and Shimano if we're gonna have
a fascinating game Guess What Alexander
shimano's reward for beating anishagiri
in the monaronian hey now you got a
rampaging alireza farouza that you got
to put an end to
it might be a farusha that's happy to
make a draw but we do still have some
games remaining Donya so we do uh you
know click one pick one I'm happy to
join you for it okay we got a three on
two Rook end game uh in Yuri kuzabob's
game but let's go to Ronald saidwani
whose name we also have not been saying
he is playing the vanquisher of top GM's
Mohamed Dubai Shasha who unfortunately
is not going to be able to upset round
act this is or maybe he is actually this
is not quite over
well he is impressive in this event he's
an international Master title but he's
taking down GM but that was a mistake
Bishop takes no this is going to be a
losing end game isn't it it's almost
impossible to defend this but wait a
second still not totally over Bishop D5
Bishop G2
what's going on here
just Rook H6 all right
H4 H4 H4 oh I said why is it
just
so I I guess white can't go after the
d-pawn that's what's uh for again yeah I
won't miss I missed it again very sloppy
there by by Muhammad and with less than
10 seconds I mean you try defending this
right Rook G7 and H6
amazing stuff I wonder why I was winning
to begin with it looked very difficult
uh but after the trade of Bishop for
Knight then this is just a win
and the easiest is actually to put the
Rook on G7 cocaine T3 King takes D4 and
give your Rook up for the pawn and go
for the pawn on game very instructive
conversion there for round act and this
is all she wrote
and it's over ronix and wani takes that
game he was a 4.5 out of seven he still
is in Striking Distance you see the list
of names off the left side of the screen
the standings four and a half of the
seven with a couple more victories he
made land himself in the top ten but
what is this game bernatsuki and
mandanka
yeah this looks like a dead draw to me I
mean even if bernatsky is able to get to
that a pawn which he very well might be
it doesn't matter I mean with only one
Pawn left there's nothing to play for
Vitale has been has been squeezing this
for like 50 moves but I think it's about
time to admit that the inevitable
peaceful result is on its way here this
is
we saw a rook Pawn ending before and
here even if you get that A5 Pawn you
just don't have material left you could
have a nice Square bishop and your A4
pawn and you still won't win
pardon me
oh yeah because of a light Square Bishop
you're right on an a it is a
light Square
unless black blunder says Knight and
it's a draw
uh good good luck blundering the Knight
here and I don't think it's gonna happen
the game is over so Donna seven rounds
are in the books the players they get a
little bit of rest it is the second Fair
Play Break uh just to make sure that
everything is nice and tidy well while
the players they may be going away from
their computers you should not leave
yours stay tuned because in just a few
minutes we will be back for the final
two rounds of the Swiss portion here at
the chess kid cup play and phase we'll
be right back
[Music]
thank you
this right here is how I use chessable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I've
actually have my streak it says 1231
days right you're gonna forget a lot of
the things that are in the book Joshua
came around when I got on chessable it's
literally I was already doing that so
this is now a game changer because I can
do it faster it's online it's in front
of me all of my books are here if
they're gonna be folders now so I can
categorize my white black and all
tactics in-game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to
show you like how many testable books
you got I'm like all of them how are you
accessible is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
Chesterville which actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 on bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just
just being honest with you
the most important thing to know about
me is that I love the game of chess I
taught my younger brother to play when
he was four now he and I have been
teaching chess for 16 years we run the
online Magnus chess Academy where kids
get weekly small group classes with
vetted and trained coaches kids can
learn compete and even get the chance to
meet and learn from the most successful
players in the world
visit chessacademy.com trial to try a
small online class
thank you
foreign
if you're a title player it could be you
who we are watching during the next CCT
playing all title players are eligible
to compete in the 2023 Champions chess
tour so don't miss your chance to
qualify for the Taurus fourth event we
host qualifiers every Monday excluding
days when other CCC events are underway
your next chance to join the action is
next Monday May 8th for details use the
command qualifiers in chat but we are in
the midst of the chess kid cup playing
it is the Swiss portion I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me Grandmaster
Daniel nerdinski Donya seven rounds in
the books just two more remain but the
players they want to reach that top 10.
they do indeed things are heating up and
not only do you want to reach the top
ten you want to be the one choosing your
opponent in the playoffs so the top five
is really the most coveted territory not
only reservous Alexander shimanov are
locked in a tie for first place on six
out of seven if you're alireza farouza a
win would go a very long way it might
even potentially guarantee you the top
five spots regardless of your last round
result so I don't anticipate a quick
draw by alireza farusha on the other
hand Robert you might want to say listen
all I want is the top five I know that
I'm playing someone I'm favored to win
against but let me guarantee
qualification to the top division which
strategy do you think alirez is going to
adhere to well all I want to do is have
some fun and I think farrugia feels the
same way he is the stronger player he
has the white pieces but shimanov he's
been the underdog in his last couple of
games and what has he done he's beating
this Geary he's been levonne aronian why
not far Asian next I do think that Ali
Raisa should play it out I think he'll
be safe even if he draws this game and
then draws the next one his tie breaks
must be superb based on his blistering
hot start but Donna what risk is he
really taking by playing this out he
played a solid line at the very least
you could play out the opening and see
what position you get he played this
exact line but with the black pieces in
the last game against jul moussard a
game that ended in a quick draw now this
is a very fashionable line and typically
black develops the Knight to F6 first in
order to get that light squared Bishop
outside the pawn chain this is the
appeal of the Karo Khan as opposed to
the French who get to get that Bishop
out although sometimes if white plays H3
Bishop to D7 is all the rage
theoretically in this position Bishop H5
is also a move but I analyzed this
recently I think G4 G5 wins upon and
according to my analysis black doesn't
have complete compensation for it but
does alireza remember all of his
analysis does he is he comfortable with
this position if not Robert then perhaps
the most prudent approach is just to
play Knight E2 and play a quiet position
and that's what he does
I wouldn't be comfortable with either
color if G4 happened you know your white
king it may be in some danger down the
road the black pieces would be missing
upon so I think 92 is The Prudent
decision I like it a lot then I come to
F4 to take that Bishop for your knight
rather than your own bishop and so I
feel like it's a great opening choice
for alireza farouza and I just wanted to
point out that I saw some game end in a
draw I believe it was the game uh
between David Alton and Eduardo
itarizaga they're now playing for the
same Federation of Spain but a draw gets
them to five and a half out of eight and
I wonder if they should have played it
out and tried to see if there was going
to be a winner because if you're gonna
make the top 10 it's looking like six
and a half that's going to be a minimum
score required minimum score and some
players with six and a half might not
make it how many times the RCC have we
seen players paying the price for taking
that last round draw suddenly turns out
you went from best tie breaks to worst
cyborgs and that is why as you've been
saying uh since the beginning you do not
want to rely on your tie breaks unless
yes your somewhat like alireza and
you've been leading the tournament the
entire time
yeah so maybe a decision that they will
regret but I don't think farooja will
regret his decision to play 92 because
look what shimanov did he took on E2 and
how could any top player complain about
this position from the white side you
have a pair of Bishops you've done
nothing abnormal you're just developing
your pieces that Knight is now coming to
F3 as you pointed out he's controlling
the E5 Pawn break and if you play E5 if
you get that in you're left with an
isolated opponent's black if you don't
play E5 you're kind of restricted here
you pointed the E4 square that Knight
can jump in there but it's not
threatening anything and white can move
the bishop out play Rook C1 and maybe C4
at some point and you don't have forever
because black has a very typical stock
plan of establishing this sort of
Pillsbury Knight on e4 supporting with
F5 and then lifting The Rook from F6 to
G6 that is another positive byproduct of
the move F5 but Alexander he's a
positional player at heart he doesn't
want to do anything crazy if he can
avoid it he's trying to prepare the
minority attack on the queen side to be
popular says no no no and he might even
drive the spawn A5 in order to take the
sting out of B5 which shimanov could
consider playing anyway Robert in order
to open up the B file but then you would
have to reckon with the long-term
weakness of the a pawn so I'm calling A5
here by alireza and he has to be
thrilled with the kind of position that
he has gotten out of the opening does
this not remind you of the world
championship that just concluded the
game that didn't run really ran one
excuse me with the white piece is
against janapamshi yacht played A6 in
Anise Geary and was on the call I
believe you were on that game too and it
was like wait the A6 is a mistake
strategically in many of these positions
because now white has full control of
the dark squares on the queen side I
think that this is going to be fun for
white I don't think it's gonna be so fun
for black but maybe shimanov just way
better versed in these structures than I
am yeah I think Sasha's decision to play
A6 was a questionable one he did it
automatically and then started thinking
after A5 exactly like Don naponishi did
it as well it's not only realizing that
this complex of weaknesses on the queen
side is really holding black away from
operating on the other sides of the
board and as crazy as it is I think E5
might actually be the Lesser evil in a
position like this because if you give
only rest a lot of time what is he gonna
do well he's gonna double on the e-file
potentially of course you'd have to
support A5 he will entrench a knight on
E5 and as solid as black is I think
you'll co-sign me on this things can get
very very bad here if you give white a
couple of Tempe to really tighten the
screws
yeah black has no space because you
don't really want to push your beep on
even though in some positions it's
available you're left with an isolated a
pawn and Knight H5 heading into F4 G3 is
played you know there's gonna be a
sacrifice over there black would take
with a bishop and win the game so 92 as
you're saying great decision from shiman
he doesn't want to sit and wait forever
and find out what's going to happen he
is taking the game action into his own
hands these are the things that we take
for granted from Top GM's recognizing
the moment when you need to change the
course of the game when you need to
generate active counter play how many
players which is kind of dilly dally
around oh I'm really solid I have a nice
Pawn structure and then before you know
it there's a knight on E5 and you're
struggling to breathe Alexander shimanov
taking matters into his own hands trying
to get his Knight to F4 trying to get a
couple minor pieces off the board and I
think that the position is still closer
to equality than it is to a clear
Advantage for white and alireza he says
I don't care about that Apon I care
about the E5 Square
I think shimanov might refrain from
Queen takes a and play Knight
effing to his guns here
yeah Queen takes A5 would be a mistake
probably because B7 will be captured and
he played your move very quickly Knight
F4 does make sense and we will get
Bishops of opposite color and done I
think we should just correct the record
before it's even stated that Bishop's
opposite color often talked about oh
it's going to be a draw maybe that's
deep down in the end game but with so
many peace on the board it's about the
attack and actually having opposite
color Bishops could be a good thing for
the attack the bishop that's on D3 it
might slide back to B1 the queen can go
to C2 and your Bishop on F4 it's not
very helpful in defense
and there's tactics there black plays G6
then there might even be Rook take C6 at
some point it may seem like white trucks
are just futilely doubled on the e-file
but they're actually setting up really
fascinating tactics in the event The
Blacklist G6 the F7 Pawn is going to be
overloaded I think Bishop B1 is going to
follow right now I wouldn't be able to
visit this move and if you shift the
Knight over to F6 in order to guard H7
well then you relinquish the control
over E5 alireza is a monster in these
types of positions and it really cannot
be stated enough that opposite colored
Bishop middle games could not be further
or obviously colored bishop and games in
uh the type of in the nature of the
position
and I do want to point out that G3 would
be a very useful move for white king G2
a drop oh
that makes me you know that makes me sad
it makes me mad I don't like draw office
and chess but I understand why I mean
for the players they just want to get
closer and closer to the top 10 and they
may be ensuring themselves of that after
this draw but at the one point let's
just put this on the board because the
game is over is G3 would be a very good
move for white to play King G2 next if
not for Bishop takes G3 and after Pawn
takes Queen G3 check the Knight on F3
would be loose but if white could play
G3 King G2 in one turn then I think
white would have been happy to play on
because even when the queen gets to C2
the Knight can defend from f8 or F6 uh
Knight E5 isn't as dangerous as it
appears so an understandable decision
again their top priority is to get to
the top five the top 10 and make it to
division one obviously it makes sense uh
given the fact that a lot of other top
games have entered in a drop
particularly Jordan van forest and on
Drake and have drawn their game quickly
as well they're both on six and a six
out of eight and so that means alireza
is praying for as many people as
possible who've got five and a half to
make a draw let's take a look at some of
those people first of all we've got
Meyer and musard locked in a fascinating
middle game battle where black is up in
exchange but White's got a couple of
Pawns and some compensation
compensation at best for for white this
is bad situation but great news for
Georg Meyer we haven't spoken about him
but the player now who competes for
Uruguay he originally played for the
German Federation he's a monster in the
quickest of time controls he led his
Stockholm snowballs to the pro chess
League finals and that was a rapid chess
event where he's playing against teams
of force on the best players in the
world so Meyer knows what it takes to
compete against the world's best and
done it in this position with five
minutes on his clock with the black
pieces do you trust Meyer to be able to
convert a position like this it will
take some help from mussar
it will indeed and ctxd4 was disliked by
the evil bar who I think I like how I'm
talking about it like a person uh which
wanted black to take on C3 and keep that
Bishop against night situation now uh
Bishop tp4 oh that was missed by Meyer
and he's gonna have to make this
incredibly awkward move Robert Knight to
D6 after which white can take on D4 with
interest threaten 96 suddenly the
position is sharpening up and Myra has
to be careful not to blunder anymore
material away
suddenly white is the side for Choice
like that position just a moment ago if
black had taken on D4 with the Knight
this was an imprecise capture we take on
the Knight forcing the pieces off the
board black has an extra exchange yes
white has a couple pawns for that
exchange but it would not be uh full
equality I think black would have been
better but now black is retreating and
walking into pins and as you said Knight
takes D4 going into E6 bring a rook to
D1 as well black it could be in some
danger here absolutely Rook is coming
out quickly like you're saying there's
Fork threats Galore on the light squares
which black cannot control because he
doesn't have a light squared Bishop uh
neither does white for that matter and
Jules is deciding whether it's to take
on D4 or investigating move to the queen
to A3 right you gotta look at all sides
of the board when the center is wide
open like this and Black's pieces are
suspended in midair
Queen A3 might Force Bishop E7 so
Black's pieces continue to step
backwards while White's pieces step
forward the Knight takes D4 after that
night C2 takes D4 that is I do not like
this position for black I see the eval
bars like no Black's doing decently even
slightly preferable position it just
feels like the trajectory of the game is
in White's favor and there's so many
weaknesses in his camp York Meyer will
have to be more careful than ever if he
is to maintain a good position if he is
to avoid losing material along this
diagonal I think Jules is more likely to
play Knight C takes D4 Knight F takes D4
which has just happened
and now how is York going to defend
against the threat of 96 he can move his
Queen up but then the queen becomes
vulnerable it's undefended and white can
investigate more tactics with moving the
Knight away and opening up a direct
assault against that Knight The Rook
could also come to D1 I'm with you I'm
totally with you I think Meyer's
position is very very tough to play from
a practical perspective unless he unless
he has some tactic here to solve all his
problems
yeah he would need to figure a way out
but Bishop takes D4 was not it
apparently you can just take that back I
understand his idea is after Queen 64 he
wants Knight F5 that way he gets out of
the pin and he is able to say I'll trade
queens and be up material but the move
was not approved of by the engine and
while this decision the next decision
upon it I did want to take our attention
just quickly Daniel if you don't mind to
Mama jarv against Iranian that could be
a candid game but it's a game for
players at five out of seven Iranian had
a hot start but after that loss of
Shimano things have not been so peachy
but look at this end game here's the
black pieces it's even material but it's
not even because black connected past
bonds they're running first
and they're running forward and they're
running fast and white has only one pass
upon right now but he has to use it
strategically if you push it too early
you're actually in a way making it more
vulnerable and I think black is
assigning to the king the very important
task of keeping upon a bay instead
chakra are activating his Rook trying to
force Black's King onto a more Awkward
square one where it will have a harder
time of stopping the pawn the way that
white draws this Robert is by giving
away the d-pawn for one of Black's
passers if chakra can engineer that then
it's basically a dead draw so from that
perspective does it make any sense for
Lavon to throw his King side pawns to
the wolves and focus on advancing his
Queen side pawns and not giving them
away
not only does it make sense it's very
instructive and undoubtedly best the H
Pawn for white is on H2 very far away
Lavon aronian he quickly plays
what a move Rook B5 is amazing just Rook
A5 let's bring up an analysis board
because I want to show you how ugly
Black's Pawn structure is down upon as
well Rook A7 Rook A5 let's put this on
the board because white has to take that
Rook on A5 otherwise the pawn just
stormed down but once Rook A5 is
captured in this position
look at Black's pawns double I said a
pawns but it doesn't matter how they
look it's that you can't stop the
further most Pawn it's queening
it's incredible and for example let's
say white starts pushing it's not I mean
black wins by like 2 Tempe right if
White had H7 here this would have been a
draw at least here after H7 this is an
amazing position Black's only way to
stop the pawn is actually F5 without the
move F5 if you had put another Pawn on
the f-file that would have still been a
draw amazing tactics here great
calculation and look at LeBron's clock
six minutes and 20 seconds how
debilitating does that have to feel for
my mediara except he's not alone has
been winning games like this for well
over two decades
yeah and I think for Lavon he was using
the clock as a weapon that Rook end game
where we tuned in the eval bar still
said that Whitehead chances to hold but
not anymore The Rook slid back to B5 the
king sits in front of the passer and
with the Rook coming to A5 to block the
white Rook you want to stop at pass Pawn
from behind but the Black Brook is
getting behind and oh my goodness as
you're saying you know it's pretty Rook
on E5 as well b and a pawn even though
White's up one unfortunately those two
pawns are too fast for Mom yard to deal
with incredible finesse that Lavon is
demonstrating here I think the reason he
played King is that so this move does
not come with check so that he could
play rookie five and basically gain
another Tempo because Rook A7 is met
with Rook A5 white can come back to E7
but then black has optimized the
placement of his Rook pushes a3a2 and
then sends the beep on down the board
you know what I love is the many ways in
which Lavon is using his beep on he's
using it of course as a past spawn but
its primary use is as an anchor right it
anchors The Rook on A5 same role that
the F Pawn has he decides to push right
away that's also plenty good enough and
Rook A5 should decide it
yeah and the black king can always scoop
up the D6 pawn and I have a question
that maybe unanswerables I had this
notation booklet when I was a kid and on
the cover it said happiness is a past
Pawn so if happiness is one pass Pawn
what are two pass pawns oh gosh that is
bliss Euphoria Absolute Total Bliss Rook
F5 check
would be something to consider here to
banish the king further to the king side
but too many hands spoil the broth and
Lavon just pushes his pawns but mama
d'arf is in time if Lavon closes his
eyes and plays A2 and B4 Robert the king
does make it to C3 in time and that is
what you want to avoid if you're mama
duara if you're aronian because then the
pawns get totally frozen so what's the
winning move if white plays King D3
you lead with the B Pawn oh King B3
there
okay well Lavon says I don't hear any of
it he starts with Rook B5 that's
actually a great move because rookie one
then B2
wow Rook B1 A2 Rook takes B2 A1 and you
pin the rook and win the rook and win
the game my major has resigned what a
win what a bounce back win for levonne
rhodian who was facing a brutal pairing
yeah with five out of seven to face Mama
jar of uh that is not what you want but
a victory was what he won it's what he
came into that game for it's what he
earned and now he's back up at six and
eight in good shape to finish in the top
ten let's go elsewhere Dania that was a
wonderfully instructive Rook end game uh
what about Dimitri Kolar as I see that
he has five and after seven and he's
taking on Karel shevchenko
and a Time scramble is impending here
Carrell has one minute on the clock and
a
on structure that leaves a lot to be
desired but I still like Black's
position he's got control over the B
file fresher on B2 and that Bishop on D5
you know I have a love-hate relationship
with pieces like that because it may
look like a big Pawn but we know a good
Bishops defend bad pawns bad Bishops
defend good pawns however you want to
slice it it's a complicated and
double-edged position
yeah and what's the material count black
is up a pawn so let's not forget about
that I had to count because Black's Pawn
structure is so bad that it doesn't seem
that way but it is an extra Pawn for
black the bishop D5 that is holding
everything together it's such a great
piece there's no way to dislodge it and
I like chefchenko's chances and given
that he's got 20 seconds on the clock
now I was gonna say Bishop takes B3 yeah
he gives up the pride of his position
but at least he simplifies the position
now he has to avoid losing all of these
pawns Rook takes me through Rook takes
C6 looks really really hard to handle I
think the time might decide this game
oh my gosh he goes for it but Rook C6
what's his plan after that that just
moves Queen
[Music]
yeah there is that check I I saw that
before the queen blocks an F7 to save
The Rook there but I thought Rook C6 it
looks more dangerous for black the more
pieces that remain on the board that
exposed black king looks like it's in
danger but I guess kolars he wants to
make a draw
I think he's still playing though Queen
takes E6 if he could recover this Pawn
then
a weakness on E7 how easy is it to miss
a fork in a position like this and E3
what an instructive move saying hey my
Pawn is condemned so let me give it away
to ruin to make you ruin your own Pawn
structure
and look at this move Rook D3 white was
turning Rook F2 trying to get that
attack going but Rook D1 check would
turn the game around in Black's favor so
very instructive E3 followed by Rook D3
and now the black rook and queen stare
at the D5 Square we might just see some
very active defense from chefchenko and
18 seconds in the hands of a player as
experienced it feels like an endless
amount of time and when you're sitting
there with 18 seconds it feels like
you've got one second when you're
watching someone who's skilled in time
scrambles handle the defensive task
like it's you know oodles and oodles of
time he would probably draw this with
five seconds
it's a really good way of framing it
because as chefchenko probably very
worried about his King safety in the
club yeah and then on the other hand
kolars he's very experienced 3 000 level
Blitz player himself King H2 let's
sidestep anything make black choose
difficult decision that King G7
similarly pass back your turn go
and the King G7 excellent prophylactic
move a rook F2 isn't even a threat
anymore I apologize because uh White is
relinquished his control over that
square that would have been
a minor disaster
and a draw Green
there's a couple more moves here with
white but okay
I would have as well just because of the
clock but collage respects and
understands that chefchenko is super
duper strong in Blitz chess let's go to
this game here we assume we're starting
georgmeyer and uh-oh Meyer yeah he was
better but he walked into a pin and now
he is down a couple pawns and just
losing well he blundered in exchange if
I could rewind we don't have to go to
now sport just really really quickly
Rook D7 he played Rook E7 and he simply
blundered a fork Rook takes C7 Queen E7
and Knight G6 goodbye he blundered his
extra exchange back just leaving himself
two pawns down uh mustard sacrifices one
of them but not for long he's gonna
recover A6 and Meyer's gonna resign
yeah two extra pawns they're just
rumbling down the road you can probably
give up your Bishop here and still win
but why do that just move your Bishop to
D4 and play B5 B6 B7 and guess what B8
is coming right after that and so
georgmeyer he throws in the towel that
is a win for Jean musard and if you look
at the standings he is tied for first
place wow incredible performance by the
French Grand Master who is close to 2
700 feet he has had a string of
over-the-board successes he's been a
grand master I think since 15 or 16
years old so musard using his experience
using his tactical adroitness and
scoring a big victory out of a difficult
position against gerkmeyer
and Tanya while Jim russard scored a big
win I'm I have to look at this game
between lamlay and minlay we have delays
they're gonna lay it out on the line you
could say but Min is down to just five
seconds and he did have the upper hand
when we started but now it looks like
the position oh oh mistake from lamlay
we should probably explain this for the
Layman man this that game is so
complicated I might I might have to lay
down after we look at this time scramble
black with nine seconds on the clock and
wonderful time is playing for a win
D5 might have been a mistake but he's he
still has no risk
zero he's up a pawn with the black piece
okay but that was smart play from yeah
lamb he's way too strong uh to say I'm
gonna sit and defend for a long time he
knows the theoretical draw but let's
talk about PK and Kasparov they play
this end game because sparva actually
lost it and despite the fact that it
this is a theoretical draw with proper
play yeah foreign
is still to draw but
ton offend is the
is that's the sort of Ideal Pawn
structure right that diagonal formation
where the pawns defend each other is
considered to be the best arrangement
that you could hope for of course black
is the same thing the problem is that
black has no breakthroughs right that F
Pawn is a weakness if you play F5 yeah
congrats you've connected all four of
your pawns how are you ever going to
make progress in that position
and you can't even get F5 in because as
soon as the black king goes to the last
rank The Rook checks it and oh he wants
to win F2 for evil Rook of three check
but he doesn't have F5 to follow and
it's a draw
and they yeah draw Green go ahead good
hold good hold for the Vietnamese
Grandmaster
which one
[Laughter]
lay
Sean good answer let's let's go to the
federal save game against kovalenko
because that one's really important
Federal Sav needs to score Victory with
the white pieces here and he plays F6
and King B5 he's going for the B6 pawn
and kovalenko has to go after White's
vulnerable pawns but both of them can be
defended Knight a what Bishop D1 was
winning on the spot now the bishop can
travel back to C4 I think white is
winning
but it's gonna be close
Bishop takes A5 oh sorry D3 is hanging
you're absolutely correct my apology
yeah but but now you can't take on D3 I
don't think you're in time to promote
your B Pawn
so you move the king
oh that was a mistake I was going to say
Dunya it's one of these end games where
the evil Bar says White's winning but
you have so many equally attractive
options and you typically choose the
wrong ones D3 the bishop has to
sacrifice for the pawn and well does
black get back in time
well cavalenko seems very confident that
he does he didn't take any of his
remaining minutes to calculate this I
would be terrified with black Air King
C3 A6 is a loss
so the draw might be yielded by Knight
to D7 check
okay but this King to be seven beautiful
Knight back to D7 and you sacked the
Knight for the pawn now King C4 A6 King
B5 is the drawing idea
oh that is barely escaping King b5s you
have a knight to B6
Tempo or Tempo and white is no way to
induce one because the Knight has too
many squares that it can hop on to now
King A6 is a draw or Knight to D7 and
back to B6 now I sound like I got mutter
I'll pause the video now and you can
find a move
but that's unfortunate for federal sale
because he apparently had a winning
position and he would have jumped to six
out of eight now he's at five and a half
out of eight he needs to win that final
round he might get the black pieces in
that final round and he's gonna have a
difficult opponent so not a good result
for him and Anish Gary has suffered two
painful losses in this event but guess
what his name is there he's inside of
the place he's got pretty good tie
breaks and he's won all of his other
games he beat harshavardan an
international master from India who has
scored a bunch of upsets in his own
right Anish Gary also probably needs a
win given to side breaks that will put
him on seven out of nine and that will
essentially guarantee qualification but
six and a half Robert it's definitely
not gonna do it for everybody there will
be a massive group with six and a half
and only one or two players might
actually qualify
Dania click on the game that Anish gear
is playing and let's let everybody see
who his opponent is so and he's curious
against Ali Reza farouza not the pairing
you wanted alireza fuja floats down from
six and a half and eight
no I would not take the draw here and
find my Niche because his tie breaks has
got to be bad
but maybe he just wants to make it into
division two
I don't know about this though Robert
come on I mean you gotta try
yeah he's forcing the draw here
and what is he counting on because he
was in seventh place to start this and
the game is drawn it's official that
alireza of course he takes that look at
uh Jewel moussard and Shimano they drew
each other so we see the top three they
are in they are going to be in the top
ten that's great for them but for Anish
giri look at the number of people
trailing him and there are probably more
that aren't even on this first list of
the standings that can catch up to him
they're all the way down to 20th Place
I'm looking Min lay has five and a half
out of eight even further down York
Meyer at 24th has five and a half so
unless Anish can rely on his tie breaks
this might be a decision that backfires
yeah I mean the more people who've got
five and a half out of eight draw the
better it is for Anisha he's hoping for
a couple of those games to end in a draw
but because everybody there needs to win
we're gonna have a bunch of decisive
results it's a complete lottery Anisha
has no way of anticipating his tie
breaks not at all he's just hoping he's
just hoping that his game against
farugia that will raise his tie breaks
obviously because he played the guy in
the first place he just wants his
previous opponent it's all to win
seems to have good tie breaks chefchenko
may not so let's just look at games that
are actually underway we'll talk about
the tie breaks and who is going to be
competing for a spot in division one
there are five spots up for grabs 10
players will take part in the matches so
you need a top 10 finish and levonne
Ronin with the white piece against
Dimitri kolars Daniel I have to say
Kolar is super strong but compared to
playing always a farugia I think levonne
arone is very happy to be facing Dimitri
this is a great pairing and and that is
absolutely no knock on Dimitri kolaris
uh you know I would be a complete fool
for saying that he's an easy pairing but
again it's all in comparison right same
thing same strategy operates when the
top five players choose their opponents
in spot six through ten gukesh he he was
first to choose in the last event he
chose Vladimir kramnik is that because
Vladimir kramnik is weak no it's just
because he'd rather play kramnik than
you know andreza farouza
yes the choices are never easy at this
stage with these level of opposition but
look at this Knight F5 I think that
choice was pretty straightforward for
Lavon if Bishop takes Pawn takes white
controls all the light squares Dania the
knight in C6 is dominated by The Pawn on
C3 it is indeed and this is a great
position out of an Italian for Lavon
who's massaging
the advantage now he's got to decide
whether to take on D6 that does secure
the bishop pair but it allows black to
reinforce his control over the center so
big decision coming up here for Lavon
and there is the potential of tactics
with Knight takes E4 Robert eliminating
the defender of the Knight on F5 of
course right now white has the Desperado
countersack Knight takes H6 the Knight
takes E4 isn't a problem Lebon could
choose to improve his position slowly
with a move like Queen C2 I feel like
that would be very much consistent with
his style
but if he gets Ultra aggressive can he
bring his F3 Knight over to H4 to
reinforce the Knight F5 and I could see
plenty of sacrifices on the king side
that look to be winning for what love
that move now that you've put this into
my mind I think Knight H4 is lovely
if you just go for the attack there's
Bishop takes H6 being threatened with
Queen G4 Checkmate ideas this looks
really scary for black and where only 14
Moves In
and of course Knight takes D6 has a case
to be made because LeBron's tie breaks
are good if he wants to manage his risk
then I would take on D6 maybe go B3 and
C4 and try to play purely positionally
in this in the center but man oh man in
a rapid game I would not resist the
temptation I would play a move like
Knight H4 or keep the tension by moving
the queen he does take gun D6 though
that is a very super GM thing to do
and a slight understatement by you Lavon
aronian cyberries aren't good they're
great so if he draws this game I think
he will LeapFrog even Dimitri on Drake
in Fair chess on YouTube who's in fourth
so I think that's good for Lavon he gets
stored in his back pocket but let's not
forget he doesn't just want to finish in
seventh place in the top ten he wants to
finish one through five because then you
get to select your opponent so if Levon
wins this and ends up say in third place
you get to choose who you play from it
will be a selection of very tough and
challenging players but I think you'd
rather choose than be forced to play
somebody like farouzia without
questioning that we'd rather choose I
would compare it's a home court
advantage and let's say a basketball
series
only the Warriors had home court
advantage against the Lakers oh wait a
second
they do hey you you mean that levana
running's gonna drop a 50 piece on
Dimitri Kohler's here and uh 7-3 is made
but this is 92. I don't really
understand what that was about
I mean he's trying to go Knight f-193
it's a typical type of way to reinforce
your control over D5 the problem is
black is not just gonna lie around
and wait for white to do that he's gonna
go D5 and you don't have to tell Dimitri
twice
I didn't like that decision but done
really even a really yeah really really
Riley
if white trades the Queens off there
should be a poll in the end game you
have a three on two advantage of the
queen side and you have the pair of
Bishop so you were thinking the same
thing after Queen D5 Knight F3 here
let's get those Queens off I do think
Levon has the upper hand in the end game
yeah D5 can actually be a very overrated
idea in these positions because yes you
eradicate one weakness you close one
door but another door opens now the E5
Pawn has replaced the D6 Pawn as the
main weakness which I can attack
directly if you can induce the move F6
you're also weakening the complex of
light squares on the king side and even
though the Queen's off the board white
can still develop a massive initiative
here Robert I'm with you I thought D5
solved a lot of Black's problems but now
I see that Lavon has gotten exactly the
kind of a risk-free position that you
want to get he goes that F1 though he is
aiming I think for the D5 Square uh on
the strength of uh the Knight E3
maneuver
yeah no it's a reasonable set of moves
there by Lavon I think that the players
without the evaluation bar I'm guessing
they both assess this as slightly better
for white with the pair of Bishops with
the three on two Edge on the queen side
in terms of the number of Pawns there
and the fact that the Pawn's an A5
sometimes you wish that pawn could go
back to A6 to challenge the bishop or
back to A7 to keep more squares under
control from the opponent's pieces but
that pawn A5 it does stick out a little
bit and maybe Levant will be able to
take advantage of it even if right now
colors has a solid setup so why don't we
check on another game because so many
games during this late stage of equal
importance and who is going to make the
top 10. listen there are some players
we've never mentioned in this tournament
who are on five and a half out of eight
who could under the right set of
circumstances qualify with a win and two
of those players are probably out of we
haven't mentioned at all like Guang Lim
we've talked about quite a bit I want to
go to their game with your permission
because avalyanov is not mincing his
words he is saying I want to Checkmate
you that is the only thing that I want
in life and I want to do it I play
Knight to H5 and threatening Unstoppable
mates on G7 and H7 black might have to
go rookie 8 Bishop f8 how is like Lem
already hanging by a thread like 10
moves into this game
and 15. black is black isn't even up a
pawn usually in positions like this
white has sacrificed the pawn somewhere
maybe the A3 Pawn is off the board so in
the long run black will be material
ahead but this is even material and the
King on G8 looks wide open Knight H5 is
met by Bishop to f8 you will not be
capturing the Knight that would be a
force Checkmate if you do but Bishop G5
if you play F6 Bishop takes G6 oh gosh
and Bishop e65
but then maybe
I know d8 is hanging
oh my gosh Knight H5 he missed it he
missed that H5
and Pablo you don't have to look at this
like is this too good to be true no it's
not Pavel now wait a second can I ask
one question
if we pull up the analysis board Knight
H5 Bishop f8 I actually don't think this
is as good as it looks Bishop d8 Bishop
H6 Knight F6 King f8
and if you take on E8 I take on d8 force
your knight back and then there's the
key resource Bishop D2 and I start
vacuuming up these weak pawns on the
queen side I actually think that Knight
H5 might not be the best move
you don't it's one of those positions
that you see the eval bar Skyrocket you
assume it's direct if you play Bishop
takes E7 first ah
like if you the queen takes they're
still Knight H5 and you go Queen f8
trying to stop the main on GSR this is
just okay you're just vacuuming all the
pawns up that's gross and Knight of six
check then leads to mate anyway
indeed you have no other way of
Defending because if you take the Knight
here and say hey I have the f8 square I
can escape no you cannot you're Queen
and this is such a common theme right in
these types of positions when the queen
stops the king's evacuation route and
blocks it
so Pavel has to hold off on the
temptation to play the immediate Knight
H5 and I think he's going to do that
because he's thinking right the fact
that he's taking now two minutes means
he's calculating these lines he is aware
this is not as simple as it appears and
he's played Rook takes C6 and I saw that
and it's good
apparently it's good I don't care about
X marking the spot he just took a pawn
that was sitting on E6 like yes that
wasn't the game-ending tactic but that
still is a brilliant idea if Paul takes
E6 Don is about to point it out for you
Bishop takes G6 leads to a checkmating
attack it's a beautiful move and I think
we can all appreciate it and we can all
accept that Bishop takes C7 was winning
on the spot so it is a mistake from a
purely objective standpoint but Pablo is
going to get a pawn up position and it's
not like his attack ends right I think
it's important to point out that after
the trade on E8 and after white
recaptures the bishop on G5 white has
this devastating idea of 94 Knight F6 so
the dark squares on the king side are
still plaguing black and he's down a
protected passer on D4
yeah I think it's one of those
situations where I would like to give
that one exclamation part instead of
four okay Bishop takes E7 with these
ideas of Knight H5 that's game over oh
look Queen D5 played Knight H5 what is
he doing which is checkmate it's
completely over this is a very
forgettable game he just forgot about
this idea of nh5 Knight H5 he will
resign on the spot
yeah and El yadav here we lifted to six
and after nine and he is going to take
part potentially in those matches to see
who gets into division one Knight H5 is
obvious I think he's been thinking about
it in the past Rook E6 was a nice tactic
uh that he found and Knight H5 is step
two and it's game over no this is just
complete Collapse by like Huang who
would have given himself some practical
chances but Bishop takes G5 but the
dejecting thing is that a draw is
obviously not good enough he was trying
to keep things complicated and in the
end he's got himself mated Pablo yanov
not a great chance I think given that we
haven't talked about him so he hasn't
been atop the tournament standings but
again the tie break is the cumulative
score of your opponents you never know
how your opponents do even if they
suffered an early round loss
well actually Bishop E4 this Knight
takes E6 you know there are things that
get a little bit tricky or like Knight
F5 trapping the White Queen the problem
is that you lose all of your minor
pieces in both of your Rooks but eh
nothing that you can't survive
how many pieces is white up white up a
queen for
one Pawn right now
[Laughter]
that's right now what about a rookie
four maybe the Knight F5 is a little
annoying
yeah
he has to be a little careful here can
you do me a favor Donya put rookie4 on
the board I'm curious if black is not
even worse anymore after rookie 4.95
okay black is better unbelievable so
easy to blunder look at that
the Queen's trapped Bishop E7 Knight H6
now it looks still winning for him but
it's not and the reason why in fact
black is winning here because there's
too many threats right rookie seven
Bishop before and F5 three threats and
black is gonna recapture The Rook with
interest
instead Pavel wants none of it and what
he does want is a win and that's what
he's gonna get I think F1 and Bishop E7
is game over sir
complete Game Over Knight F6 following
Queen H7 Checkmate it just all it took
was that King Moving Out The Way of the
bishop and now this is over so I think
we can get out of here the game is
officially over El janov wins and you
see him there in seventh place currently
with many of the other contestants still
playing their final round game
and a lot is going to come down to the
players who still have six out of eight
I'm talking uh levana running Dimitri
callers and the players who currently
have five and a half for debate
um one of whom
who has a crazy position against Pete
and Eon the very same guy who defeated
Anish giri in the early round
and
what do you make of this
hello Five Pawns for black Five Points
so even material somehow I feel like
Black's King on E6 despite being wide
open is very safe because that Queen B3
it can't get in if that Queen could
somehow Slither to a square like C5 or
come in the dark squares then the king
would be in trouble but the A2 Pawn is
loose so white feels a bit stuck and I
wonder how black can make progress yeah
White's Queen is stuck you don't have A3
none of B4
Rook A1 there's the answer but what
about King B2
only move I guess and where does iguana
go Rick F1 he's going after the pawn
simply
trying to force white into playing Rook
G2
Bishop E3 would be a huge blunder
because F4
okay
it's defensive but it's stepping the
wrong direction for sure
but you might have no choice he's trying
to defend actively he wants Rook D6 and
queen 65 but does that work tactically
I don't think it does I think black can
take
and he does
ah so
yeah I'm confused by this game but Rook
D6
Queen takes D5 is still something to
consider but I think black is able to
get out of that yeah Queen T5 and rookie
eight almost Checkmate but black has the
Escape score on D7 maybe he missed
something like that I think he actually
missed that after Queen D5 black takes
on D2 and white does not get checkmated
there the problem is that Black's Queen
escapes the sixth ranked pin so that
black can take on D5 this I think he
might have overlooked
but he's still trying look at him go
King C1 that was a mistake apparently
well now there's no threat Queen takes
D5 is no longer a threat because black
has Queen A3 in response getting out of
the pin on the sixth rank with check and
then you win the queen so black has a
move
I think you cannot allow Bishop G5 check
that might result in Checkmate so black
should play F4
great move that's such a nice
prophylactic move and it also advances
the passer could do worse than that and
is some trouble here
that was actually awesome I really like
I like that one he's playing quickly but
he is in trouble on the board and David
has had a really good day of Chess he
would love to get this Victory and end
up in the top 10.
he absolutely would and he started off
by Leading the tournament he was the
only player I think to win his first
four games I want to say
before he met Mr farugia and Mr farusha
has stopped a lot of players from having
a perfect score
yeah and David Anton made a bunch of
draws along the way so he would love to
end with his one what about Queen C8 and
queen G4 girl love it let's go the Queen
the queen on A6 it's it did attack A2 it
was protecting C6 but now it's time to
bring in the game and deliver that final
blow to the white king I think Queen G4
is just nasty
there goes black screen love those types
of geometric Maneuvers maybe Anton has
left himself with plenty of time to
figure this out this is
easy stuff for breakfast you'll find it
he should
and I'm just looking at the other games
because so many are important for the
standings I see that Jordan van Forest
he had six out of eight entering this
final round he got the white pieces
against Eduardo itarizaga all things
considered a great pairing now he's up a
piece and I see the evaluation bar
saying that Jordan should be winning
let's go to that game real quickly B4 by
the way is a sick move by David Anton
and he follows it up with Knight C3
checks so one way or the other I think
he's figured out a way to get to White's
King let let us indeed go and see if
Jordan can convert this position with
five minutes on the clock yeah he's
gonna convert it or is he
wait a second when I when I looked off
screen before it said that white was
winning and he is of a piece but the a
pawn is causing him problems and now
he's losing his H Pawn and once he loses
his H Pawn the G Pawn Falls next and if
he loses the chief on then he's down to
only one Pawn this could come down
Robert to rook and Bishop versus rook
and I don't know if a tourism has enough
time to save Bishop H7
yeah it's coming and then she said if
you're King D6 Bishop H7 takes G6 on the
road the king for black is in the wrong
space What A Move by Eduardo
eval bar is being inconclusive here I
wouldn't even go Bishop E6 and try to
keep Black's King confined oh you're
brilliant and he doesn't King E2 King E3
King D4 King E5 King F6 Here Comes The
King
yes sir and I think Eduardo has to has
to have used his pawns to keep White's
King at Bay Rook G4 was the worst
possible move I think white can sack
everything and go to F6 goodbye yeah
here comes again later see you later I
think it's over gotta run King e a king
d8 he's blundered it wow he threw
yeah and what's the winning move here
it's King F6 no king king F6
88 The Rook D7 check you have to go to
EA I have I have Rook C7 a little kicks
you have Rook D3 check
take all of the pawns and the fact that
he left himself with that one last
remaining Pawn that's what's gonna do
him in
look at this just taking F3 and taking
G6 then he will in fact win F4 Jordan
from forest he could even be the one
seed so he wins this game he turns out
was an immense time and where does he
finish no he's in fourth place uh but
this the final standings are not set
because still games in session still tie
break points to be won and let's go back
to maybe the Indian game against uh
David Anton
let's go back because David Anton still
hasn't quite delivered the finishing
touch and now he's the one down to 40
seconds on the clock he's struggling to
figure out the crushing blow here and
inion is setting up potential counter
play against the F7 punt of course you
can't really play C5 ever because of
Queen F1 Checkmate what's the winning
move here as David offers the queen
trade is that it it is
yeah and he's winning with two separate
pass pawns if you take on B6 let's not
forget that black is actually a pawn
ahead in the position and you could take
C6 those pawns are unimportant he's got
the F Pawn and the pass C Pawn that's on
C3 in enemy turret to a great move from
deviantan no risk associated with it and
he's winning the game
and that would mean naveena tone Rises
to six and a half out of nine displacing
somebody who's got six and a half from
qualification to the top division so I
stand corrected most players who got six
and a half are going to qualify in fact
probably everybody bought a single
unlucky player is going to qualify that
is why anisha's decision is so risky
because you're playing the lottery you
have no idea who that player is going to
be
well Daniel I'm looking right now and
there's still many more games oh players
with the five night points that's how
many people at five and a half the
standings keep going down all the way to
23rd Place I see Garrick Meyer he is at
five and a half and eight still going on
there but anisha's hybrid seemed better
than a bunch of those players we'll see
when all is said and done but we know
David Anton he's about to take this one
and that means that he'll make it
through to the top ten indeed and
there's the queen trade there's F3 he's
got too many pass pawns white has to
stay afloat but white is almost in zuk
zwang I think he's got to keep his Rook
on the f file so something like Rook F5
and then black just goes Rook F1 and F2
and it's the classic scenario where
you've got the C Pawn keeping White's
King on the losing Square Rook F1 is
beautiful geometric finish with a skewer
at the end and so that means David Anton
will finally get to six now it feels
like we were talking about it for a
while now with the winning chances but
that seems obvious and it's nice to see
the wind you know exactly how the game
concludes Rook F1 F2 and then A1 is the
dagger and D6 is futile King E8 holds
the F Pawn while keeping the d-pawn at
Bay this has been known for over 400
years this is a classic classical ft C6
I would simply play and if the Rook
stops the pawn from the side then Rook
to C1 check followed by promotion picks
up the rook and wins the game
nicely done good execution Rook A1 you
want to see the final move there it is
resigns
well done for David Anton so is that all
are all the games done right now I still
see some in session some in session so
the next the top game that is still
session is kobalenko against sedwani
and Igor kovalenko is in big big trouble
against the Indian Talent it's around X
and wani has something to say
yeah he could sneak into the top 10 and
try to play for qualification into
division one of the chess kid cup and
queen C4 I would not be trading Queens
if I'm black Black's King is way safer
than white but that F3 squares under
White's control that's important because
Rook F3 ideas is what I'm aiming for
yeah and I guess Queen A1 King B3
White's King is more or less safe for
the time being it's important that the
F3 square is being held instead
kovalenko tries to cover the king with a
nice little blanket moves The Rook over
to A2 and it's so debilitating that
you're also a pawn down in this position
you're not even suffering for anything
yeah though black can't bring the Rook
into the attack because C7 is loose and
I don't think Veronica is going to
repeat the position but look at
kovalinko's clock a minute 45 compared
to 24 seconds for his opponent yeah that
could allow him to survive this game it
absolutely could allow them to survive
this game but he's got to figure out the
proper arrangement of his heavy pieces
does the queen belong on C4 and where
does The Rook belong The Rook is going
hither and thither it is Meandering from
A2 to E2 back to A2 defending and
attacking in Black has to leave the C7
Pawn hanging and now we're gonna get a
crazy tactical scramble
yeah YouTube this one is hanging it is
winning A4 is hanging the E2 Rook is
under attack and queen one check Queen
see a two where's the mate where's the
mic
I see one just to C5 yeah Carver that
like that as well oh but Queen C5 King
A2 and rep remember why does this check
on H3
Roddick might not be seeing it and I
don't see it but but I think Queen C1 to
bring the queen to B2 and then Queen C5
check because A4 hangs with check oh you
rascal that's exactly Rook a four Rook
before beautiful great tactical find by
you
and ronak wins the game it's a six and a
half out of nine
so the big question now that he's won
the game is where does he land I'm
looking for his name on the list where
is run except oh 11th place so right now
he is no just outside the top ten but I
want to remind everybody the tie breaks
update automatically after the last
round is like uh as men wins his game
and moves to six and a half out of nine
so take what you see in front of you
with a grain of salt because the tie
breaks they automatically update but
only after all of the games are finished
so someone like Min Lee might actually
end up in the top ten
it's true but right now 14 players well
I should say 5 through 14 so it is 10
players who have six and a half out of
nine and not all of them will make the
top ten why is it so important to be in
the top ten there will be a match play
after this and one through five get to
choose their opponents in six through
ten and the winner of those matches they
make it to division one of the chess kid
cup so Dania I don't think this game
will impact this the standings for top
10 which is hilarious because we're
talking an FFL yeah and another really
really FFL we have two legends of the
game in a rook end game now it's just
Kings and both these players I mean
Superstars gotta komsky playing against
carpool for a feeding World Championship
soccer mamajarov has been well over 2800
but they played to Bear Kings they made
a draw and unfortunately for them
they're not gonna Vibe for division one
but maybe they'll be able to fight for
division two
this reflects a lot more on the strength
of the tournament than on the weakness
of these players every single round is
brutal you can lose to absolutely
anybody and a lot of players who were
leading early who had two out of two uh
they're nowhere to be found because they
lost a couple of critical games in the
later rounds Dennis lazovic
unfortunately he was one of those
players who lost his last round and is
not going to make it into division one
but now the big question Robert which of
these players are going to have the
better tie breaks we have 14 people
right now uh and six and a half out of
nine is a huge tie
who is going to make it who's not it's a
complete lottery it's a total Lottery
are there any games still going because
that's the nature of olympiads and
events where Ty bricks are apart and
look at this game uh it seems irrelevant
right these players aren't competing for
the top 10 but maybe they help someone
with tie breaks so let's look at that
crooked Bishop versus Rook Donna you
mentioned earlier how much more
difficult this is than rook and Knight
restrict but this I believe is the
Cochrane defense in in the rook and
Bishop ending you keep the bishop pinned
from a distance and that means the king
can't come over to C5 yeah this type of
defensive construction named after John
Cochran uh lived in the late 18th
century he's also known for the Cochrane
variation of the Petrov now out of
fashion but still very interesting line
where you sack the Knight on F7 he also
contributed to the theory of rook and
Bishop versus Rook villador as well
analyze this and a drop by 50 move Roll
But mentee holds the draw and like you
said this half Point Robert could be the
difference between one player qualifying
and another player qualifier anybody who
played these two players that is going
to impact the overall Tournament
standings in the Moment of Truth has
arrived the standings are about to
update but we still owe a game going
oh my goodness and you have two pass
pawns for black a white has a rook and
if that white king could get into D6
when the Kings on d8 there could be
checkmating threats so black does need
to be a little bit careful here Rook H7
is what I would play oh he goes into the
king first all right I think you need to
kick that King to the back rank you know
what the player with the white pieces
does when he's got a sore throat
he gargles with salt water
I was waiting for something bad you've
had so many great puns throughout the
day and I'm glad it's the end of the
Swiss before you made your first hero
and the results are in we see farrugia
in first place we have zoom Broussard
second shimana third uh George went
forward in fourth no surprise there but
look down to 10th kareal chefchenko he
sneaks in andish Gary also is in the mix
and El yanov after that great win over
Liam oh he does not make it and neither
does mentally and neither does York
Meyer I didn't even realize that he was
in contention for six and a half out of
nine what an insane finish in anishagiri
Robert I guess his decision to make that
draw it was rewarded he got to play
alireza that gives his tie breaks a
massive boost we will see a niche in the
playoffs for around for the top group
we certainly will and we would talk
about top 10 matches it may be confusing
for some but let's let everybody into
the know this is what is at stake in
match play five players will advance to
division one 16 players will make their
way to division two 32 will go to
division three and 21 players that are
going to be playing in the matches will
be eliminated and not taking part in the
chess kid cup so Dania we don't know
who's gonna make it to division one of
the Chester cup but we do know three
players who made it via the chessful
messers Nakamura karwana and Abdus
atarov so three super strong players
waiting to find out who the other five
will be in division one indeed it's
quite easy to follow there are eight
total players in uh the chess get final
three spots secured and you're like well
are there 10 players who qualify no 10
players make it into the playoffs of
division one but of those five are going
to win their mini matches and join these
three monsters for uh the chess get cup
which will be commentated from Oslo
it'll be my first trip and I honestly
can't wait for it
no I can't wait either I'll be
spectating you and the Gang commenting
that but before any of that happens we
don't know who's gonna make it let's
talk about the format of match play
because for division one there will be
10 players uh trying to make it through
five will get there but 10 minutes and
two seconds per move just like we've
seen in the Swiss the matches will have
two games one and a half points out of
the two games or if you score two out of
two you win the match and the top five
from the Swiss will choose their
opponents that play six through ten and
in match play the results determine the
division placement for the chess kid cup
and so Donnie and I throughout this show
have been talking about how important it
is to finish the top ten and in
particular those who finish in the top
five because as you see here the top
five get to choose numbers six through
ten so the numbers one through five
they're gonna hang out on the left
number six through ten they're on the
right and the players on the left say oh
I want to play you you're my opponent of
choice Donna these choices are never
easy though
they're never easy sometimes they're
more obvious and sometimes you can
choose along similar along different
philosophies right one way to choose is
I'm going to play the oldest player you
know I'm going to play the guy uh you
can also play the guy's least
experienced in your eyes and Rapid
sometimes you have good results against
a particular opponent but I do want to
say that the choice of an opponent is a
pretty big Advantage a player can really
optimize their chances for success by
choosing the player that they think
they're gonna have the biggest success
against obviously another fun narrative
is when that choice backfires and when
the first player chooses and then ends
up losing this mini match but again it's
a 2 game mini match there's zero margin
for error Robert and I just love the
melding of different formats the fact
that we have a Swiss where you can
afford to lose a game and then a a mini
match where essentially you can
no you cannot and I like what you're
saying there because in the air things
messers some players who finished at the
top and chose their opponent they didn't
actually win that match but for the
chessful Masters the top players all
selected their opponents and all four of
them won there are five spots up for
grabs this time because Magnus Carlsen
will not be taking part in the Cheska
cup he has an over-the-board conflict
that means he cannot play in the third
leg here of the Champions chess tour but
in the chesswell Masters we saw Liam lay
we saw Levon aronian we saw Vladimir
fellow and vladislav artemiev they chose
their opposition and all four of those
players won their matches so we have
five players that we know get to choose
and we saw four players finish with
seven to the nine and then between six
and a half and nine there were 10 people
tied unfortunately some will not have
access to division one but even they
will play batches they'll be vying for
division two and if they lose their
match they go down to division three so
done is so many spots are up for grabs
indeed and that I think is the The
Genius of the divisions right yeah if
you're in division two division three
you're not going to get that
professional coverage from the Norway
Studio what you are going to get are
very serious prizes There's 7 500 10 000
at stake for these bottom two divisions
what does that mean it means the lower
rated players players who know that they
don't really have much of a chance to
make it into the top ten by the way
there aren't a lot of those players
almost everybody has a serious chance we
saw players like Min Lee who recently
got his GM title confirmed he was that
close to making his way into the
playoffs for division one but the
players who finish in 30th and 40th
they're not going to be forgotten about
they are going to get a chance to win a
serious prize I mean less than 7 500
that uh is quite a bit more than my
first car cost
yeah no the players even in division two
I believe first place in division two
wins a cool ten thousand dollars and
access to the next events division one
and here we see it these are the players
who finish in the top ten those on the
left hand side of your screen they get
to choose their opponent from the right
hand side of the screen so Dania I'm
gonna put you on the spot I know we're
friends but sometimes friends have to do
this to one another if you were playing
If This Were Your Choice who are you
selecting from six through ten
so you're saying if I'm alireza farouza
who gets to select first
um I'm going to predict that alireza
farusia definitely I think it's gonna be
between David and son and Dimitri
callers I'm gonna vote Dimitri callers
then I think Jewel mustard is going to
choose the vedanta
I think Alexander shimanov is going to
choose Karel shivchenko and I think
Jordan went Forest is going to select
his compatriot Anish giri
okay Daniel I don't know how anyone is
supposed to make these choices because I
don't know either yeah player's name on
the right hand side of the screen are
super strong when Anish giri Dimitri on
draken David Anton and Dimitri college
and kareel shevchenko by the way is
almost 2 700 feet a I don't envy the
task of the top five players I think
it's going to be difficult for them they
will take some time deciding who they
want to face and while they do that we
are going to take a break but when we
return we will have the matchups of
division one ready for you we'll see who
will be able to make it through to
division one in the chess kid cup but
for now we take a break along with the
players and we will be back for more
action
chess kit is fun
Jess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
oh
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chest tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quant experience
no problem
so do you think you have what it takes
to compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back everybody I know it's been
a while but if you've forgotten I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me
Grandmaster Daniel narodiski after nine
grueling rounds of action in the Swiss
in this Rapids High Patrol we know our
pairings for placement into division one
there are 10 names vying to join no dear
back up five minute karwana and Hikaru
Nakamura and Donya these are your
matchups when you see these three here
which matchup sticks out you the most
man oh man I already forgot my
predictions Robert so you know that's
the best part of it I don't know if I
got it right or wrong shimanov
chefchenko is going to be a fascinating
matchup I'm looking at Ole reservous and
David Anton who what a brilliant game
that you directed my attention to
earlier Robert I want to see David and
Son score some options and I want to see
farouza go further than he did last time
it's an Unstoppable Force against an
immovable object well farooja chose uh
David Anton as his opponent will that
payoff remains to be seen But there are
two more match-ups that will happen to
determine the five contestants joining
the three already qualified in division
one this one's huge look at these
matchups Tanya they were down to the
last two choices but Jordan Von Forrest
he had the fourth pick he chose to play
his compatriot Anish giri
he did indeed and I remember that was
the prediction that I had made
man oh man Anish giri did Jordan then
Forest a solid the other way around
actually and taught of Steel when
Jordan's win against abdusatora Robert
guaranteed anishikiri the tournament
Victory but right now they're enemies
right now there will be blood spill to
the board
there certainly will be just like tats
of Steel a couple years ago when they
played in a tie break and Jordan van
Forest took the title but let's not
count out this matchup between 11 of
ronin and Dimitri on draken uh Lavon was
left with no choice he had to play on
draken and that one is a toss of super
Grand Masters but there's also action
that is going to happen for placement in
division two where the winners of some
matches they'll go to division two the
losers they secure a spot in division
three but look at these names Dunya I
mean look at how many great players are
on this list
I gotta say number 16 The Armenian
International master has the most
awesome name of all time
it like rolls right off the tongue so
it's great to see players who are a
little bit less famous a little bit
lower rated getting a chance for a big
prize is who pointed out ten thousand
bucks for the winner of division two and
of course you've got some regular names
you've got Min late or Meyer and
paboliano of the players who didn't
quite make it into the top ten are going
to have a chance to make it into the
next tournaments division one with a
victory in that's two as we look at the
next players
that's right look at how many strong
players still on this list chocol has a
chance to make it to division two David
Navarra that is a former super Grand
Master Vincent kymer a current super
Grandmaster so done the list goes on and
on so much strength even at the bottom
of the players who are trying to make it
to division two
indeed Chris Johnson camera there
anything but the bottom in terms of
their rating and their abilities and
this is honestly fascinating you can
follow division two a division three
they function as their own Super
tournaments they really do there are so
many strong chess players in the world
and we're happy to highlight them and
that includes the people who are
participating in the matches determining
whether they go to division three or
they don't take part at all in the chess
kid cup at the end or May 22nd to 26th
you see names like gotta komsky just
missing out on a chance to play for
division two and Arjun era geisi who was
in the air things Masters top division
Dennis lazific as well done it they're
playing just to get into division three
yeah I mean Dennis lazovic was tied for
first he started off so well but over
nine rounds you have to sustain the
effort you have to avoid consecutive
losses and some of these were not quite
able to do that and yet they still have
a chance to Vie for serious prizes and
of course the winner of division three
gets an automatic ticket into next
tournaments division two it's a long and
Rocky and difficult path but uh I was
gonna say it's a Balboa path but it's a
path that any of these players can take
it's a complete toss-up
it is because look at this list as well
we see strong names like Lauren Francine
we saw a game of his earlier uh but when
you look at these players Maxine Chicago
he could be fighting for division one in
fact I believe that he's taken part in
matches where he could have made it to
that top division Dunya just a countless
strong chess players I only got one
thing to say and that's babazada
babazada just kidding Alexander
donchenko comes to mind as well he's
almost 2700 chagaya vayapov really
incredibly evenly matched battle going
on in division three and so great these
players are getting an opportunity to
have their moment in the sun again bye
for serious money prizes and keep
ascending their way to the next division
more names join these bunch I mean look
at this the last batch of players we
have Andrew Tang better known as penguin
GM he is a bullet Beast we have players
like razva priyotsu who were in the Pro
chess League knocking off higher rate
opponents Benjamin Buck a popular
streamer and David paravian he was
always a force in the rapid Chess
Championship so no matter where you look
all the way down to number 74 here
trying to make it into division three we
have to remind everybody that The Losers
of these matches they are limited so to
remind everybody as well of not just you
know who might get a limited of the
format because we are no longer in the
Swiss
10 minutes and 2 seconds per move that
time control remains but the matches are
just two games you can't lose a game and
hope to bounce back three rounds later
this is a match the first of one and a
half points wins and we saw the top five
select their opponents from places six
through ten the rest of the players
fighting for division two and division
three they just face the opponents that
were in the standings opposite them but
this is a match play Donya I'm super
stoked I'm stoked as well we got so many
matches to follow uh Robert and we're
gonna be toggling between the games the
start of the games are staggered so
we're gonna try to bring you all of the
most interesting action from all of the
games obviously from the commentators
perspective we hope that there will be
Armageddon we hope that some of the mini
matches will end one one from the
players perspective you just want to
knock your opponent out in the first
game you want to strike early and often
and you want to justify your choice if
you're in the top five of course in the
NBA you've got the bottom seeds
dominating the top seeds let's see if we
see that same thing here
yeah no this is a situation where I
think the fans they love Armageddon with
the bidding that's been a favorite in
the Champions chess tour but the players
that's stressful for them they want to
avoid that if they can so we'll see as
the first moves go underway you know who
is going to be in good shape nine rounds
of Swiss plus a match that's exhausting
it's grueling Dania it isn't it and
that's obviously one of the reasons why
in the first game you often see the
player with the white piece is taking a
little bit of less of a risk right and
playing something a little calmer at the
same time you want to set it a good tone
and at the same time we've also seen so
many players from Alexi serrana uh to
alireza farusha we've seen so many
players coming back in the second game
on demand in fact it happens with
Incredible frequency in these specific
mini matches Robert so we will see which
stories of resilience we will have but
the games are underway we've got alireza
and have you done tone repeating they're
opening from their game during the Swiss
I was going to say this position looks
familiar and I was going to dig deep
think who played this game and it was
these exact moments and that game was
won by Oliver his King if we can
remember went to F1 after it was given a
check and then he was able to outplay
David Anton so look at David think he
plays Bishop G4 just like last time and
after D4 we saw the black pawn go up to
E6 and the bishop1fa did not theme keto
because it's a Pawn on E5 that would be
in its path
and we remember that if you don't want
E6 and then he went F6 at the wrong
moment and created more weaknesses on
the king side so David really the ball
is in his court to demonstrate that this
is a playable position but I seem to
remember Robert that we did like his
position structurally and from a
developmental standpoint I think that he
should focus on quickly getting his King
side pieces out again he plays this move
E6 in order to freeze the E5 pawn and
lock it in as a Target
yeah why not I mean go after that E5
Pawn but white easily defends it F6 is
one of those big choices that black will
have to consider at the right time but
it's just not an easy move to play if
your king falls under Fire so I'm
looking at the clocks they're evening up
El Reza he is making sure that he's not
making early mistakes and he castles
King can hardly fault him for doing that
yeah you absolutely cannot we're
expecting Bishop G7 and then the big
decision that David is gonna have to
make once again is whether he develops
his Knight to E7 and F5 French style or
does he disrupt the center immediately
with F6 which I think makes a little bit
more sense here than it did the first
time he played it because his gang can
seek shelter on the king side in that
semi-open f file again very standard
Affair in the French even though this
didn't come from a French it doesn't
matter the structure is still the same
that's true and there's players I mean
they're really moving quite slowly at
the start here it is a rapid game they
get 10 total minutes the two second
increment will come in handy uh but
we're very early stages of this game and
they keep going for these pretty
decently sized things
indeed they are but David one of the
other things he's doing in the same way
is he's taking a lot of time the first
10 moves ten plus two sounds like a very
expansive time control but all it takes
is one long think and hey you're down to
four or five minutes almost every time
we've seen a player fall behind I think
three minutes or more that is basically
like being down upon
yeah no James candy he says all the time
that the clock is the 17th piece you got
to use the clock as a weapon when you're
ahead on time and right now alireza
freezer well ahead on the clock still
plenty of time for David Anton but the
situation it hasn't even gotten tense
yet no pawns are staring at each other
and I'm starting to worry about his
chances he chose the structure but I
don't like it for black yeah he shows in
it for the second time let's do it again
he's doing exactly the same thing he's
got a lot of decisions to make and from
that perspective I think alirez is Play
It's just much easier whether or not
he's better that's a different story I
think he is probably slightly better but
for alireza he's got only one Pawn
breakthrough D4 he can play H3 which I
think is very likely just to force black
to give up the bishop pair and that's
exactly what happens Bishop G7 is
obviously going to be met with D4 From
dividend's perspective he's got to
decide when to play F6 he's got to
decide maybe whether to play D4 himself
and try to isolate that E5 Pawn but he
has more decisions to make and that's
not necessarily a good thing in Rapid
game is often a bad thing
yeah the D4 push for black it can be
good to go up to the E5 Pawn but it can
backfire because only one side has a
light Square Bishop Black's Pawn
structure from F7 through D5 and the G6
H7 pawns all on light squares so that
Bishop on now on F1 where is it going
what's its useful diagonal it's waiting
for light squares to be opened up and
then it will try to see the light of day
indeed H6 very flexible move have you
been improving his position I like the
way that Black's pieces are coordinated
here he's active he's got a lot of space
but he is down two minutes on the clock
so will the time play a big role in this
game that obviously remains to be seen
as they enter the middle game phase and
I think that affords us a good
opportunity to take a look at some of
the other games uh that we have underway
we've got mussar against Dimitri kolars
and chefchenko shimanov
which of these shall we hop into now
maybe the mustard game yeah that one
looks really interesting because in that
matchup we see a black queen on D5 but
also this Knight on F4 and that can be
scary for white that's why the white
Bishop is on F1 Donna I like Black's
initiative here I like the way that
Black's pieces are situated but there is
tension between the knights on E5 and G6
and also you're often advised not to
blockade a pawn with a queen why is that
you might think well the Queen's the
strongest piece but that also makes it
the most vulnerable piece and the
easiest one to attack and I think a big
reason why Black's block k9d5 is
unreliable is the possibility of Bishop
to C4 which Not only would knock the
queen out of D5 but it would orchestrate
serious pressure on the F7 Pawn you
could easily see white taking charge
with a subsequent Queen to B3 and all
ours wants none of that he brings his
Queen back on his own volition in order
to generate a Tempo that he can use to
contest the bishop with something like
Bishop E6 although he also have to be
very careful not to drop a piece in the
center with like a well-timed knight
takes G6 as you were indicating
it's true there is some tension in this
position I liked your point about Bishop
comedy E6 for black that Bishop would
like to be on D5 you don't want to
blockade a pawn an isolated Pawn with a
queen you'd rather do it with a piece a
knight ideally but a bishop is not that
much worse so colors he takes a sip of
his water Donna we know what that means
he must be happy about his position
yeah but I I wouldn't be all that
thrilled if I was him because Bishop C4
on the board Queen B3 is coming and this
is what I was mentioning earlier Bishop
E6 here at the very least is gonna lose
a pawn to Bishop takes E6 Knight takes
C6 and at the end the pawn is whatever
Pawn or piece appears on E6 is going to
hang and that is one of the big
drawbacks of pushing H6 early you're
weakening your control over the G6
square and by extension you're gonna
have a harder time contesting why it's
control over this diagonal so water or
not all right black has to be very very
careful here
does indeed in another position another
game where both players need to be
careful is the one between shimanov and
chefchenko then I just looked at that
position of the corner of my eye and I
have no idea what opening it came from I
don't know how the players got there but
it looks like a very weird position
it's like the Somerton man you don't
know anything about it you don't know
how he washed up there what opening it
is what evaluation it is let's go to
that game I'm gonna click on
here this was and no wasn't an album so
it was a trumpowski Believe It or Not
White's Bishop is nowhere to be found
White's dark squid Bishop that landed on
G5 on the second move now what's the
material count that I can do around I
think I can count the Panzer but I'm
still not sure okay materials are equal
like black has these double I said bee
pawns this Pawn on F4 uh White is
missing a dark Square Bishop but the
evaluation bar only slightly in Black's
favor I think if we isolated the you
know Concepts we're talking about here
black should be better but maybe it's
Box Pawn structure I know you say it
tends to be overrated isolated B POS
isolated d-pawn and tension between G3
and F4 perhaps that's what keeps white
in the balance here
yeah and I mean
once the F warp on disappears white
could open things up with E4 get this
bishop out get the Knight out so as as
visually unappealing as White's kingside
looks black has the more persistent
weaknesses and the more static problems
with the I with the Double B pawns the
isolated d-pawn and it's not like
Black's development is all peaches and
cherries either you've got that Bishop
on C8 which was currently buried behind
the rubble and if you ever played D6
you're gonna have to potentially reckon
with uh b2b4 and sochenko doing
everything he can to maximize the
activity of his pieces that is a
gorgeous looking move
these moves are really difficult to
predict Rook A4 he does hit that night
on D4 a second time so white does not
have time to play the move G takes F4 or
to develop pieces and B3 you're pointing
B4 uh B4 could hit that Bishop on C5 B3
it does create some weaknesses on the
queen side of the Rook can slide up to
A3 at any point I feel like actually
Bishop takes D4 is available after B3 as
well because of tactics I'm worried
about shimano's chances yeah if you play
B3 before before and black can take on
D4 before and then take on C3 after B4
um Knight C2 white avoids it with a 10
foot pole moving the Knight back to
relative safety but opening up the
diagonal for white I really do like this
move though again a big problem consists
in the unstability the instability of
the F4 Pawn if it is captured then white
can finally get this bishop out of the
gates with E4 maybe it's worth for black
to consider the move G5 to keep this
Pawn entrenched and keep the epon
paralyzed
big question I mean that's G5 a hard
move to play with Queens on the board
but even without Queens on the board
that can backfire because pawns cannot
move backwards and if you push up the G5
you leave some squares behind so this
one is interesting all the games at this
point are interesting because the
matches are fantastic no matter who
selected their opponent we are left with
some great challenges ahead so done any
of the other Games catching your eye
well I think we can go back quickly to
the farugia Anton giharo game because
we're getting a lot more clarity in the
type of Pawn structure so I'm gonna
swing back to that game what we're also
getting Clarity on is that David is in
fact paying the price or his time
management early in the game he's
already down to four minutes they've
barely entered the middle game and black
is experiencing major problems with the
dark squares on F6 and on D6 do not let
white get a knight to F6 especially if
you're planning to Castle kingside do
you think White's better or am I over
optimistic here
white definitely is better and something
we mentioned earlier if black pushed D4
and that's exactly what happened that
light Square Bishop for white it has a
diagonal to work with the bishop can go
right out to G2 hit the Queen the B7
Pawn behind it and it's a happy piece so
I feel like black can't really attack
anything of whites the E5 Pawn is extra
well defended and if you take on C1 and
get into opposite colored Bishops that
doesn't help either your Bishop on G7 is
very bad wow so David trying to engineer
some counter play knocking the night off
of C4 alireza says first of all let me
feed and Kettle my Bishop hit the queen
and then he can very calmly drop the
Knight back to D2 that might be where it
wants to be anyway if it eventually
wants to access the F6 Square
now this looks very problematic for
black because if the knights get traded
on D2 then the bishop slides out to B4
in the future takes control of some big
diagonals and if you take the bishop on
C1 a rook just gets to the open C file
and white is active before black is able
to even Castle so I don't like this
position for David I don't like his
clock Mansion either nope and the
stubbornness right he repeated the same
Karo Khan line against alireza's Knight
F3 and D3
doesn't mean that he wasn't okay to
begin with but it does mean that he just
doesn't feel comfortable in this
particular structure and right now I
would not play B4 if I'm Ali Reza
because that would give black access to
a major hole that white would create on
C3 instead what I would actually do is
go Knight F3 and then maybe swing the
Knight around to G4 because that is an
alternate airport that you could fly
through if you want to reshoff six
that is really beautiful rerouting of
pieces and he goes Knight F3 so step one
and he does not want to go B4 I know
some people want to attack a knight if
you played Pawn to B4 then Knight goes
to A4 into C3 that is not a good move
we're talking about it pawns
overextending pawns can't move backwards
this would be a great example of that it
absolutely would and Knight H2 is not
mandatory you could start with Bishop D2
that would be an alireza style now if he
likes to keep his options open and
particularly all top players like to
play on both sides of the board but I'm
gonna give myself a pat on the back
Knight H2 is on the board now how does
David play because if he goes H5 Robert
the medicine is worse than the disease
you're weakening G5 and you're making G3
G4 even stronger
all of this looks good and Knight G4
played Knight F6 check to get that dark
Square Bishop is available you don't
have to rush it if black doesn't play
the move H5 no I don't like this
position I see the eval bar saying
White's only slightly better I think if
you look at this from a practical point
of view that with under three minutes of
the clock with the less safe King White
having the pair of Bishops this is
really good winning chances for alireza
faruso so should we look at another game
Donna because we've been on this one it
looks good for fuja other games underway
Ollie Russ is going to keep pressing I'm
gonna go to the aronian on Dragon game
which is absolute Madness it is anarchy
pandemonium Chaos on the board of
honoronian as the white pieces and he
seems to be having all the fun in this
rematch from their no less crazy match
in the speed Chess Championship Lavon
just seems to have Dimitri's number thus
far in their affairs
yeah not his number because they're
besties calling each other all the time
this one looks like Dimitri might start
hating Levon if this result goes his way
uh this position is wide open for white
to go after Black's King white king is
very safe on G1 there's some tactics
here clearly a pond was captured on C4
and you could take back because the
queen on D2 is loose but so is the
bishop on E5 and what do you do here as
black because there's so many tactics
available to White this with the King
sitting on E8 the C5 Pawn will be loose
in many positions I don't like this one
bit I don't either and even if the best
case scenario happens and black gets a
chance to Castle Queen side which is
much more feasible than castling King's
side it's not like you're safe I mean
white is Queen A5 why does this bishop
on H2 which is lying in weight and can
set up potential mating threats by
controlling the B8 Square so I mean at
best Dimitri avoids losing a minor piece
right away and gets under an attack but
look at the speed look at the power he
sacks on E5 and there goes the Knight
into G6 it goes it will double back to
E5 and Fork the queen and Bishop I think
black is losing material and losing the
game
sick tactical vision from looking at
Dimitri yes like what is this w TF what
does this guy do to me they played in
the Swiss and it was completely one side
in the elephant Now The Rook on h8 is
under attack so you could save your
Bishop but you lose your Rook you save
your Rook You're Gonna Lose Your Bishop
Knight takes E5 and no matter where the
queen moves that Knight captures the
bishop on C4 and what does white have
okay you could get oh Checkmate thread I
see what you're doing there Donna the F2
Pawn will push forward to F4 that is
probably the move that is necessary
defending the Knight on G5 and the pawn
on G2
if I had to guess lavon's moon no Queen
E2 sadly relinquishes the defense of the
Knight on G5 with a maid threat so Levon
has to be careful here Knight H4 is
nothing to sneeze at threatens mate
threatens Knight F3 ideas and white
could easily lose one of his minor
pieces back
but do you see anything convincing yes
Knight takes C4 Knight H4 Pawn to F4
defending the Knight and defending the
checkmate at the same time what a
cold-blooded defensive move and that is
hard to see those lateral moves that set
up lateral defenses and defend against
two things at once Lavon is still
searching for it
yeah but I think he'll find it but he
wants to make sure that he doesn't lose
on the spot after these Knight H4 ideas
but after you see the move F4 it does
shut down your Bishop on H2 that's the
bad news but you'll have two minor
pieces for just the rook and as you said
before Black's King isn't exactly going
to be safe anytime soon no it most
certainly will not and Lavon investing
his time smartly right he's not just
blitzing out every move he's giving
himself the time that he needs to stop
on critical moments otherwise he plays
very quickly when he feels confident but
here he senses that this is the turning
point in the game if he finds the right
idea he might be able to win immediately
yeah so a big moment for Lavon aronian
if he plays Knight takes C4 I think he's
well on his way to Victory if he doesn't
that's when the tides turn and black
will be better if we count material real
quick black has a rook for just one
piece and so black is ahead in material
you need to capture this Knight Bishop
on C4 with your knight then play F4 to
protect your knight on G5 and stop the
Checkmate but the more he thinks Daniel
yeah exactly uh he plays it though he
found it he waited for us to say that he
played Knight take C4 was just double
triple checking the last thing you want
is to miss a check on F3 and lose your
queen now accuracy is still required
Robert black is very active as active as
he's probably going to be attacking D3
threatening Queen takes C4 I've seen
crazier things happen and we know how
tricky Dimitri and draken can be uh in
these complicated tactical positions
he's losing objectively but Lavon maybe
a cold-blooded move like Rook D1 is what
the doctor ordered here but then there
might be Knight takes she too and queen
takes C4
wow that's that's a sick tactic maybe
Knight to E5 just protect your D3 pawn
put your knight in a defended square and
the bishop on H2 is playing a role it's
defending the Knight on E5 through the
F4 Pawn so I think Knight E5 looks
simplest to my eyes but black will have
some play uh but Donya another game
that's catching my eye uh I know there's
a lot to juggle at this stage but the
game between Jordan Von forest and Anish
giri could not be going worse for the
Dutchman and in this case I'm talking
about the Dutchman with three names
that's Jordan Von Forest it looks really
bad for him
let's go to that game The Last move is
F5 F4 Anish Geary is slicing white up on
the king side and in the center and he's
got the uncontested bishop on B7 what on
Earth has happened it looks like Jordan
has been busy setting up his pieces for
the next game and I think if this
continues along the same Trend he is
going to be setting his pieces up for
the next game or or rather chess.com is
going to set them up for him
93. goodbye
and Bishop takes D4 F takes G through
anything wins yeah because what are you
gonna what are you gonna do take that
Knight energy for open up that bishop
and you probably get segmented I need
she's like biting his sweater here uh
but he doesn't really need to bite his
time he's up three minutes and he has
the attack so I think he can just punish
Jordan by even taking on g3 at this
moment
no no this there's Tic Tac if Knight G3
F takes G4 Rook takes F1 and Knight
takes you to check what a beautiful
pattern should I show that or do we wait
for him to reproduce it I I think you
got to show it just real quick showing
it Knight G3 FG Rook takes a fun
deflection Knight takes you to fork and
pin all rolled up in one the Knight on
D4 is pinovich and now after black takes
the queen black has a decisive material
advantage and follows up with a
checkmating attack against Black's gang
someone did their puzzle Rush this
morning and I hope Anish giri did his
puzzle rush along with Robert Hess
because this is the most convincing win
and what I've seen in these types of
situations if you think for too long
things can get complicated Anish though
choosing a different but no less
effective approach Queen D6 more
business-like just heading for the G3
pawn and white can simply resign
actually that's even better why get
fancy when you can be direct G3 is
falling and the white king is gonna tip
over this just leaves the Checkmate so
Anish giri his head maybe going off
screen he you know he's so focused
that's what the players do we end up
getting the forehead cam but nope he
heard me he's back up and he is ready to
take game one and that's bad news for
Jordan Von Forest beating any scare with
black good luck to you buddy we've seen
it we've seen on-demand wins for some
reason what stands out to me is Fabiana
carwana who I think defeated Alexi
serrana on demand from a losing position
with a black thesis so it's not
unprecedented these players have
expansive opening repertoires that allow
them to generate chances the problem is
as one wise man said Anish Gary is Anish
giri and he is rather hard to beat with
the black piece is on demand
okay I think this one's over it's safe
to say yeah let's go to a different game
this hurts to look at it does so there's
Lavon there's farugia let's quickly
check out ferrugia's position because
they are in a Time scramble I will also
point out Robert before I ask you to
deconstruct this position that zul musar
is very very close to defeating Dimitri
kolars there in an end game I think this
game though is a little bit more
interesting
yeah let's stay here I'll keep an eye on
that game if it continues to heat up but
this one uh what is going on white has
this Knight on G5 Bishop on G4 the black
king not being hunted just yet and B2
was taken and The Rook comes back to C2
so I feel like
Krill excuse me I was looking at the
chef chicken gave to the side David on
Todd here just puts his Queen and rook
in contact with one another and maybe
their ideas with Rook C1 later try to
trade off some of the white aggressors
but this is just a position where it's
super tense I would be terrified but H5
might run into the subtle Queen to d8
and that pin against the G5 Knight it
might not be that strong while the
Knight is defended but if you ever want
to open up the king side you're going to
have to reckon with the consequences and
the time situation is starting to
equalize this is absolutely anybody's
game as alireza drives this Rook into D6
and the queen infiltrates to C3 and
attacks the rook and E1 but now the
Knight is hanging
yeah but the rook's hanging and if the
Rook moves off the e-file down goes the
E5 pawn and that could be just what is
necessary rookie three that may be the
option but leaving your first rank
allowing a rook to C1 and a queen to A1
but you can see black go after the white
kid gosh everybody's mating everybody
there's also sacrifices on E6 and on F7
that are not out of the question
especially with Black's heavy Pieces
away from the defense of the king and so
Anton tries to eliminate whites
attackers he's definitely in charge now
but can he convert this into a win and
stay afloat on the clock
with Bishop E6 is a deadly threat and
the Knight is five oh no this looks
really dangerous for black what do you
do here Bishop takes G5 was impulsive I
understand why he did it but it had the
opposite effect and yet it's not over
there goes the night Knight takes D3 is
a huge threat both sides are going after
each other's King
I like Bishop E2 though it saves
everything it protects everything H5
Knight D2 check doesn't scare you H5
Knight D2 King G2 and you would even
potentially be happy to give away the
Rook honey one and he takes E6
is it a perpetual
it is he's I don't think he's getting
more than that Queen H6 back to G6
you can take the pawn on E6 but I would
not flirt with that with one second left
he does Rook F7 my goodness Rook F7 then
there's queenies there's no more checks
still perpetual
yeah oh just a draw
uh that was a topsy-turvy battle there
down the stretch and that is a draw
Grace let's go to our other games good
result for David Antoni draws of the
black pieces he gets white in game two
oh my gosh we gotta go to the Lavon game
where Dimitri on draken is trying to
engineer some counter play and is
failing levana's gonna win this game
yeah what is lavono he's up at peace
right now and if the Knight takes the
Rook well you could just take back with
your knight and what is white up two
minor pieces for Rook plus some past
pawns Lavon is in charge and Dimitri
kolars found a great defensive idea to
save that end game against juul massar
their first game with Landon to draw as
well
and we gotta go to the shifchenko game
which
is pretty crazy I think it's a draw but
it's not going to be Elementary
wait a second isn't white up a piece for
just a pawn so I don't care what the
engine says this looks like white can
win this unless the Rooks get traded the
Rooks are off the board immediately a
draw Bishop A6 here keep the pieces on
the board
it is important what you just pointed
out bishop and Knight against Bishop is
a drop by definition it's a textbook
draw so white has to keep the Rooks on
the board and actually try to attack
Black's king that's quite a few pieces
you got there I would go all in with an
eventual 95.
white is winning this game I know the
evaluation Bar says it's level but it's
not level practically speaking in time
trouble a few seconds left for black
that King is in huge trouble and you see
the eval bar going up in White's favor
there's Force Galore everywhere there's
Checkmate threats there's checks
everywhere you want them and he's
delivering them and Knight can come into
C6 can go back to D3 White's got 50
moves though assuming that black doesn't
move his Pawn
and if you move the pawn I'll take it
and start the 50 move all over again
Knight danger to C5 looks scary and
that's why he plays D3
Rook H4 King T5 Rook D4 King C5 Rook E5
is a last ditch attempt but of course
with the increment white should be able
to mate
and look at this Knight D5 check wins a
piece but you lose the bishop on C4 at
the end so Knight D5 where's the king
going Rook A6 now Alliance he's going to
the king side I feel like white should
win this game in time in Black's time
absolutely and now the eval bar is
creeping up I think King E5 runs into
Bishop C7 check using the PIN
so white has to be a little bit more
subtle than that
okay Rook G5 offering a rook trade okay
King B7
black is saved
Knight d5's Rook G4 check hanging in
there five and then you've got Bishop A6
you just don't quite have the Firepower
to deliver the final blow and so he
tries to reshuffle again
King going over to B4 to protect the
bishop so the Knight is free to move
King B3 now oh Knight E4 all right
okay now maybe a check on C6 the forest
blacks King to decide but the king can
slide over to C7 and now Black's got
these back ring checks that are gonna
Force whites King away from its optimal
Square
super annoying tenacious defense
but the bishop is retreating you don't
want to keep bring your pieces about
Knight C3 Bishop A5 check is important
this idea of deflecting one of white
spaces and reducing to a rook and Bishop
versus Rook would make Black's defensive
task easier although still very very
difficult one second now as he tries to
Rook trade shimanov says no thank you
for real
oh my gosh King needs to get up the
board here you need to get the white
king forward but the bishop A4 Rook D4
check watch out for these checks here
Rook C7 check with every move he inches
closer to the 50 move roll they've
already probably made something like 30
moves and he skewers the pieces forcing
the king back and Carill does he even
have a way of Defending uh Alexander
does he have a way of Defending his
Knight or Bishop I don't think so
we'll watch out for Knight D5 at some
moment as well so there are so many
options here is there like a knight D5
King C6 threading Checkmate oh my God
what an idea but then maybe King slides
over to E8
and you win the game and then you don't
take the Rook you actually win The Rook
with Rook G6 because rook and Bishop
Rook vs Bishop is a draw but this is
only part of it he saved his piece
congrats but he hasn't made any progress
with that extra piece where he ate
rookie rookie eight you missed it oh but
he found a save
oh my God rookie 8 was winning a piece
yeah he had to start with rookie eight
and still though this has good winning
chance for white I don't know what move
number uh they have to reach to make a
draw but they're already a move 107.
yeah it's I think it's already been over
30 moves I think now
black is very likely to make a draw
because white has made backward progress
Robert the king is now on its best
Square it's been in about 30 moves
But Here Comes the white king to E4 Rook
F3 check is a huge threat move the
bishop away
as well and Knight B5 and Knight C6 one
second for shermanov
and the King will step away with the
check then you have to move the bishop
he is walking on hot coals right now
Rook F7 King D5 this has to be a mating
net but we're knocking on the door of
the 50 move rule which is Gonna Come
First
wow what defense rookie seven com Bishop
G1 with one second he's played Bishop A5
he is just praying right now for a 50
movable to be reached
C7 check
and now it's a draw again
he's a hero they're reaching move 50.
it's about to be a draw on Black's move
White's gonna make a move and then it's
a draw because the 50 move Roll But
Donya it actually looks like this final
position is almost winning for white the
black king on the back rank but amazing
Resources by karil shepshenko the now
player from Romania he's from the
Ukraine what in oh my gosh what a
defense unbelievable Save By by
shifchenko he couldn't believe that he
held it shimanov doesn't quite make it
happen he's gonna have to do it with the
black pieces in the second game as we
review the results from game one a
pretty peaceful round overall as David
on tone I thought he had a good save
against firushu because I was confident
that he was going to lose that position
down like three minutes on the corner
it seemed like the situation was Dire
but he held on three draws in these
matches but the next two they were not
so friendly we did see Anish giri take
down Jordan Von forest and we saw
levonne aronian beats Dimitri on draken
so the super Grand Masters they were
able to score some victories will on
draken now with the white pieces be able
to take game two and for Jordan Von
Force he is black in game two I think
that this task may be too much to ask
from him wow that even Rhymes and then
Forest he's gonna have to play something
that unbalances the game Anish he seems
to know everything every opening under
the side I'm expecting something like a
London from a niche something solid for
Jordan you you don't want to try to do
it in the first 10 moves right you want
to try to drag this game out same with
Dimitri on Drake and the way that you
win on demand you drag the game out you
get an unbalanced position and at some
point you just have to pray for a
mistake at some point the luck has to be
on your side
yeah you can't just force a win because
you want one your opponent needs to make
a mistake at the highest level there are
many draws in chess games but the
players do have their chances I think
Jordan Fun Forest he's as creative as
they come so he may have some opening
idea up his sleeve to make the situation
interesting but of course the niche
Geary heavy favorite at this point if he
can trade the pieces off and make a draw
he'll do just that and make his way to
division one of the chest kid cup and we
had a couple of other saves in the games
that we didn't devote as much attention
to we had and Dimitri callers who found
an incredible incredible inventive save
and he now sits half a point to half a
point
and I think the games are about to begin
yeah I'll erase this game I believe is
underway against David Anton so we can
get to the second game there we go their
match and they've made a bunch of moves
that have been seen before this is
familiar territory in the match between
farrugia and Anton uh farouza and he has
the black pieces in game two so Debbie
nuts on he like to rely on the white
pieces opposite colored Bishops where we
enter this position done yet but that
may be good for the attacking side it is
indeed and with uh employing the Petrov
that indicates to me that farusha
doesn't mind an Armageddon but he knows
that David Antone isn't just gonna try
to force a draw he knows that David
Antone is going to step on the gas pedal
and try his best to generate a win with
the white pieces obviously a 1-1 tie
results in an Armageddon we will cross
that bridge if we get there I think we
are likely to get there in at least one
of our matches this is an opposite
colored Bishop position it cannot be
stated enough Robert that in a middle
game it's a completely different kettle
of fish than it would be if you swap the
Queens
yeah but can at least be a kettle of
goldfish because I'm hungry I would like
to a snack sounds amazing right now it
doesn't white would like to snack on the
F7 Pawn the bishop on B3 is aiming
across the line and if you could
successfully get your knight to G5 is
white that will be very dangerous for
black and the bishop on D6 on the other
side it's biting on granite as you like
to say
yeah and G6 is a risky risky move do not
play H5 here that would be a very common
blunder a very instructive blunder
allowing Queen takes G6 you know who's
not gonna play H5
um initials AF all the rest of fashion
all right
you know AF stands for Abercrombie and
Fitch so don't get into this
conversation you might be sued but yeah
here uh faruja just he's sees King G2
he's doing well on the clock with David
Anton's doing even better nine and a
half minutes for him yeah I like how we
had King G2 and King G7 so a little
peace treaty signed by the players all
right let's take a couple Tempe to
improve our position and now white has
to figure out a way to keep the pressure
on the F7 Pawn up he can go Knight G5
the Knight can also maneuver to the
other side of the board and we also
could get a lot of action along the
e-file potentially leading to a trade of
Rooks if all four Rooks are traded I
think that we're likely to see a draw
so will we get an armor getting in this
match well not too early to tell
Donna we have to go the game between
Chef Chaco and Shimano there was a huge
mistake just played by well not by both
players but if you just go back a few
turns in this game Bishop takes E7 was a
mistake but after F5 e takes F6 was a
huge mistake because after Queen F4 oh
my gosh we'd see one check was missed
was missed by Alexander shimanov
this is chest and take B2 and it's
basically over you just win a thousand
pawns white has to go Knight beat into
and give another one up and then another
one up
and that's essentially resignable Robert
this is unbelievable
yeah I think he made a believed his
opponent or played a little bit too
quickly there but now white can Castle
kick side and black is better that's the
good news for shimanov but he could have
been better and up two pawns now it's
equal material with an edge for black on
Passat was an unthinkable movement Karel
shiv shank is gonna have to pull a
little bit more magic out of the Hat he
saves game one white pieces in game two
and he's worse just 10 moves in could
have been dead lost though so he's gonna
consider himself lucky I wonder if one
or both players are aware a Quincy one
was missed if you're Alexander shimanov
ignorance is bliss while you play the
game because if you're aware of a missed
opportunity like that psychologically
we've all been there right it's almost
impossible to focus on the course of
events because you're constantly mulling
it over and over and over in your head I
could have just played this move and I
would have been winning
yeah now here's a big thing to mull over
is E5 for black you want to get those
pawns rolling but your king is still in
the center so if you play E5 white plays
Bishop B5 and you need to be certain
that pushing those pawns is a good idea
because the king remains just to you
know kind of talk about it the F Pawn is
missing for black so at some point Queen
H5 check would be available I would be
scared to play E5 as black I'd probably
just Castle
I would Castle as well do the things you
have to do first tie your shoes cross
your t's dot your eyes and then figure
out if you want to play E5 doing it
immediately might result in some sort of
sack such as Knight bd2 E4 Knight 64
which is pretty standard in a lot of
these positions where Black's King ends
up getting stuck and caught under the
crossfire of White's e-file attack
yeah this is one of those situations
where sacrificing a piece the Dynamics
could allow white to gain the upper hand
because Black's King may not have true
safety and shimanov he's spending his
time here I should have spent it a move
or two ago with Queen C1 check but I
think that chefchenko for now the worst
is behind him that was an oversight
mutually they both missed it but I think
that black Still Remains better with the
bishop pair so Donna is there another
game you want to venture to maybe some
interesting action on other boards well
there's interesting action on the boards
where a player has to score a must win
uh there are two of those boards one of
them is the one I just pulled up giri
against van Forest Jordan has the
tougher end of the stick as compared to
Dimitri because he's got the white
pieces and he's doing exactly what most
players do when they need to win they
play the Sicilian Defense Yuri responded
to the rosalimo and we are gonna get
some early tactics here who do they
favor
uh This is complicated and that's all
you can ask for if you are Jordan fund
Forest you hope that you know a bit of
fresh air did him well in between games
and speaking of fresh air Daniel what's
the air like over by you you got one of
those air things devices and it's right
next to me I'm glad you asked air
quality is good I checked yesterday
my radon count is am I even allowed to
share that 0.7
my PM is two but it said the air quality
was good yesterday so I'm happy
foreign my PM is 428 down here because
that's the time in New York City but for
each Geary air quality is good in that
situation even better because he has a
one point lead in this position the Eva
Bar says better for white but the type
of position that Jordan needs he needs
chaos and he has a pair of Bishops all
the pawns remain on the board All Things
Considered this is the best chance that
Jordan will get the problem is creating
chaos is not the final step it's the
first one right just because you create
Chaos on the board means absolutely
nothing in each Gary how many times has
he handled these tense positions with
total Perfection right and for Jordan
you've got to celebrate what you've
gotten thus far you've gotten exactly
the kind of position you want the
problem is I think he's slightly worse I
think he has the shorter end of the
stick here largely because why does this
idea of playing A3 and really
accentuating the awkwardness of Black's
Queen right also has more space in the
center but obviously the light squares
are where white suffers and if black can
deploy the bishop to B7 and force white
to make a concession in the center then
then we're talking
yeah and we've seen some feature chats
in the Dutch heavyweights these two
players number one and number two from
the Netherlands and he's curated the
winner of 2023 Tata steel and Jordan
Forest the reason that any skier did not
have a previous title because Jordan won
the 2021 tons of steel Chess Masters so
this position I really think it's all
you could ask for for Jordan van forest
and now he has two Bishops against two
knights now I'm starting to flat out
like his position he probably is
considering Pawn takes F6 in order to
open up that g file but I really don't
see a compelling downside the bishop
takes F6 Anish might be banking on E5
just blasting the center open and Paving
the way for 94 in fact I'm quite
confident that he wants to play E5
either before or after Pawn takes C6 but
if blackened find a way to tuck his King
away to safety Robert we might be
talking about Jordan having an advantage
here and a referees of his win against
the Medusa tsarov in the final round of
Tata Steel
wow that would not be good for a niche
coming into this game all he needs to
draw and sometimes the best way to play
for a jaw is your normal chest I don't
think his position is bad right now he's
attacking the bishop on F6 the loose
Pawn on C5 there will be tactics in the
center of the board Black's King sits
there but I think that so far Jordan is
doing a good job so while Anish and
Jordan they think about what to do next
why don't we hop to one of the other
games well let's take a look at the
other must win situation between Dimitri
and draken Dima with the white pieces
against levonne aronian who has been
playing with such Supreme confidence all
throughout the Swiss stage and now
throughout the knockout stage Queen to
A5 is the last move this is a rogozin
and I'm sorry to say for Dimitri and
draken fans
I don't see him winning this game I'm
gonna
put it directly
not the type of game you want in must
win situation we're just looking at
Jordan Von forest and his crazy game
there was chaos across the board and we
have an entirely symmetrical structure
where D5 is defended and D4 isn't the
ninth can take on on C6 but you're
trading more pieces and heading into the
end game so Bishop G5 probably a good
idea from White trying to take mf6 and
take on D5
oh man look at how quickly he's playing
D5 isn't even loose because it's the
knight at C3 is pinned I appreciate your
discussion of the position but let me
ask you the more important question
between lavon's snazzy purple shirt and
yours ooze would you rather wear to a
part
we asked the chess.com chat what does
Hess say
look look at the featured chat there
where did I buy that shirt uh that's for
Wandering Minds to not know the answer
to and look at actually that is a snazzy
shirt from
I love that I want that I'm gonna ask
him to message him afterwards I'll hit
him up on WhatsApp and say Lavon come on
I'll send you mine uh I'll buy one for
you and you can buy one of those for me
dude that Violet is a really underrated
color I think that particular shade of
blue or purple or whatever you want to
call it that is one of the most
beautiful colors out there and right now
LeBron is playing with beautiful speed
and beautiful confidence and he should
not lose this game his Knight is on e4
he is compelling white to either trade
and basically relinquish all winning
chances or give up the C3 Pawn either
way Robert do you see any chances here
redema
Dima has to give up the C3 Pawn if he
takes the Knight on e4 opposite colored
Bishops that game would just be a draw
so at least here after Knight takes C3
you play F3 you do have a four on three
Advantage from the e to the H file so
you need to count your pluses in the
position and that's what's going well
for white so I could see a future
somewhere down the line where Dima gets
him when he turns if it gets his pawns
rolling but for now levada has done
everything perfectly including choosing
his attire for the match yeah and he has
been playing perfectly if he draws this
game he advances to the finals of uh the
chess kid cup which will be held toward
the end of May Be commentating it from
Oslo Knight takes C3 F3 is on the board
Dimitri trying to cash in is kingside
Pawn majority but he is Living on a
Prayer at this point
yeah this is not looking good for Dima
but if anyone can squeeze out a victory
from an end game where you have the
bishop pair it is Dimitri on draken he
is one the second most title Tuesdays
behind Hikaru Nakamura he's been a
Mainstay in all the rapid events on
chess.com and we know how capable he is
and he also did well in the fide Grand
Prix event that happened before the
candidate so yeah he plays all type
controls well but levonne Ronin has come
to play today which has not been too fun
for on Drake and he has already been on
drinking twice and this doesn't look
like the win that on Drake it needs
let's go elsewhere Dania we can't come
back to this game if it gets a little
bit more interesting but what other
games oh you're answering it before I
could finish
as always we're on the same page I'm
gonna flip on callers against bustard
which is the only game we haven't looked
at yet this round I will update
everybody uh as to the fact that uh
Antonio and eloreza ferruja are I would
give it a 95 likelihood that game will
end in a draw which means we will have
our first Armageddon after all of the
games are concluded once that result
comes in we'll update you but it's an
opposite colored Bishop end game we've
got a lot of opposite colored Bishops I
feel like we've had them a lot in the
Swiss portion now we have them a lot in
the playoff portion White's got all of
the control he could possibly ask for
this is a night off gun really wrong for
Jewel
and I don't really understand what
you're saying because you said Bishops
of opposite color but I only see white
having a bishop that piece on E7
you're being very generous and calling
that a bishop but there is a few things
structurally speaking that are important
to note the D6 Pawn is well defended by
that bad Bishop if you play A4 as black
that would be a huge strategic mistake
you need to have B4 as an availability
to you because otherwise white will then
pick those Queen side pawns up later so
Rook f8 I think this is a good idea I
understand the eval bar is saying
White's position is overwhelming I think
Rook D5 as a response go after this
loose Pawn it may sound far-fetched but
sometimes because white has the onus of
actually converting it can be hard to be
white in this position especially with
low time Rook D5 great call if you can
impel black to play F4 uh before B4 then
white could take with CB and establish
it past Pawn with A4 now he's got Queen
E2 and he's going after that pawn windy
seven would have won a pawn
oh Queen D7 is winning on the spot
yeah sometimes you can go your own way
but the right way was D7 back to E2 yo
in your own Camp white is better for
sure but this move was probably missed
by Dimitri colors here you can't take on
B5 as your Rook on D2 would be loose
indeed and he goes back to G4 he might
have seen the idea of Queen D7 he's
pulling a shimanov except he is gonna
see it this time and there he goes Jewel
musard that might have just been the
decisive blow
game over Queen D7 wins B5 it probably
wins more than that if your Rook takes
on B5 it goes to B7 and you're going to
Checkmate the black king in the corner
the bishop on B3 stares through all of
those squares stopping a rook F7 or a
rook G8 no Daniel this is game over and
Dimitri kolars looks like he's ready to
play in D1 and he's gonna play Super
Grand Masters but do not underestimate
this player for the Berlin Bears he's
played the protest League he's played
for the German Olympia team he is a
tough opponent he's an amazing player
and he's an experienced Blitz player so
I don't think anybody's looking and say
oh Dimitri callers that's basically a
free point nobody thinks like that we
know too well how good these lower rated
players can be how hungry they are when
they finally get an opportunity to face
the Top Gun it's going to be an
interesting one but we have some
interesting games still remaining we've
got farugia and gihara they've
officially drawn their game so they are
at 1-1 and they will move on to an
Armageddon
won his second game I think Jordan Von
Forest going all in he said let's go
with Reckless abandon and he did lose
that game so anishkiri makes his way
through to division one and will curiel
shivchenko join him who saves the first
game gets out into a much worse position
in the second game could have been
losing in one move now he's up a pawn
and he's the only one who seems to have
any winning chances but Alexander
shimanov saying I've got that Apon I'm
gonna bring it down to A3 and I'm going
to try to pick off the A2 Pawn while I
still have a chance
yeah it's a good idea you need activity
the bishop on F6 is a great piece
because at some point you can put your
Pawn on A3 and then even put your Bishop
on B2 where it defends your a pawn and
protects the G7 Pawn so I think that the
wind will be very difficult but at some
point for white H4 G5 just don't do that
too soon because the black might come up
to C4 and cause you some problems indeed
and white has to be careful because if
you accidentally allow The Rook to get
to C2 then Black's pawn and A3 is going
to be two steps away from promotion so
as tempting as it is to play H4 G5 why
does the balance attack in defense and
another big problem Robert is that it's
very hard to actually get to that G7
Pawn even if you're able to play G5 move
A3 actually establishes a stronghold for
black on B2 but shimanov is taking this
in another Direction he is trying to
stop G5 all together using some tactics
Bishop takes H4 check anybody oh the
Knight can't take and if the king takes
you lose the Knight F3
and there's some really crazy mating
Nets especially if Flex Rook moves up to
A6 and cuts off the king's Escape
you gotta be a little bit careful here
I've seen crazier things happen
is found just it's an equalizing move on
the spot and if you are crucial right
now you play Rook d8 trade off the Rooks
and just make a draw I think that well
actually you're kicking so much trouble
seven
I I take it back you get mated Rogue d8
you can immediately play King H7 you
don't even have to take on d8
oh my gosh what a brave move what about
Rook A6
Rook A6 threatens G5 Rook H3 mate there
we go G5 for white
G5 for white might be forced and then
I'll play Rook G6 and I'll scare the
living crap out of you even if you'll
hold the draw there which you probably
will
yeah but that does look very scary so I
don't like what's happened here but I
think that white is running out of
choices
wow
this is nerve-wracking who wasn't
expecting to be in the defensive
situation here he was in the driver's
seat two seconds ago now he's about to
get checkmated if he's not careful and I
think he is careful that is an excellent
cold-blooded defensive move covering the
H3 Square
yeah G5 check King H5 there are no more
squares available for the white king but
the black Rook doesn't get to H3 in time
and that's one of those checks that you
probably shouldn't include because with
the white king going to H5 it will be
used as a weapon in some positions as
the black king will have to say in the
first two ranks so I think that it's a
great play by chefchenko there uh he may
have been better up a pawn before but
that is the thing of the past just make
the draw send this match to Armageddon
bidding we've got a couple of big
results and big near results Dimitri
callers continuing to convert his
position against your mustard but Levon
aronian is about to emerge and punch his
ticket to one of these five remaining
spots Robert because Dimitri and Drake
and now officially has virtually no
winning chances
yeah levada ronian he made it to the
chesso Masters division one pipe taking
part in the Swiss and then winning his
match and then you see him here he can
be borderline Unstoppable when he is in
his best shape and opposite color
Bishops in a rook in Bishop ending just
three pawns per side unless you blunder
Checkmate and I don't even know how that
happens you win a match it almost feels
like he has concluded every one of his
games in the Swiss portion and now this
portion with over three minutes on his
clock which is crazy
yeah no he's a beast and he almost made
it through so he wouldn't even have to
play in this play and had he taken down
Magnus Carlson but he beat Wesley so in
the chessful Masters he had some great
games there uh but for Dimitri on Drake
and he would have liked to be in
division one for the first time not
happening not today says Lavon aronian
but he is going to end up in division
two and he will contend for very serious
prizes so Dimitri can hold his head up
high of honoronian like you're pointing
out when he's in good form
I mean I think there's a similar effect
from playing mvl who also plays very
very fast when he's confident he's
making good moves
man it's a nightmare pairing
yeah I realized I misspoke he actually
lost to Wesley so but he beat Federal
Sav and artemiev so he had some really
good results in the losers bracket
before and eventually losing two Magnus
so uh we see in this position he has no
risk at any of the other two games a
little more exciting or is this where we
have to stay I think we should go to the
kolars game and watch him finish it off
against Jewel moussard now finishing off
he still has to because he's got right
about a minute and we have seen pull off
some crazy comebacks he's still trying
but he's down so many pawns and all of
them are passed and I think the simple
B4 might just end the game in this
position
why not I mean look at this black would
hope to take a few pawns but white
doesn't need many pawns remaining you
just need one Pawn to become a queen and
B4 was played nice spot by you and nice
spot by kolars yeah and he doesn't even
have to rush he doesn't have to sack The
Exchange he can just play King to B3 on
the next move and take as long as he
desires because anytime black approaches
upon with game G4 white could just send
the king away if he so desires with
Bishop E6 Jack now this is this is just
too one-sided
yeah no this is
a game that white was dominating from
the start black had a very bad dark
Square Bishop it's nice to call it a
bishop to begin with it is a good Bishop
now but look at how many extra pawns
white has and no risk that Bishop can be
captured so that's it how about the
subtle A7 may I propose
what's your threat I'm missing something
Rook C5 or meeting you on A5 now a queen
also guards that swear
threat
Rook G6 Bishop E6 oh beautiful what a
mating construction that Rook on F2
doing what shimanov's Rook on A6 was
doing
and look at colors you see that that was
relief but also Jubilation at the stress
of these chess games have been getting
to him but now he makes his way through
to division one we will have a player in
the 2600s in division one of the chess
kid cup
incredible what a performance by the
young German Grandmaster he holds his
composure he defeats juul moussard who
had an excellent Swiss portion and will
try to avenge his loss in division two
speaking of avenging a loss
so will Dimitri on draken because his
winning chances have gone from zero to
negative
yeah he could lose this game but credits
him in some sense because in order to
make it through you need to win and a
loss and a draw are equivalent for
Dimitri and Drake and Rook G4 is a good
idea as you're pointing out just do not
hang any pawns and you'll be able to
take this draw and take on E5 now with
his right yeah I mean
at this point I think Dimitri it's time
to offer a draw
and King E6 so this is a draw for
essentially yep and white is not losing
this is in fact a draw
but he is losing the mini-match
okay let's see when the players are in
G5 forcing the trade of Pawns Lavon very
clinical
yeah just F4 check Bishop takes F4
that's when the game will end
it does end exactly like that and big
congrats to Levon aronian who is in to
the chess kid Cup finals
yeah credit to him he played a great day
of Chess and so in the first three
matches otherwise could not get by David
Anton nor could shevchenko or Shimano
they will be going to Armageddon they'll
have to bid on their time but Dimitri
kolars he beats ju moussard it was nine
versus two so that means musar picked
kolars he probably wants to take that
one back
he most certainly does and uh Dimitri
Kolar is showing himself capable of
competing with the strongest players in
this tournament in the world and
Alexander shimanov and real shivchenko
they had a very evenly matched Affair
except Alexander shimanov is going to be
kicking himself he had that win in game
one he fails but he saves game two
and uh to armageddon's Robert what more
could we ask for well for the other
players who were in the competition to
get into division one they're happy that
they don't have armagedds Anish Gary
sweeps yordavan Forest two games to none
that was a demolition and levada ronian
put on a clinic against Dimitri on
draken he won game one he drew game two
with black without too much difficulties
so levonne aronian Anish Geary they will
be in division one of the chess kid cup
I think that Hikaru Fabiano and
nordierbeck they're not exactly thrilled
that those two will be joining the mix
especially given the form that both of
them displayed and what's amazing is
that anishiri lost the second game of
the Swiss to pee and Eon in
heartbreaking fashion uh with the white
pieces and he came back he lost another
game a little bit later but this is what
the top players do they're not always
smooth they're not always consistent but
they always get back on their feet and
when things really matter and when push
comes to shove that's when they bring
out their best chess and that is what
anishagiri did today that's what he's
gonna have to do at the end of May
well four players are still taking part
here they will have to play in
Armageddon so they are going to bid on
their times we will take a break but
when returned we'll know who gets white
and who gets black withdrawals in those
two matches stay tuned we'll be right
back
[Music]
we first thought that we had experienced
the chest boom that had washed Over Us
in 2019 at the end of 2018 kind of going
into 2019 we kind of looked at ah well
that was guys that was the chess boom
and oh we're a new level
it was kind of then but then like
literally like covet happened we were
ramping up
so quickly in each country that locked
down Italy India you could see the
registrations flying through as each
country locked down and it was all
happening so fast there was no like oh
this is so cool this was like oh my gosh
we're going to uh we literally couldn't
keep up and so there was no like
positive coolness out of this it wasn't
until like
we were into the you know pandemic and
then like several months and we're like
oh wow this okay well during the
pandemic or more people are gonna play
Chessy we'll die back down nope then
came POG Champs and what do you talk
about and we're like oh my gosh then
okay after that no okay and then came
Queen's Gambit were like all right well
that was definitely the peak and then
the media started writing about Chess
and then okay where is it gonna stop we
have been yeah three you're just getting
in waved after wave after wave and then
there's the stuff in the media now which
is like wave and like we almost can't
even come up the breath fast enough to
recognize this before there's like
another wave coming from this point on
we just don't know what to expect is
there another way of coming probably
foreign
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels
no matter your level everyone could use
a coach download Learn chess with Dr
Wolf for Android or iOS devices today
foreign
have made their way through to division
one of the chess kid cup two players
will also join noribbeck abdusitara five
minute caruana and hikar Nakamura who
qualified via the chessful master so
Dania two spots Remain the players they
will have to choose their color it's
going to be very intense so let's let
everybody know what the tiebrec format
is because well it's not going to be
easy for the players to make their bids
as they choose they bid for the right to
choose color the lower bid wins and
starts with that amount of time the
opponent starts with 10 minutes no
increment no time added per move and
black wins the match with a draw or win
so my first question for you Dania is
how low would you go
how low would I go well we've seen some
crazy bids throughout the months and
years Robert particularly with us
experienced players I would not go any
lower than seven minutes and that is
because of that second to last bullet
point no time added per move that is in
contrast to the time controlled during
the Swiss and layoff portion which is
ten plus two here flagging is very much
on the table so if you start with five
and a half or six minutes yeah congrats
you've got the draw odds but
unless you're Hikaru Nakamura uh or
Magnus Carlson you're just not going to
make it happen and that factors into
white strategy during Armageddon you
have to play for the clock you have to
keep the clock times in mind and you
have to not hesitate to go into a
quote-unquote drawn end game if you
believe that you can milk your
opponent's clock down a zero yeah
he bid seven minutes about against Pablo
pankratov in the chess.com Global
Championship back in 2022 he regretted
that decision so as you said you cannot
bid too little time you need time
remaining there is no time added per
move so you have to be quick and you
have to start with a good amount on the
clock
you do and of course it's a matter of
preference there's no right answer
at some point we know a lot of players
if they want to play White you basically
bid 10 minutes right or you bid
something like 9 30 which would make it
very worth it to play Black at the end
of the day I think Armageddon is very
fair I think it's an elegant system of
deciding a winner and it's a shame we
didn't see an armor getting in the world
championship but we're gonna see two of
them now
I don't think dingley Wren considers it
a shame he was happy to win he made the
brave choice of putting his Rook on G6
so we will know the players with the
white pieces and how much time the
players with black have I'm looking at
it the producers are telling us that Ali
Reza faruja he bid 7 minutes and 10
seconds
8 minutes and 33. so alireza he gets the
black pieces with only 7 minutes and 10
seconds that is the absolute lowest I
would go as I said seven to ten he
really believes that he's the faster
player he's definitely the faster player
in terms of Blitz context so when
Armageddon I think for the black side
very important to get a good position
from the opening some players
particularly ones who bid on the lower
end they overcompensate they play too
quickly and then in the blink of an eye
their dead lost who cares about all the
extra time if you're simply lost so if
you're on the black side you don't have
to get obsessed with playing fast it's
okay to spend a minute on the first 10
moves you've got to get the kind of
position that's easy to play fast
yeah and we have word that Alexander
shimanov he bid 7 minutes and 23 seconds
Karel Chef shank up at 7 59 so shimanov
will get the black pieces and draws with
7 23. so the games they are about to get
underway let's hopefully get them up as
the players all is on the line it's you
win this match you get into division one
if you do not win you still get to play
in division two so it's not the worst
consolation prize in the world
absolutely not but here we go there's a
lot of pressure a lot of money on the
line and the games are underway we've
got farrugia with the black pieces in a
draw odd situation against Anton giharo
the Vietnam tone playing and opening
that he feels comfortable with he is
finally White against Ali Reza uh and
what do you make of this position
yeah the position let's bring that up on
camera Donna let's get the game going
yeah when we can and so let's talk about
this one because for alireza farusa he
bid just over seven minutes he's going
to be able to play quickly
yeah he is and uh
Okay so we've got slight Adventure we'll
get that we'll get that game up in just
a moment
yeah no so this looks like
that yeah let's just uh figure this out
sorry everybody we will bring the game
up as soon as we can but these players
have started and this is one game left
this is not a best of two you can't lose
and then come back and you need to do
what you need to do now and the player
with the black pieces well they can draw
the game and count as a win the player
with white they must win
they must win indeed and again it's much
more important to get a good position on
the board than to keep your time
Advantage your time Advantage isn't
going to be good for anything if you've
you relinquish all winning chances and I
actually think that's exactly what David
Antone is doing he's played a little bit
too fast in the opening again we will
get that game up for you as soon as we
possibly can uh but it already looks
like alireza farusha though he's still
down two minutes on the clock has a very
comfortable position
yeah no it's one of those situations
where alireza comfortable and can play
uh just being transparent we are
experiencing some technicians we will
get the game up as soon as we can but
they are playing so you can also go on
chess.com events and try to follow that
yourselves but we would like to bring it
up on screen for all of you we apologize
but Dania this matchup alereza faruza
big favorite against David Anton despite
the effect that davine is almost 2700
rated himself
lost their battle during the Swiss
portion then he was able to hold the
same type of position with the black
pieces in the first game of the Swiss
and the second game of the of the uh
knockout that is uh was also a
relatively uneventful draw so far we're
not missing too much it's a relatively
balanced position I think alirez is off
to a good start he's already Shrunk the
time advantage to a minute
and that's not the biggest surprise
because David Anton he has been playing
deliberately methodically out of the
opening stage and that's likely why oh
there is a figure that he could bid such
a low amount of time seven minutes and
change against 10 minutes he thought
that David will be the first to think
and that he could catch up and I'll
raise him he is a former 2800 and even
though davita's on himself a former 2700
close to that rating him now uh that
farja felt he would be the favorite in
having drawds is huge
indeed and uh
it does look like dividend is trying to
create some chances again uh we are
close to fixing and bringing up the game
but you can follow yourself on chess.com
events right now they're still locked in
a complicated middle game
and uh
yeah
yeah we will get it up as soon as we can
we really sincerely apologize so we are
you know we're looking at it on our own
screens and yeah it's a position where
it's about balance maybe slightly better
for David Anton but uh not huge
happenings just yet
indeed
Okay so
I will pull up the game on my own end as
well
okay here we go still going still early
in the middle game so nothing has been
decided just yet
nope and we would love to get up for you
we will do that shortly again apologize
apologies to everybody but there are 20
moves in uh alvareza fuja has five
minutes and 50 seconds his opponent has
six minutes and 30 seconds remaining so
we will have it up shortly hopefully and
yeah
here we go
oh I'm situation I think we have the
game up the situation on the clock is
now equalized I mean first is still down
40 seconds and we have the game up for
you we're sorry about that thanks for
being patient as you can see you haven't
missed all that much there's still only
on move 21. White's last move was Knight
D2 and black responds by attacking
White's Queen with Rook to E5
whoa an aggressive move by black uh the
queen is under attack you can slide back
to the D3 square but then Black's light
Square Bishop will come back to F5 and a
black kid punched through the move d4 to
D3 that Bishop on A7 it's lurking back
there it will aim all the way to the F2
pawn and that could be dangerous for
white
yeah I mean this is exactly the kind of
position that you want as black and you
don't want to modify your style you want
to play the same way that you would play
in a situation where you didn't need to
win that's exactly how you guarantee
that you play the best chess that you
can play Black is going to double on the
E file like you're saying the pawn on E2
is under serious pressure and it is
being held down forcibly by this Pawn on
D4
yes no that pawn D4 is a thorn in white
side the bishop on G2 does look very
nice for White and the pressure down
that diagonal it's not amounting to all
that much because that pawn on B7 Knight
and C6 they're very stable over here and
look at how quickly alireza is playing
he's better on time he's better on the
board and he only needs a draw
he only needs to draw and Bishop to F3
was apparently a very very bad move now
the eval bar is dipping in Black's favor
do you see a tactic Bishop F5 forcing
the queen away and I think black's
d-pawn might Rumble forward to D3 the
only thing that's stopping that is the
pin that the bishop is exerting on the
pawn to The Rook where is White's Queen
gonna go
it is exactly what I was gonna say the
queen can go to A4 but then you Pawn to
B5 but there might be Bishop takes C6
there's a lot of tactics that we're
gonna analyze but I was gonna say Daniel
that if I'm alireza I don't think I want
those positions even after Queen C5
Bishop C5 Rook takes C5 suddenly white
gets a rook and a bishop for a queen and
you alleviate a lot of the pressure in
your own position the queen is more
valuable but a rook and a bishop are two
pieces maybe you can start teaming up on
some of Black's pawns and some of the
squares
indeed and that is exactly what olures
is thinking about and that's a blessing
in disguise where to be downtown because
again he is coming up ahead on the clock
if you're just joining there is no
increment in the Armageddon games so
uh as alireza thinks about his move I
think we should check in to our other
Armageddon game we have another one
folks between shishenko and shimanov and
look at the crazy position that they've
got on the board
oh my goodness it looks like literal
Armageddon like the end of the world is
coming throwing everything they can to
the other person maybe is wipe down I
feel like white should be down a piece
here for the attack against the black
king but I'm looking and white is not
even down a pawn
what and I was looking and I was going
through the exact same process surely
white sacrificed a minor piece I keep
counting three minor pieces for each
side now two minor pieces for each side
now white is down upon
but that is you know like buying Apple
stock for 50 cents a share this is this
is a steal and he might even steal the
D3 Pawn Yeah that pawn is going to be
won the black king is probably gonna
have to Castle kingside and then that E6
Pawn will remain that's it past Pawn
that's far Advanced so I love this
position for a crucial and you look at
the clocks white needs to win this game
white has a healthy Pawn that is sitting
on E6 and is ahead by nearly a minute
and a half on time
and no matter how good of a Defender you
are you're basically going to have to
spend at least 15 20 seconds per move
here to sidestep all of the hot coals
that you're walking on if black plays
Bishop E7 you have to assess Bishop
takes H6 and queen H5 Chuck now shimanov
is falling behind very heavily on the
clock as well unless he finds a way to
stabilize the position first and
foremost and I think he's doing the
right thing Robert because you have to
try to get a good position first then
you can start playing fast but what good
position taking on D3 now material is
even the Knight on F5 is under attack
you could play the move G6 but then
white just plays Bishop B2 that connects
the Rook C6 will be targeted once a rook
gets to C1 I feel like everything in
this position is going well for crucial
and have I mentioned that he has a pass
Pawn on E6 that's difficult to attack
and pretty easy to defend
no this is the position is essentially
plays itself and it's important to point
out that White's Advantage does not
contingent on Black's King being stuck
in the center even if black manages to
get the king to relative safety look at
these Queen side pawns white can just go
Rook C1 Queen takes D5 will be a threat
I don't love Bishop B2 precisely because
he walked into Knight C4 and has allowed
Black's Bishop to come out to D6 that
was a very sloppy move by Krill I think
Alexander now has a chance he does
because he gets that development in but
I don't think one player has a chance
and that is David Anton let's go back to
that game if we can because it looks
like alireza farouza he's not just going
to get the draw that he needs he's
winning a game Rook takes and he's
winning on the spot
Supple threat you can't do anything and
there's a back ranked Checkmate against
the white king
what's he thinking about
what's he thinking about just take honey
too and the D3 is coming at the end of
the line done it no it's over it's
White's turn
oh crap I'm sorry Grandmaster
no but okay but you're building the
point is coming there's nothing to think
about for white either because Rook
takes E2 is Unstoppable I apologize that
was my mistake it's a long day folks
please uh hold your pitchforks I didn't
see whose clock was ticking of course it
can be hard to determine that but it's a
moot point and that tells you all you
need to know about this position even
with white to move he simply cannot
defend E2 and if you play E3 which is an
old resource black can just play Ponte
xc3 can't take the Rook because the pawn
takes on F2 Black's Bishop on A7 is the
unsung hero of this entire Construction
yeah this is just dead right now and
actually resigned so I'll do this makes
it through to the chess kid cup he will
be in division one and for David Anton
it was an unfortunate ending but he will
be in division two alongside many super
Grand Masters and top players so alireza
he earned it he gets back to division
one
and let's go to the other game because
it's still going it's heating up it
looks like kiril shivchenko might have
lost the line Sheriff's Advantage what
has he done what has he done in this
position to allow black skin to go Queen
side and to allow black to develop a
massive attack on White's gang no way
yeah and it looks like the last one
played by black somehow was an
inaccuracy but I don't really see why
the queen was on C7 it went over to D7
but maybe there was a move that led to
almost a win for black at that point
incredible but still it looks very good
the time situation is looking better
than ever White's time Advantage has
dwindled to only 30 seconds but that's a
total moot point still plenty of time
for both sides how is white going to
untangle these pieces from black side of
the board now shimanov is threatening to
move his Bishop just about anywhere
particularly F6 and that is why he
played Queen D7 so that White's Queen
could not escape with check I think it's
a very smart move yeah and if you play
uh here for black queen G4 is a pretty
deadly threat Bishop D6 or Bishop F6
because the bishop on G7 is in trouble I
think Queen H6 is the move I play you're
hitting the C6 Pawn so let's not forget
that the black king is in some danger so
I would start with Queen to H6 and then
I would figure out the rest later but
what I'm worried about Donna is karil is
now down to two and a half minutes he's
spending too much time
way too much time Queen H6 has been
found
he stays in the game and 96 just
throwing all of his pieces into black
side of the board but these pieces have
no anchor squares they're all suspended
in midair
stuck in molasses I think Shimano needs
a couple more accurate moves though and
whatever he does do not give away your
C6 spawn do not allow some sort of
lateral combination which smokes the
bishop out of D6 yeah also it looks like
Rook takes E6 Rook E6 Queen takes G7
because G2 is threatened with Checkmate
but the issue for black bear is the
White Queen will stay on the board back
to H3 and the black king isn't the
safest piece so in must win territory I
know the evaluation Bar says black is
favored and we can't deny that but there
are good chances for white
and I think shimanov probably saw Rook
takes C6 but decided to refrain from
that move to get a position that's a bit
easier to play and rookie seven is
another very ingenious move because if
White's Bishop moves away then The Rook
swings over to H7 and white loses on the
spot because H2 is going to be dropped
with a devastating series of discoveries
to follow what about Knight of Fate he
plays it as soon as they ask it the grip
is in The Bishop's path the queen is
under attack and now there are all sorts
of tactics not to mention the Rook on G8
it is trapped over there so if it gets a
tackle or Rook takes E7 you have to
watch out for a queen E6 check the Rook
could be lost if you're not looking for
it
Knight f8 as he's consorting himself to
keep his minor pieces alive and this is
what I mentioned if Queen F5 white takes
on E7 so easy to forget about White's
Queen going back to E6 and queen E8 but
Shimano and apparently that was a
mistake and is it because of her Rook
takes Rook or is there a crazy tactic no
Rook takes rook and Knight back from f8
to E6 and all of White's pieces suddenly
are defended and by the way Donya let's
do a material count white is up a pawn
and White's got three connected passers
on the king side it's crazy to think
about them as past pawns but that's
exactly what they are and once the
Knight drops back to E6 that F bond is
gonna Rumble up the board but this game
might very well be decided on the clock
because at this point hero is down 15
seconds and he's got to be perfect
he has no increment so he needs to move
and shimanov started this game with 7
minutes and 23 seconds to shipchenko's
10 and suddenly shimanov with the lead
in the clock because there's so much
pressure on white to win but he's got a
move done and he cannot keep thinking
here
and he cannot forget that there is no
increment we have seen players lose
Armageddon games because In the Heat of
the Moment they forget that they don't
get a Time Edition per move 96 found now
he's gotta keep going the night is
attacked again where is it gonna go it
moves back to D4 wax Queen protects C6 I
think shimanov has the edge here with 40
extra seconds on the clock and no
Clarity in the position at all here
comes H4 H5 H6 H7 and guess what h8
equals Queen so the Knight comes to F5
Bishop 55.
oh no I guess 97 check oh yes
does he see it wait there's also rookie
one because if Bishop takes G7 there's
Knight E7 check
but there might be Rook takes G7 and 48
seconds now for Corel his panicking he
goes for B1
where is the attack for white that's the
big question oh I think Bishop G7 it
still have an 87 check in fact I think
he's setting that one up
tactics
Rook G7 I just take and you have to take
with the bishop and then the H spawn I'm
just throwing that of the word H4 H5 H6
go
yeah and he's 30 seconds down but the
redeeming factor is that this is so much
easier to play for white all you have to
do is push your pawn and respond to
threats against your queen that's
literally it and already shimanov is
halved his material his time Advantage
now both sides under a minute and here
come the pass Pawns
and watch out Queen A6 check okay that's
why I blocked the B file but look at
this black is split black has to stop to
pass pawn and stop checkmating attacks
win A6 check could come at the most
inconvenient moment White's Rook could
swing to the open file but Black's pawns
are rumbling forward on their own and
here comes white spawn that's why he
tries to combine threats on the queen
side and the King side I love it from
Queen G6 now like this queen F3 watch
out A5 Queen a check there's all sorts
of mating Nets that black kids be
careful about
and queen G4 check was forking the
bishop of blackhead Queen G7 both sides
down to 30 minutes this is gonna be a
wild time scramble a draw wins the game
for black
okay but A5 at some point oh gosh both
are scary C3 oh there was Rook B5 there
there was Queenie check and Rook B5 that
was overlooked by white but that's
really hard to find and it was
overlooked again and now black spawns
are almost at the Gates of Heaven but so
are White's pawns what is the win here
Queen oh queen queen
oh my gosh she blundered it again again
he found it
he's gonna win
oh my goshenko turns it around
and you see it on shimano's face he
cannot believe it and the reason this is
winning is his check you have to take
the queen and the H1 promotes now he
goes Queen C4 takes C2 and he's up on
time and up a queen that was completely
unnecessary could have gone Queen C4
check but it's completely winning as
long as he doesn't blunder his Queen
yes or he doesn't lose on time but he is
the one ahead on the clock
way 96 oh okay now it's
yep just put his Queen in a light square
that is brilliant bullet technique
yeah this is great I mean he's a 3000
plus bullet player unless he still meets
the king
okay no way no way not here not today
look at that look at that he is in the
dark but his chest is a bright light on
the world he wins this game he moves on
to the chess kid cup division one wow
Daniel that was exciting what an
unbelievable end to that game carrill
started off with a blistering attack he
was dead winning he gave Black's King a
chance to move to safety it looked like
the opposite was gonna happen and then
kiril found it in himself less time bad
position pieces dangling everything
collapsing and yet he generates just
enough counter play to take home the
game
that was an unbelievable finish and I
think for shimanov he can't believe it
either he was doing so well objectively
speaking he was ahead on the clock he
had two pieces for Rook but his King was
less safe and done it you're an absolute
monster you're often number one in the
Blitz and bullet leaderboard than
chess.com it just goes to show how
King's safety is Paramount it's
Paramount and it's often more important
than the objective evaluation that's why
you can't pay attention to the eval bar
when you have a time scramble as we look
at the final results from the division
one matches we have valireza ferrugia
who defeats to be it on tone in style
with black he needed a draw he got a win
and kiril shivchenko he survived so much
he survived an endgame in game one he
survived a near loss in game two and he
survives at one point a lost position in
the Armageddon game to take home the
ticket for division one
yeah farouza kolars and chefchenko they
earned their way through but two players
who had maybe a little bit less
difficulty I guess kolars he won in two
games as well but these two super Grand
Masters Anish giri and Lavon aronian
they also were able to secure placement
in division one of the chess kid cup
Geary wins two nil levada Ronin one half
half he won game one and then game two
was in no danger of losing whatsoever so
Dania we now know the five players who
are joining Hikaru Nakamura Fabiano
caruana and nodier back Abdul sitarov
and I believe all of them are very
deserving what an Eclectic field it's
going to be we've got some of the
Mainstays we've got the super GMS we
also have a golden opportunity for
Dimitri kolars right who
know how hungry these younger players
the lower rated players are to exploit
the opportunity that they have they're
not just there to lose a couple of games
and learn they're there to score some
upsets they're there to shake out shake
up the tournament standings and I am so
excited to see how colors and how I'm
just a tour of and how the younger
players are going to deal with Hikaru
Nakamura in the Mainstays yeah kolars he
played a nice match there against Jean
moussard and let's not forget that
musard picked kolars and let's not
forget that Jordan van Forest picked
Anish giri now his two options were
Anish giri and Dimitri on draken you
just toss a coin at that point but I
think any scary took that personally he
beat his compatriot and his friend and
someone he's worked on chess with but
Geary was mad and he won 2-0 so he joins
kolars he joins chefchenko for ruja wins
an Armageddon and levonne aronina maybe
the most impressive player of the day
indeed as we look at the final field for
the chess get cup which will be coming
our way on May 22nd it ends on May 26th
so mark your calendar uh it'll be
broadcasted from the Oslo Studios and
what an amazing playing field we have
Hikaru Nakamura of course is the top
seed but he will have a big red X on his
back as Dmitry collars levonne Ronin and
other players who survive today will try
to make their presence felt and make
their Mark in this third CCT event
wow what a field that is there are no
easy customers you even look at Dimitri
kolars that's his it must be his
chest.com rapid rating careers of
Chico's rating it's too low I looked at
it before today's event it was in the
2400s he just doesn't play that much in
online rapid chess but his fide
classical rating is near 2700. this is a
brutally strong field if you are Hikaru
if you're Fabiano if you're no dearbeck
you did not want to see these players
make it through you want an easier time
of it you were hoping that some others
made it into division one but farouja
aronian Geary chefchenko and kolars oh
that is going to be a fun chess kid cup
it is indeed I'm so looking forward to
covering it
and I was looking forward to covering
today and it most certainly did not
disappoint it never seems to disappoint
no it doesn't because when you have
about 150 super strong players most of
them being Grand Masters play in a nine
round Swiss and then it gets whittled
down and the rest get to play matches I
mean this is what the Chess World needs
I feel it's so exciting and for players
like Dimitri kolars I want to give him a
special shout out they often don't get
the opportunities to play in the biggest
events because they're small round
Robins they're very selective and their
Rays aren't quite high enough but he has
proven that he belongs in an event with
all the best players he gets to play in
division one in the chess kid cup so
Daniel it's a great opportunity for him
he secures a really nice payday and
maybe he'll make some of those bigger
names pay when he face them across the
board well he knows who he's going to
face he's got a couple of weeks to
prepare and first and foremost he has to
recover from this Marathon session that
he played today and I won't lie so do I
this was an incredible pleasure to cover
these six seven hours they fly by so
quickly and I can't wait to see how
these newcomers fare against the likes
of and other monsters when push comes to
shove
it promises to be an exciting Third Leg
of the Champions chess tour I want to
thank all of you for tuning in for
staying with us for all these hours it's
been really fun I want to thank the
players because without these events
certainly not possible Donna of course I
have to give you a nod it's always great
to commentate with you it's been a while
our producers everybody working behind
the scenes thank you so much and well
the chess kid cup will be May 22nd to
26th but up next is the OES
preliminaries that happens Thursday and
Friday of this week so if you want more
chess tuned right back in here chess.com
continues to cover all of the biggest
and best events but for now we say
goodbye and have a good rest of your day
[Music]
thank you
foreign